Odin
the highest and the oldest of all the
gods is Odin
Odin knows many Secrets he gave an eye
for wisdom
more than that for knowledge of runes
and for power he sacrificed himself to
himself
he hung from the world tree igtrazzle
hung there for nine nights
his side was pierced by the point of a
spear which wounded him Gravely
the winds clutched at him buffeted his
body as it hung
nothing did he eat for nine days or nine
nights nothing did he drink
he was alone there in pain
impact the light of his life slowly
going out
he was cold in agony and on the point of
death when his sacrifice bore dark fruit
in the Ecstasy of his Agony he looked
down and the runes were revealed to him
he knew them and understood them and
their power
the Rope broke them and he fell
screaming from the tree
now he understood Magic
now the world was his to control
Odin has many names
he is the all father the lord of the
slain The Gallows God
he is the god of cargos and a prisoners
he is called grimnier and third
he has different names in every country
for he is worshiped in different forms
and in many tongues but it is always
Odin they worship
he travels from place to place in
Disguise to see the world as people see
it when he walks Among Us he does so as
a tall man wearing a cloak and hat he
has two Ravens whom he calls hugin and
moon in
which means thought and memory
these birds fly back and forth across
the world seeking news and bringing Odin
all the knowledge of things
they perch on his shoulders and Whisper
into his ears
when he sits on his High Throne at
halitzkelf he observes all things
wherever they may be nothing can be
hidden from him
he brought War into the World battles
are begun by throwing a spear at the
Hostile Army dedicating the battle and
its deaths to Odin
if you survive in battle it is with
Odin's Grace
and if you fall it is because he has
betrayed you
if you fall bravely in war the Valkyries
beautiful battle mavens who collect the
souls of the noble dead will take you
and bring you to the hall known as
Valhalla
he will be waiting for you in Valhalla
and there you will drink and fight and
feast and battle
with Odin as your leader
Thor
Thor Odin's son
is the thunderer
he is straightforward where his father
Odin is cunning good-natured where his
father is Devious
huge he is and red bearded and Strong by
far the strongest of all the gods his
might is increased by his belt of
strength Megan girth when he wears it
his strength is doubled
Thor's weapon is mjolnir a remarkable
Hammer forged for him by Dwarfs
its story you will learn
trolls and frost Giants and Mountain
Giants all tremble when they see mjolnir
for it has killed so many of their
brothers and Friends Thor wears iron
gloves which help him to grip the
Hammer's shaft
Thor's mother was youth the Earth
goddess
Thor's Sons amorthy the angry and magni
the strong
Thor's Daughter his throat the powerful
his wife is Sif of the golden hair
she had a son uller before she married
Thor and Thor is Allah's stepfather
is a God who hunts with bow and with
arrows and he is the god with skis
Thor is the defender of Asgard and of
midgar
there are many stories about Thor and
his adventures
you will encounter some of them here
Loki
Loki is very handsome
he is plausible convincing likable and
Far and Away the most Wily subtle and
shrewd of all the inhabitants of Asgard
it is a Pity then that there is so much
Darkness inside him
so much anger so much Envy so much lust
Loki is the son of loyvee who was also
known as null or needle because she was
slim and beautiful and sharp
his father was said to be faboti a giant
his name means he who strikes dangerous
blows and farbati was as dangerous as
his name
Loki walks in the sky with shoes that
fly and he can transform his shape so he
looks like other people or changing to
animal form
but his real weapon is his mind
he is more cunning subtler trickier than
any God or giant not even Odin is as
cunning as Loki
Loki is Odin's Blood Brother
the other gods do not know when Loki
came to Asgard or how
he is Thor's friend and Thor's betrayer
he is tolerated by the gods perhaps
because his stratagems and plans save
them as often as they get them into
trouble
Loki makes the world more interesting
but less safe
he is the father of Monsters the author
of wolves
Sly God
Loki drinks too much and he cannot guard
his words or his thoughts or his deeds
when he drinks Loki and his children
will be there for Ragnarok the end of
everything
and it will not be on the side of the
Gods of Asgard that they will fight
before the beginning and after
one
before the beginning there was nothing
no Earth no Heavens no stars no Sky only
the Mist world formless and shapeless
and the fire World always burning
to the north was nettleham
the Dark World
here 11 poisonous Rivers cut through the
Mist each springing from the same well
at the center of it all the Roaring
Maelstrom called havaragomir
was colder than cold and the murky Mist
that cloaked everything hung heavily the
skies were hidden by mist and the ground
was clouded by the chilly fog
to the South was moospel
moosepel was fire
everything there glowed and burned
moosepel was light when niflehem was
gray molten lava where the Mist world
was frozen
the land was a flame with the Roaring
heat to the blacksmith's fire there was
no solid earth no Sky nothing but Sparks
and spurting heat molten rocks and
burning embers
at the edge of the flame where the Mist
burns into light where the land ends
stood Sutter who existed before the Gods
he stands there now
he holds a flaming Sword and the
bubbling lava and the freezing Mist are
as wanting
it is said that at Ragnarok which is the
end of the world
and only then certara will leave his
station
he will go forth from moospel with his
flaming sword and burn the world with
fire and one by one the gods will fall
before him
two
between musbel and nifflehead was avoid
an empty place of nothingness without
form
the rivers of the Mist World flowed into
the void which was called ginungagap
the yawning Gap
over time beyond measure these poison
rivers in the region between fire and
Mist slowly solidified into huge
glaciers
the ice in the north of the Void was
covered in Frozen fog and pellets of
hail that to the South where the
glaciers reached the land of fire The
Embers and the Sparks from muspel met
the ice and Warm Winds from the flame
lands made the air above the ice as
gentle and as comfortable as a spring
day
wear the ice and the fire met the ice
melted and in the melting Waters life
appeared the likeness of a person bigger
than worlds huger than any giant there
will be or has ever been
this was neither male nor was it female
but was both at the same time
this creature was the ancestor of all
the Giants and it called itself emir
Emir was not the only living thing to be
formed by the melting of the ice
there was also a hornless cow more
enormous than the mind could hold
she licked the salty blocks of ice for
food and for drink and the milk that ran
from her four others flowed like Rivers
it was this milk that nourished emu
the giant drank the milk and grew
Emir called the cow aldumblr
the cow's pink tongue licked people from
the blocks of ice the first day only a
man's hair the second his head and the
third day the shape of a whole man was
revealed
this was Buri the ancestor of the Gods
Emir slept and while it slept it gave
birth
a male and a female giant were born from
beneath emir's left arm a six-headed
giant born from its legs from these
emir's children all Giants are descended
Buri took a wife from among these Giants
and they had a son whom they called boar
boar married besla daughter of a giant
and together they have three sons Odin
vili and they
Odin and Villi and vay the three sons of
boar grew into manhood
they saw as they grew far off the Flames
of moosepel and the Darkness of
nipplehem but they knew that each place
would be death to them the brothers were
trapped forever in gingonga gap the vast
gap between the fire and the Mist they
might as well have been nowhere
there was no sea and no sand no grass
nor rocks no soil no trees no Sky no
stars there was no world no heaven and
no Earth at that time
the Gap was nowhere only an empty place
waiting to be filled with life and with
existence
it was time for the creation of
everything
they and Billy and Odin looked at each
other and spoke of what was needful to
do bear in the void of ganunga Gap
they spoke of the universe and of life
and of the future
Odin and Billy and they
killed the giant email
it had to be done
there was no other way to make the
worlds this was the beginning of all
things the death that made all life
possible
they stabbed the great Giant
blood gushed out from emir's Corpse in
unimaginable quantities Fountains of
blood as salt as the sea and gray as the
oceans gushed out in a flood so sudden
so powerful and so deep that it swept
away and drowned all the Giants
only one giant Bagel me emir's grandson
and his wife survived by clambering onto
a wooden box which bore them like a boat
all the Giants we see and we fear today
are descended from them
Odin and his brothers made the soil from
emir's flesh emir's bones they piled up
into mountains and cliffs
our rocks and Pebbles the sand and
gravel you see these were emir's teeth
the fragments and bones that were broken
and crushed by Odin and daily and they
in their battle Within
the Seas that girdle the worlds
these were emir's blood and it swept
look up into the sky
you were looking at the inside of
email's skull the Stars you see at night
the planets all the comets and the
shooting stars these are the Sparks that
flew from the fires of muspel
and the clouds you see by day
these were once image brains and who
knows what thoughts they are thinking
even now
three
the world is a flat disc and the Sea
encircles the perimeter
giants live at the edges of the world
beside the deepest Seas
to keep the Giants at Bay Odin and vili
and they made a wall from emir's
eyelashes and set it around the middle
of the world
they called the place within the wall
midgard
midgard was empty the Lambs were
beautiful but nobody walked The Meadows
or fished in the clear waters nobody
explored the Rocky Mountains or stared
up at the clouds
Odin and Billy and they knew that a
world is not a world until it is
inhabited they wandered high and low
looking for people and they found
nothing
at last on the rocky shingle at the edge
of the sea they found two logs sea
tossed that had floated there on the
tides and been cast ashore
a slog was a log of Ashwood
the ash tree is resilient and handsome
and its roots go deep it's wood carves
well and will not split or crack Ashwood
makes a good tool handle but the shaft
of a spear
the second log they found beside the
first on the beach so close to the first
log they were almost touching was a log
of Elmwood
the elm tree is graceful but its wood is
hard enough to be made into the toughest
planks and beams
you can build a fine home or a hall from
Elmwood
the gods took the two logs they set the
logs so they were upright on the sand at
the height to people
Odin held them and one by one he
breathed life into them
no longer were they dead logs on a beach
now they were alive
Philly gave them a will he gave them
intelligence and drive now they could
move and they could want
they carved the logs he gave them the
shape of people he carved their ears
that they might hear and their eyes that
they might see and lips that they might
speak
the two logs stood on the beach two
naked people
they had carved one with male genitals
the other handcuffed female
the three brothers made clothes for the
woman and the man to cover themselves
and to keep them warm in the chilly sea
spray on the beach at the edge of the
world
last of all they gave the two people
they had made names
the man they called ask or ash tree
the woman they called embla or Elm
ask and embla were the father and the
mother of all of us every human being
owes its life to its parents and their
parents and their parents before them go
far enough back and the ancestors of
each of us
will ask and then blood
embla and ask stayed in midgard safe
behind the wall the gods had made from
emir's eyelashes
in mid God they would make their homes
protected from Giants and monsters and
all the dangers that wait in the wastes
in midgard they could raise their
children in peace
that is why Odin is called the all
father
because he was the father of the Gods
and because he breathed the breath of
life into our grandparents grandparents
grandparents
parents whether we are gods or Mortals
Odin is the father of a soul
igtrassel and the nine worlds
the ash tree igrasov is a mighty ash
tree the most perfect and beautiful of
all trees also the largest
it grows between the nine worlds and
joins them each to each it is the
biggest of all the trees there are and
the finest the tops of its branches are
above the sky
it is so large that the roots of the ash
are in three worlds and it is fed by
three Wells
the first route and the deepest goes
into the underworld to nettleham the
place that existed before other places
in the center of the Dark World is the
ever churning Springer so loud it sounds
like a roaring kettle
the Dragon nidhog lives in these Waters
and it is always gnawing at the root
from Below
the second route goes to the realm of
the frost Giants to the well that
belongs to mimir
there is an eagle who Waits at the
highest branches of the world tree and
who knows many things and a hawk who
perches between the Eagle's eyes
a squirrel ratatosk lives in the
branches of the world tree
it takes gossip and messages from nidhog
The Dread Corp seater to the eagle and
Back Again
the squirrel tells lies to both of them
and takes joy in provoking anger
there are four Stags who graze on the
huge branches of the world tree
devouring the foliage in the bark
there are uncountable snakes at the base
of the tree biting at the roots
the world tree can be climbed
it is from this tree that Odin hanged
himself in sacrifice making the world
tree a Gallows and himself The Gallows
God
the gods do not climb the world's tree
they travel between the worlds using
bifrost the Rainbow Bridge
only the gods can travel on the rainbow
it would burn the feet of any Frost
Giants or trolls who attempted to
clamber up it to reach Asgard
these are the nine worlds
Asgard the home of the Acer this is
where Odin makes his home
alfame
for the light elves live
the light elves are as beautiful as the
Sun or the Stars
nether Valley which is sometimes called
svartel Fame where the Dwarfs who are
also known as dark elves live beneath
the mountains and build their remarkable
creations
midgard which is the world of women and
men the world in which we make our home
yotenheim for the frost Giants and the
mountain Giants wander and live
and have their Halls
vanahang
where the Vania lived the Acer and the
Vania are Gods United by peace treaties
and many Vania gods live in Asgard with
the Asia
niflame the dark missed world
moosepel the world of flame where certra
awaits
and there is the place named after its
ruler
hell
where the dead girl who did not die
bravely in battle
the last root of the world tree goes to
a spring in the home of the Gods to
Asgard where the Acer make their home
each day the gods hold their counsel
here and it is here they will gather in
the last days of the world before they
set out for the final battle of Ragnarok
it is called The Well of uran
there are three sisters the norns who
are wise maidens they tend the well and
make sure that the roots of ictrasal are
covered with mud and cared for
the well belongs to UD
she is faked destiny
she is your past
with her a birth family
her name means becoming and hers is the
present
and school
whose name means that which is intended
and her domain is the future
the norns will decide what happens in
your life
there are other Norms not just those
three
Giant norns and elf norns dwarf norns
and Vania Norms good norms and bad and
what your fate will be is decided by
them
some Norms give people good lives
and others give us hard lives or short
lives
Twisted lives
they will shape your fate
Bearer towards well
head and Odin's eye
in yotenheim the home of the Giants is
Mimi as well
bubbles up from deep in the ground and
it feeds igtrassel the world tree
Mimi the Wise One the guardian of memory
knows many things
his well is wisdom and when the world
was young he would drink every morning
from the well by dipping the horn known
as the gyalahorn into the water and
draining it
long long ago when the worlds were young
Odin put on his long cloak and his hat
and in the guise of a Wanderer he
traveled through the Land of the Giants
risking his life to get to mimir
to seek wisdom
one drink from the water of your well
uncle mimir
said Odin that is all I ask for
me shook his head
nobody drank from the well but mime
himself
he said nothing
seldom to those who are silent make
mistakes
I am your nephew
said Odin my mother Besler was your
sister
that is not enough
said Mimi
one drink with a drink from your well
Mimi I will be wise
name your price
your eye is my price said me man your
eye in the pool
Odin did not ask if he was joking
the journey through giant country to get
to Mimi as well had been long and
dangerous Odin had been willing to risk
his life to get there he was willing to
do more than that for the wisdom he
sought
Odin's face was set
give me a knife
was all he said
after he had done what was needful he
placed his eye carefully in the pool
it stared up at him through the water
Odin filled the gyllaborn with water
from mimir's pool
and he lifted it to his lips
the water was cold
he drained it down
wisdom flooded into him
he saw farther and more clearly with his
one eye than he ever had with two
thereafter Odin was given other names
blender they called him the blind God
and Hower the one-eyed and the bow leg
the Flaming eyed one
Odin's eye remained Mimi as well
preserved By the Waters that feed the
world Ash seeing nothing
seeing everything
time passed
when the war between the Acer and the
Vernier was ending and they were
exchanging Warriors and Chiefs Odin sent
mimir to the vanir as an advisor to the
Acer God heineer who would be the new
chief of the Vania
heiner was tall and good looking and he
looked like a king
when mimer was with him to advise him
Heine also spoke like a king and made
wise decisions
but when mimeo was not with him heiner
seemed unable to come to a decision and
the Vania soon tired of this
they took their Revenge not on Jaime but
on Mimi
they cut off Mimi's head and sent it to
Odin
Odin was not angry
he rubbed meme's head with certain herbs
to prevent it from rotting and he
chanted charms and incantations over it
for he did not wish Mimi's knowledge to
be lost
soon enough Nima opened his eyes and
spoke to him meme's advice was good
as it was always good
Odin took Mimi's head back to the well
beneath the world tree and he placed it
there beside his eye in the waters of
knowledge of the future and of the past
Odin gave the girl to Handel Watchman of
the Gods on the day the gyalahorn is
blown it will wake the gods no matter
where they are no matter how deeply they
sleep
heimdel will blow the gyalarhorn only
once at the end of all things
at Ragnarok
the Treasures of the Gods
one
Thor's wife was the beautiful Sith
she was of the Acer
Thor loved her for herself and for her
blue eyes and her pale skin her red lips
and her smile and he loved her long long
hair the color of a field of barley at
the end of summer
still awoke
stared at sleeping Sith
scratched his beard
then he tapped his wife with a huge hand
what happened to you
he asked
she opened her eyes the color of the
summer sky
what are you talking about she asked
and then she moved her head and looked
puzzled
her fingers reached up to her bare pink
scalp
and touched it exploring it tentatively
she looked at Thor horrified
my hair
was all she said
Thor nodded
it's gone
he said
he has left you bald
asked Seth
fella said nothing
he strapped on his belt of power Megan
girth which doubled his enormous
strength
Loki he said Loki has done this
why do you say that said Sif touching
her bald head frantically as if the
fluttering Touch of her fingers would
make her hair return
because
said Thor when something goes wrong the
first thing I always think is it is
Loki's fault it saves a lot of time
Thor found Loki's door locked so he
pushed through it leaving it in pieces
picked Loki up and said only
why
why what
Loki's face was the picture of perfect
innocence
my wife's golden hair it was so
beautiful why did you cut it off
a hundred Expressions chased each other
across Loki's face cunning and
shiftiness truculence and confusion
Thor shook Loki hard Loki looked down
and did his best to appear ashamed
it was funny
I was drunk
Thor's brow lowered
sif's hair was her glory people would
think that her head was shaved for
punishment that she did something she
should not have done did it with someone
she should not have
well yes there is that
said Loki they will probably think that
and unfortunately given that I took her
hair from the roots she will go through
the rest of her life completely bald
no she won't
Thor looked up at Loki whom he was now
holding far above his head for the face
like thunder
I am afraid she will but there are
always hats and scarves
she won't go through life bald said Thor
because Loki loyfe's son if you do not
put her hair back right now I am going
to break every single bone in your body
each and every one of them and if her
hair does not grow properly I will come
back and break every bone in your body
again
and again
if I do it every day I'll soon get
really good at it he carried on sounding
slightly more cheerful no said Loki I
can't put her hair back it doesn't work
like that
today
mused Thor it will probably take me
about an hour to break every bone in
your body but I bet that with practice I
could get it down to about 15 minutes it
will be interesting to find out
he started to break his first bone
Dwarfs
treat Loki
pardon dwarfs they can make anything
they could make golden hair for safe
hair that would bond with her scalp and
grow normally perfect Golden Hair they
could do it I swear they could
then
said Thor you were better go and talk to
them
and he dropped Loki from high above his
head onto the floor
Loki clambered to his feet and hurried
away before Thor could break any more
bones
he put on his shoes that let him travel
through the sky and he went to
svartelfheim where the dwarfs have their
workshops the most ingenious Craftsmen
of them all he decided were the Three
Dwarfs known as the sons of evaldi
Loki went to their underground Forge
hello sons of Vivaldi I have asked
around and people here tell me that
Brock and Atri his brother are the
greatest dwarf Craftsmen there are or
have ever been
said Loki
no
said one of the sons of evaldi it's us
we are the greatest Craftsman there are
sure that Brock and Atri can make
Treasures as good as those you can
lies said the tallest of the sons of
Vivaldi I wouldn't trust those
fumble-fingered incompetence to shoe a
horse
the smallest and the wisest of the sons
of Vivaldi simply Shrugged
whatever they make we could do better
I hear that they've challenged you
said Loki three Treasures the gods of
the Acer will judge who made the best
treasure oh and by the way one of the
treasures you make needs to be hair ever
growing perfect golden hair
we can do that said one of the sons of
Vivaldi
even Loki could barely tell them apart
Loki went across the mountain to see the
dwarf called Brock but the workshop he
shared with his brother Atri
evaldi's sons are making three Treasures
as gifts for the gods of Asgard
said Loki the gods are going to judge
the treasures evaldi's Sons want me to
tell you that they are certain you and
your brother Atri can't make anything as
good as they can they called you uh
fumble fingered incompetence
Brock was no fool
this smells extremely fishy to me Loki
he said are you sure this isn't your
doing
stirring up trouble between Atria and me
and evaldi's boys seems like the sort of
thing you'd do
Loki looked as guileless as he could
which was amazingly Godless
nothing to do with me he said innocently
I just thought you ought to know
and you have no personal stake in this
asked Brock none whatsoever
Brock nodded looked up at Loki
Brock's brother Atri was the great
Craftsman but Brock was the smarter of
the two and the more determined
well then we'll be happy to take on the
sons of evaldi in a test of skill to be
judged by the gods because I have no
doubt that Atri can forge better and
craftier things than evaldi's lot but
let's make this personal Loki eh
what do you have in mind
asked Loki your head
said Brock if we win this contest we get
your head Loki there's lots of things
going on in that head of yours and I
have no doubt that Atri could make a
wonderful device out of it a thinking
machine perhaps
or an Inkwell
Loki kept smiling but he scowled on the
inside
the day had started out so well
still he simply had to ensure that
Atrium Brock lost the contest the gods
would still get six wonderful things
from the dwarfs and Sif would get her
Golden Hair he could do that
he was Loki
of course he said my head no problem
across the mountain the sons of evaldi
were making their Treasures Loki was not
worried about them but he needed to make
sure that Brock and Atri did not could
not possibly
win
Brock and Atri entered the forge
it was dark in there lit by the orange
glow of burning charcoal
Atri took a pigskin from a shelf and
placed it into the forge
keeping this pigskin for something like
this
he said
Brock just nodded
Right Said actually you work the Bellows
Brock just keep pumping them I need this
hot and I need it consistently hot
otherwise it won't work pump pump
Brock began to pump the Bellows sending
a stream of oxygen-rich air into the
heart of the forge heating everything up
he had done it many times before ape
tree watched until he was satisfied that
it would all be to his liking
Atri left to work on his creation
outside the forge as he opened the door
to go out a large black insect flew in
it was not a horse fly and it was not a
deer fly it was bigger than either
it flew in and circled the room in a
malicious way
Brock could hear the sound of eight
trees hammers outside the forge and the
sounds of filing and twisting of shaping
and banging
the large black fly it was the biggest
blackest fly you have ever seen landed
on the back of Brock's hand
both of Brock's hands were on the
Bellows he did not stop pumping to swat
the fly the fly bit broke hard on the
back of the hand
Brock kept bumping
the door opened and Atri came in and
carefully pulled the work from the forge
it appeared to be a huge ball with
bristles of cleaning gold
good work said Atri a fraction of a
degree warmer or cooler and the whole
thing would have been a waste of our
time
good work you too
said Brock
the black fly up on the corner of the
ceiling sieved with resentment and
irritation
Atri took a block of gold and placed it
on the forge
right he said this next one will impress
them when I call start pumping the
Bellows and whatever happens do not slow
down or speed up or stop there's fiddly
work involved
got it said Brock
Atri left the room and began to work
Brock waited until he heard atres call
and he started to pump the bellows
The Black Fly circled the room
thoughtfully then landed on Brock's neck
the insect stepped aside daintily to
avoid a rivulet of sweat for the air was
hot and close in the Forge it bit
Brock's neck as hard as it could
Scarlet blood joined the sweat on
Brock's neck
but the dwarf did not stop pumping
Atri returned he removed a white hot arm
ring from the forge
he dropped it into the stone cooling
pool in the Forge to quench it
there was a cloud of steam as the arm
ring fell into the water the ring cooled
moving rapidly to Orange to Red Hot and
then as it cooled to gold
it's called droope near
said Atri
the dripper that's a funny name for a
ring
said Brock
not for this one
said actually and he explained to Brock
what was so very special about the arm
ring
now said Atri there's something I've had
in mind to make for a very long time now
my master work but it's even trickier
than the other two so what you have to
do is
pump and don't stop pumping
said Brock
that's right said a tree even more than
before do not change your pace or the
whole thing will be ruined
Patriot picked up an Ingot a pig iron
bigger than any Ingot that the black fly
who was Loki had ever seen before and he
hefted it into the forge
he left the room and called out to Brock
to begin pumping
Brock began to pump
and the sound of atri's hammers began as
Atri pulled and shaped and welded and
joined
Loki in fly shape decided that there was
no more time for subtlety adrie's
Masterpiece would be something that
would impress the gods and if the gods
were impressed enough then he would lose
his head
Loki landed between Brock's eyes and
started to bite the dwarf's eyelids the
dwarf continued to pump his eyes
stinging Loki bit deeper harder more
desperately now blood rammed from the
dwarf's eyelids into his eyes and down
his face blinding him
Brooke squinted and shook his head
trying to dislodge the fly he jerked his
head from side to side he contorted his
mouth and tried blowing air up at the
fly
it was no good the fly continued to bite
and the dwarf could see nothing but
blood a sharp pain filled his head Brock
counted and at the bottom of the
downstroke he whipped one hand from the
Bellows and swiped at the fly with such
speed and such strength that Loki barely
escaped with his life
Brock grabbed the Bellows once again and
continued to pump enough
called Atri
The Black Fly flew unsteadily about the
room
Atri opened the door allowing the fly to
escape
Atri looked at his brother with
disappointment Brock's face was a mess
of blood and sweat
I don't know what you were playing at
that time I said eight tree but you came
close to ruining everything the
temperature was all over the place at
the end as it is it's nowhere near as
impressive as I'd hoped we'll just have
to see
Loki in Loki shape
stroll in through the open door
so all ready for the contest he asked
Brock can go to Asgard and present my
gifts to the gods and cut off your head
said Atri I like it best here at my
Forge making things
Brook stared at Loki through swollen
eyelids
I'm looking forward to cutting off your
head
said Brock
it got personal
two
in Asgard
three Gods sat on their Thrones
one-eyed owed in the all father red
bearded Thor of the Thunders and
handsome Frey The Summer's Harvest
they would be the judges
Loki stood before them beside the three
almost identical sons of Vivaldi
Rock
black bearded and brooding was there
alone standing to one side the things he
had brought hidden beneath sheets
so Odin what are we judging
Treasures
said Loki the sons of evaldi have made
gifts for you great Odin and for Thor
and for Frey and so have Atrium Brock it
is up to you to decide which of these
six things is the finest treasure I
myself will show you the gifts made by
the sons of evaldi
he presented Odin with the spear called
gungnir it was a beautiful spear carved
with intricate runes
it will penetrate anything and when you
throw it it will always find its mark
said Loki Odin had but one eye after all
and sometimes his aim could be less than
perfect and just as important an oath
taken on this spear is Unbreakable
Odin hefted the spear
it is very fine
was all he said
and here said Loki proudly is a flowing
head of golden hair made of real gold it
will attach itself to the head of the
person who needs it and grow and behave
in every way as if it were real hair a
hundred thousand strands of gold
I will test it
said Thor uh Sif come here
Sith Rose and came to the front her head
covered
she removed her head scarf the gods
gasped when they saw sith's naked head
bold and pink and then she carefully
placed the dwarf's golden wig on her
head and shook her hair
they watched as the base of the wig
joined itself to her scalp and then Sith
stood in front of them even more radiant
and beautiful than before
impressive said Thor good job
Sif tossed her golden hair and walked
out of the hall into the sunlight to
show her new hair to her friends
the last of the sons of evaldi's
remarkable gifts was small and folded
like cloth
this cloth Loki placed in front of Frey
what is it
it looks like a silk scarf
said Frey unimpressed
it does
said Loki but if you unfold it you will
Discover it is a ship called skith
blaffner
it will always have a fair wind wherever
it goes and although it is huge the
biggest ship you can imagine it will
fold up as you see like a cloth so you
can put it into your pouch
Frey was impressed
and Loki was relieved
there were three excellent gifts
now it was Brock's turn
his eyelids were red and swollen and
there was a huge insect bite on the side
of his neck
Loki thought Brock looked entirely too
cocky especially given the remarkable
things of Aldi's Sons had made
Brock took the Golden Arm ring and
placed it in front of Odin on his High
Throne
this arm ring is called drug near
said Brock because every ninth night
eight gold arm rings of equal Beauty
will drip from it
you can reward people with them or store
them and your wealth will increase
Odin examined the Armory then pushed it
onto his arm up high on his biceps
it gleamed there
it is very fine
he said
Loki recalled that Odin had said the
same thing about the spear
Brock walked over to fray he raised a
cloth and revealed a huge ball with
bristles made of gold
this is a boar my brother made for you
to pull your chariot
said Brock it will race across the sky
and Over the Sea faster than the fastest
horse there will never be a night so
dark that its golden bristles will not
give light and let you see what you are
doing
it will never tire and will never fail
you it is called Golem bursty the golden
bristle one
Frey looked impressed
still thought Loki the magical ship that
folded up like a cloth was every bit as
impressive as an Unstoppable bore that
shot in the dark
Loki's head was quite safe
and the last gift Brock had to present
was the one that Loki knew he had
already managed to sabotage
from beneath the cloth rock produced a
hammer and placed it in front of Thor
so I looked at it and sniffed
the handle is rather short
he said
Brock nodded
yes he said that's my fault I was
working the bellows but before you
dismiss it let me tell you about what
makes this Hammer unique
it's called mjolnir the lightning maker
first of all it's unbreakable doesn't
matter how hard you hit something with
it the hammer will always be undamaged
Thor looked interested he had already
broken a great many weapons over the
years normally by hitting things with
them
if you throw the hammer it will never
miss what you throw it out
Thor looked even more interested he had
lost a number of otherwise excellent
weapons by throwing them at things that
irritated him and missing and he had
watched too many weapons he had thrown
disappear into the distance never to be
seen again
no matter how hard or how far you throw
it it will always return to your hand
Thor was now actually smiling and the
Thunder God did not often smile
you can change the size of the hammer it
will grow and it will also shrink down
so small that if you wish you can hide
it inside your shirt
Thor clapped his hands together in
delight and thunder echoed across Asgard
and yet as you have observed concluded
Brock sadly
the handle of the hammer is indeed too
short
this is my fault I failed to keep the
Bellows blowing on my brother Atri was
forging it
the shortness of the handle is a minor
cosmetic problem
said Thor this Hammer will protect us
from the frost Giants this is the finest
gift I have ever seen
it will protect Asgard
it will protect all of us
said Odin with approval
if I were a giant I would be very afraid
of Thor if he had that hammer
said Frey
yes it's an excellent Hammer but Thor
what about the hair Seth's beautiful new
golden hair
asked Loki slightly desperately
what oh yes my wife has very nice hair
said thought now show me how to make the
hammer grow in shrink Brock
Thor's hammer is better even than my
wonderful Spear and my excellent Armory
said Odin nodding
the hammer is greater and more
impressive than my ship and my bore
admitted Frey it will keep the gods of
Asgard safe
the gods clapped Brock on the back and
told him that he and H3 had made the
finest gift that they had ever been
given
good to know I said Brock
he turned to Loki
so said Brock I get to cut off your head
Louisville's son and take it back with
me
hey she will be so pleased we can turn
it into something useful
I will Ransom my head said Loki I have
Treasures I can give you
Adrian I already have all the treasure
we need
said bro
we make Treasures
no Loki I want your head
Loki thought for a moment
then said then you can have it if you
can catch me and Loki leapt High into
the air and ran off far above their
heads
in moments he was gone
Brock looked at Thor
can you catch him
Thor Shrugged I really shouldn't he said
but then I would very much like to try
out the hammer
in moments Thor returned holding Loki
tightly
Loki was glaring with impotent Fury
the dwarf Brooke took out his knife
come here Loki he said I'm gonna cut off
your head
of course said Loki you can of course
cut off my head but and I appeal to
Mighty ode in here if you cut off any of
my neck you are violating the terms of
our agreement which promised you my head
and my head only
Odin inclined his head
Loki is right he said you have no right
to cut his neck
Brock was irritated
but I can't cut off his head without
cutting his neck
he said
Loki looked pleased with himself you see
he said if people thought through the
exactness of their words they would not
dare to take on Loki the wisest the
cleverest the trickiest the most
intelligent the best looking
Brock whispered a suggestion to Odin
that would be fair agreed Odin
Brooke produced a strip of leather and a
knife
he wrapped the leather around Loki's
mouth
Brock tried to pierce the leather with
the tip of the knife blade
it's not working
said Brock my knife isn't cutting you
I might have wisely arranged for
protection from knife blades said Loki
modestly just in case the whole you
can't cut my neck Ploy did not work
I'm afraid no knife blade can cut me
Brooke grunted and produced an all
appointed Spike used in leather work and
he jabbed it through the leather
punching holes through Loki's lips then
he took a strong thread and he sewed
Loki's lips together with it
Brock walked away leaving Loki with his
mouth sewn up tight unable to complain
for Loki the pain of being unable to
talk hurt even more than the pain of
having his lips stitched into the
leather
so now you know
that is how the gods got their greatest
treasures
it was Loki's fault
even Thor's hammer
was Loki's fault
that was the thing about Loki you
resented him even when you were at your
most grateful and you were grateful to
him even when you hated him the most
the master builder
Thor had gone to the east to fight
trolls
Asgard was more peaceful without him but
it was also unprotected
this was in the early days shortly after
the treaty between the Acer and the
vamir when the gods were still making a
home for themselves and Asgard was
undefended
we cannot always rely on Thor said Odin
we need protection Giants will come
trolls will come
what do you propose
ask tame doll The Watchman of the Gods
a wall
said Odin high enough to keep out Frost
Giants thick enough that not even the
strongest troll could batter its way
through
building such a wall
said Loki
so high and so thick would take as many
years
Odin nodded his agreement
but still he said we need a wall
the next day a newcomer arrived in
Asgard
he was a big man dressed as a Smith and
behind him trudged a horse
stallion huge and gray with a broad back
they say you need a wall built
said The Stranger
go on
said Odin
I can build you a wall
said the stranger build it so high that
the tallest giant could not climb it so
thick that the strongest troll could not
better through it I can build it so well
by placing Stone upon stone that not an
ant could find Space enough to crawl
through it I will build you a wall that
will last for a thousand thousand years
the Satchel wall would take a very long
time to build
said Loki
not at all said the stranger I can build
it in three seasons tomorrow is the
first day of winter it would only take
me a winter a summer and another winter
to build
and if you could do this said Odin what
would you ask in return
I need little enough payment for what
I'm offering
said the man
only three things first I would like the
beautiful goddess freya's hand in
marriage
that is not a little thing
said Odin and it would not surprise me
if Freya had her own opinions about the
matter
what are the other two things
The Stranger grinned a cocky grin
if I build your wall he said I want the
hand of freyja and I also want the Sun
that shines in the Sky by day and I want
the Moon that gives us light at night
these three things are what the gods
will give me
if I build your wall
the gods looked at Freya
she said nothing but her lips were
pressed together and her face was white
with anger around her neck was the
necklace of the briefings which Shone
like the Northern Lights as it brushed
her skin and her hair was banded in gold
which was almost as bright as the hair
itself
don't wait outside
Odin to The Stranger
the man walked away not before asking
where he could find food and water for
his stallion which was called
swathelfari which means one who makes an
unlucky Journey
Odin rubbed his forehead
and he turned and looked at all the gods
well asked Odin
the gods began to talk quiet shouted
Odin one at a time
each of the Gods and the goddesses had
an opinion and every one of them was of
the same opinion that freyja the sun and
the moon were all too important and too
valuable to be given to a stranger even
if he could build them the wall they
needed in three seasons
freyja had an additional opinion she
felt that the man should be beaten for
his impertinence then thrown out of
Asgard and sent on his way
so said Odin the all father we are
decided we say no
there was a dry cough from a corner of
the hall
it was the kind of cough intended to
attract attention and the gods turned to
see who had coughed they found
themselves looking at Loki who stared
back at them and who smiled and held up
a finger as if he had something
important to divulge
it is worth my pointing out he said that
you are ignoring something huge
I do not think we have overlooked a
single thing Troublemaker of the Gods
said Freya tartley you are all
overlooking he said that what this
stranger is proposing to do is to make
no bones about it quite impossible
there is no one alive who could build a
wall so high and so thick as the one he
described and have it finished in 18
months not a giant or a God could do
this let alone a mortal man I would
stake my skin on it
at this the gods all nodded and grunted
hmm and looked impressed
all of them except for freyja and she
looked angry
you are fools she said especially you
Loki because you think yourself clever
what he says he can do said Loki is an
impossible task so I suggest this we
agree to his demands and to his price
that we set him stiff conditions he may
have no help building his wall and
instead of three seasons to build his
wall he has but one
if on the first day of summer any of the
wall is unfinished and it will be
then we pay him nothing at all
why would he agree to that ask tamedal
and what advantage would that give us
over not having a wall at all asked Frey
freya's brother
Loki tried to suppress his impatience
what all the gods fools he began to
explain as if he were explaining to a
small child
the Smith will begin to build his wall
he will not finish it he will work for
six months unpaid on a Fool's errand
at the end of six months we will drive
him away we might even beat him for his
presumption and then we can use whatever
he has done so far as the foundations of
the wall that we will complete in the
years to come there is no risk to us of
losing Freya let alone the sun or moon
why would he say yes to building it in a
season asked tear God of War
he may not say yes said Loki but he
seems arrogant and sure of himself and
not the kind to refuse a challenge
all the gods grunted and clapped Loki on
the back and told him that he was a very
crafty fellow and it was a good thing
that he was crafty and on their side and
now they would get their foundations
built for nothing and they congratulated
each other on their intelligence and
their bargaining ability
Freya said nothing
she fingered her necklace of light the
gift of the briefings
this was the same necklace that had been
stolen from her by Loki in the form of a
seal when she was bathing and that
Heimdall had fought in Seal form with
Loki to return to her
she did not trust Loki she did not care
for the way this conversation had gone
the gods called the Builder into their
Hall
he looked around at the gods they all
seemed in Good Humor grinning and
nudging each other and smiling
freyja however did not smile
well asked the Builder
you asked for three seasons said Loki we
will give you one season and one season
only tomorrow is the first day of winter
if you are not finished on the first day
of summer you leave here unpaid
but if you have finished building the
wall as high and as thick and as
impregnable as we have agreed then you
will be given everything you have asked
for the moon the sun and the Beautiful
Freya you may have no help in building
your wall from anyone you must build
this wall alone
The Stranger said nothing for some
moments
he stared away into the distance and
seemed to be weighing Loki's words and
conditions
then he looked at the Gods
and he Shrugged
you have said I may have no outside help
I would like my horse swathelfari to
help me haul the stones here the stones
I will use to build the wall I do not
believe this to be an unreasonable
request
it is not unreasonable
agreed Odin and the other gods nodded
and told each other that horses were
good for hauling heavy stones
they swore Oaths then the mightiest of
Oaths the gods and the stranger that
neither side could betray the other
they swore on their weapons and they
swore on drobe near Odin's Golden Arm
ring and they swore on gongnir Odin's
Spear and an oath sworn on gongnir was
Unbreakable
the next morning as the sun rose the
gods stood to watch the man work
he spat on his hands and he began to dig
the trench into which the first Stones
would go
he digs deep said Handel
he digs fast said Frey freya's brother
well yes obviously he is a mighty Digger
of ditches and trenches said Loki
grudgingly but imagine how many stones
he will have to haul here from the
mountains it is one thing to dig a
trench it is another two whole Stones
many miles unaided and then to place
them one stone upon the next so tightly
fitted that not an ant could crawl
between them higher than the tallest
giant to make a wall
Freya looked at Loki with disgust but
she said nothing
when the sun set the Builder mounted his
horse and set off for the mountains to
gather his first rocks
the horse dragged an empty Stone boat
behind it a low sled but it pulled
across the soft Earth
the gods watched them leave
the moon was high and pale in the early
winter sky
he will be back in a week said Loki I am
curious to see how many rocks that horse
can haul it looks strong
the gods went to their feast folder and
there was much merriment and laughter
but Freya did not laugh
it snowed before Dawn a light dusting of
snowflakes a presentiment of the deep
snows that would come further into the
winter
him though who saw everything
approaching Asgard and who missed
nothing woke the Gods in the Darkness
they gathered by the trench The Stranger
had dug the previous day
in the Gathering Dawn they watched the
Builder walking beside his horse
coming toward them
the horse was steadily dragging a score
of blocks of granite so heavy that the
sled made deep ruts in the Black Earth
when the man saw the gods he waved and
called good morning cheerfully
he pointed to the Rising Sun and he
winked at the Gods
then he unhitched his horse from the
rocks and let it graze while he began to
manhandled the first of the Granite
blocks into the trench he had already
dug to receive it
the horse is indeed strong
said balder most beautiful of all the
Acer
no normal horse should be able to drag
rocks that heavy
it is stronger than we imagined
said Casa the wise
ah said Loki the horse will soon Tire
this was its first day on the job it
will not be able to haul that many
stones every night and winter is coming
the Snows will be deep and thick the
blizzards will be blinding and the way
to the mountain will be difficult there
is nothing to worry about this is all
going according to plan
I hate you so much
said Freya who Stood unsmiling Beside
Loki
she walked back to Asgard in the Dawn
and did not stay to watch The Stranger
build the foundations of his wall
each night the Builder and the horse and
the empty Stone boat left for the
mountain each morning they returned with
the horse dragging another 20 blocks of
granite every block larger than the
tallest man
each day the wool grew and by evening it
was bigger and more imposing than it had
been before
Odin called the gods to him
the wall is growing a pace he said and
we swore an unbreakable Oath a ring oath
and a weapon oath that if he finishes
building his wall in time we will give
him the Sun and the Moon and the hand in
marriage of freyja the beautiful
faster the wise said no man can do what
this master builder is doing
I suspect that he must be something
other than a man
a giant said Odin
perhaps
if only Thor were here side Boulder
Thor is hammering trolls away in the
East said Odin and even if he were to
return our Oaths are Mighty and binding
Loki tried to reassure them
we are like old women getting ourselves
all worried about nothing the Builder
cannot finish the wall before the first
day of summer even if he is the most
powerful Giant in the land it is
impossible
I wish Thor were here said hang Dell he
would know what to do
the Snows fell but the deep snow did not
stop the wall Builder and it did not
slow swathelfari his horse
the gray stallion pulled his sled piled
high with rocks through snow drifts and
through blizzards up steep hills and
down again through icy gorges
the days began to get longer
Dawn came earlier each morning
the Snows began to melt and the wet mud
that was exposed was thick and heavy the
kind of mud that clings to your boots
and drags you down
the horse will never be able to haul
those rocks through the mud said Loki
they will sink and he will lose his
footing
but swathelfari was sure-footed and
implacable even in the thickest wettest
mud and he hauled the rocks to Asgard
although the stone boat was so heavy it
cut deep gashes into the sides of the
Hills
now the Builder was hauling the Rocks up
hundreds of feet and man handling each
rock into place
the mud dried and the spring flowers
came out
yellow cult's foot and white wood
anemones in profusion and the wall being
built around Asgard was a glorious
imposing thing when it was finished it
would be impregnable no giant no troll
no dwarf no mortal would be able to
breach that wall
and the stranger continued to build it
with Relentless Good Humor he did not
seem to care if it rained or it snowed
and neither did his horse each morning
they would bring the rocks from the
mountains each day the Builder would lay
the granite blocks upon the previous
layer
now it was the last day of winter and
the wall was all but completed
the gods sat on their Thrones in Asgard
and they spoke
the Sun
said balder
we have given away
the Sun
replaced the moon in the sky in order to
mark off the days and the weeks of the
Year said brege got a poetry moodly
now there will be no moon
and freyja what will we do without
freyja asked tear
if this Builder is actually a giant said
Freya with ice in her voice then I will
marry him and follow him back to
yotenheim and it will be interesting to
see whom I hate more him for taking me
away or all of you for giving me to him
man
now don't be like that began Loki but
freyja interrupted him and said if this
giant does take me and the Sun and the
Moon then I ask only one thing from the
gods of Asgard
name it said Odin or father who had said
nothing until now
I would like to see whoever caused This
calamity killed before I go said Freya I
think it only fair if I am to go into
the land of the frost Giants if the moon
and the sun are to be plucked from the
sky and the world plunged into Eternal
Darkness than the life of the one who
got us to this point should be forfeit
said Loki the apportioning of blame is
so difficult who remembers exactly who
suggested what as I recall all the gods
share equally in this unfortunate
mistake we all suggested it we all
agreed to it you suggested it said Freya
you talked these idiots into it and I
will see you dead before I leave Asgard
we all began Loki but he saw the
Expressions on the faces of all the gods
in that Hall
and he fell silent
Loki son of loyvee
said Odin this is the result of your
poor Council
and it was as bad as all your other
advice said balder Loki shot him a
resentful glance
we need the Builder to lose his wager
said Odin without violating the oath he
must fail
I don't know what you expect me to do
about it said Loki
I do not expect anything from you said
Odin but if this Builder succeeds in
finishing his wall by the end of
tomorrow then your death will be painful
and long and a bad and shameful death at
that
Loki looked from one God to the next and
in each of their faces he saw his death
saw anger and resentment he did not see
Mercy or forgiveness
it would be a bad death indeed but what
were the Alternatives what could he do
he did not dare to attack the Builder on
the other hand
Loki nodded
leave it to me
he walked from the hall
and none of the Gods tried to stop him
the Builder finished placing his load of
stones on the wall
tomorrow on the first day of summer as
the sun was setting
he would finish his wall
and then he would leave Asgard with his
wages
only 20 more Granite blocks to go
he clambered down the rough wooden
scaffolding and whistled for his horse
was grazing as he normally was in the
long grass at the edge of the forest
almost half a mile from the wall but he
always came when his master whistled
the Builder grabbed the ropes that
attached to the empty Stone boat and
prepared to Hitch it to his great gray
horse
the sun was low in the sky but it would
not set for several hours and the disc
of the moon was pale but it was there
high in the heavens as well
soon both of them would be his the
greater light and the Lesser and freyja
the lady who was more beautiful than
either the Sun or the Moon
but the Builder would not count his
winnings before they were in his hands
he had worked so hard and so long for
all the winter
he whistled for the horse again
Colin he had never needed to whistle
twice
he could see swathelfari now shaking his
head and almost prancing in the
wildflowers of the Spring Meadow
the horse would take a step forward and
then a step back because if he could
sense something enticing in the warm air
of the spring evening but could not tell
what the scent was
called the Builder and the stallion
pricked his ears up and moved into a
swift Canter across the meadow heading
for the Builder
the Builder watched his horse head
toward him and he felt satisfied the
hoof beats pounded across the meadow
doubling and redoubling with the Echoes
that bounced from the high gray Granite
wall so for one moment the Builder
imagined that a whole herd of horses was
coming toward him
now thought the Builder just one horse
he shook his head and realized his
mistake
not one horse not one set of hoof Beats
two
the other horse was a chestnut mayor the
Builder knew she was a mayor immediately
he didn't have to look between her legs
every line of her every inch of her
everything about the chestnut was female
swathelfari wheeled as he ran across the
meadow then he slowed and reared and
made loudly
the chestnut mayor ignored him
she stopped running as if he were not
there and she put her head down and
seemed to be cropping the grass as
swathelfari approached her but when he
was within a dozen yards she began to
run from him a Cantor that became a
gallop and the gray stallion ran behind
her trying to catch her always a length
or two behind nipping at her rump and
tail with his teeth yet always missing
they ran across the meadow together in
the creamy Golden Light of the end of
the day the gray horse and the brown
swept glistening on their flanks it was
almost a dance
the Builder clapped his hands loudly and
whistled and called swathelfari's name
but the stallion ignored him
the Builder ran out intending to catch
the horse and bring him back to his
senses but the chestnut mayor seemed
almost to know what he intended for she
slowed and rubbed her ears and Mane
against the side of the stallion's head
and then ran as if wolves were after her
toward the edge of the forest
swathelfari ran after her and in moments
they both vanished into the Shadows of
the wood
the Builder cursed and spat
and waited for his horse to reappear
the Shadows lengthened and swathelfari
did not return
the Builder returned to his Stone boat
he looked into the woods
and he spat on his hands took hold of
the ropes and began to haul the stone
boat across the meadow of grasses and
spring flowers toward the Mountain
Quarry
he did not return at dawn
the sun was already high in the sky by
the time the Builder returned to Asgard
hauling the stone boat behind him
he had 10 stone blocks on the stone boat
all he could manage and he was hauling
and heaving the stone boat and cursing
the stones but with each heave he got
closer to the wall
beautiful Freya stood at the Gateway
watching him
you have only 10 stone blocks with you
she told him you will need twice that
many bricks
finish our wall
the Builder said nothing
he carried on hauling his blocks toward
the unfinished Gateway his face a mask
there were no Smiles no Winks not me
longer
Thor is returning from the East
Freya told him he will be with us soon
the gods of Asgard came out to watch the
Builder as he hauled the Rocks toward
the wall
they joined Freya stood about her
protectively
they watched silently at first
and then they began to smile and to
chuckle and to call out questions
hey shouted Boulder you only get the sun
if you finish that war
do you think you'll be taking the sun
home with you
and the moon said Breaky
Such a Pity you do not have your horse
with you he could have carried all the
Rocks you need
and the gods laughed
the Builder let go of the stone boat
then
he faced the Gods
you cheated
he said and his face was Scarlet with
exertion and with anger
we have not cheated said Odin no more
than you have cheated do you think we
would have let you build our wall if we
had known you were a giant
the Builder picked up a rock one-handed
and smashed it against another breaking
the granite block into two
he turned to the gods half of the Rock
in each hand and now he was 20 30 50
feet tall his face Twisted he no longer
looked like the stranger who had arrived
in Asgard a season before Placid and
even tempered now his face looked like
the granite face of a cliff twisted and
sculpted by anger and hatred
I am a mountain giant he said and you
gods are nothing but cheats and vile
oath Breakers
if I still had my horse I would be
finishing your wall now I would be
taking the lovely Freya and the Sun and
the Moon for my wages and I would be
leaving you here in the darkness and the
cold without even Beauty to cheer you
now oath was broken
said Odin
but no oath can protect you from us now
the mountain giant roared with anger and
ran toward the gods a huge lump of
granite in each hand as a club
the gods stood aside
and only now the giant saw who was
standing behind them
a huge God red bearded and muscular
wearing Iron gauntlets and holding an
iron Hammer which he swung once
he let go of the hammer when it was
pointing at the Giant
there was a flash of lightning from the
clear skies followed by the dull boom of
Thunder as the hammer left Thor's hand
the mountain giant saw the hammer
getting rapidly bigger as it came
hurtling toward him and then he saw
nothing else
not ever again
the gods finished building the wall
themselves although it took them many
more weeks to cut and hold the last 10
blocks from the quarries high in the
mountains and dragged them all the way
back to Asgard and placed them in
position at the top of the Gateway
they were not as well shaped or as well
fitted as the blocks the master builder
had shaped and placed himself
with those of the Gods who felt that
they should have let the giant get even
closer to finishing the wall before Thor
killed him
Thor said that he appreciated the gods
having some fun ready for him when he
got home from the East
strangely for it was most unlike him
Loki was knocked around to be praised
for his part in luring away the horse
swafflefari
nobody knew where he was although there
were those who spoke of a magnificent
Chestnut mare seen on The Meadows
beneath Asgard
Loki stayed away for the best part of a
year and when he showed up again he was
accompanied by a gray foal
it was a beautiful fold although it had
eight legs instead of the usual four and
it followed Loki wherever he went and
nuzzled him and treated Loki as if he
were its mother
which of course was the case
the foal grew into a horse called Sleep
near a huge gray stallion the fastest
and the strongest horse that ever there
had been or ever there would be a horse
that could outrun the wind
Loki presented sleep near to Odin as a
gift
the best horse among Gods and Men
y people would admire Odin's horse
but only a brave man would ever mention
its parentage in Loki's presence
and nobody ever dared to allude to it
twice
Loki would go out of his way to make
your life unpleasant if he heard you
talking about how he lured swafel fari
away from its master and how he rescued
the gods from his own bad idea
Loki nursed his resentments
and that is the story
of how the gods got their War
[Applause]
the children of Loki
Loki was handsome and he knew it
people wanted to like him they wanted to
believe him but he was undependable and
self-centered at best mischievous or
evil at worst
he married a woman named sigin who had
been happy and beautiful when Loki
courted and married her but now always
looked like she was expecting bad news
she bought him a son narfi and shortly
afterward another son Bali
sometimes Loki would vanish for long
periods and not return and then sigim
would look like she was expecting the
very worst news of all
but always Loki would come back to her
looking Shifty and guilty and also as if
he were very proud of himself indeed
three times he went away
three times he eventually returned
the third time Loki returned to Asgard
Odin called Loki to him
I have dreamed a dream
said the wise old one-eyed God
you have children
I have a son not AFI a good boy although
I must confess that he does not always
listen to his father and another son
Vali obedient and restrained
not them
you have three other children Loki you
have been sneaking off to spend your
days and your nights in the land of the
frost charts with anger Botha the
giantess and she has borne you three
children I have seen them in the eye of
my mind as I sleep and my Visions tell
me that they will be the greatest foes
of the Gods in the time that is to come
Loki said nothing
he tried to look ashamed and succeeded
simply in looking pleased with himself
Odin called the gods to him with tear
and Thor at their head and he told them
that they would be journeying far into
yachtenheim to Giant land to bring
Loki's children to Asgard
the gods traveled into the Land of the
Giants battling many dangers until they
reached anger botha's keep
she was not expecting them and she had
left her children playing together in
her Great Hall
the gods were shocked when they saw what
Loki andangabotha's children were but
that did not deter them
They seized the children and they bound
them and they carried the oldest between
them tied to the stripped trunk of a
pine tree and they muzzled the second
child with a muzzle made from knotted
Willow and they put a rope around its
neck as a leash while the third child
walked beside them gloomy and disturbing
those on the right of the third child
saw a beautiful young girl
while those on the left tried not to
look at her for they saw a dead girl her
skin and flesh rotted black walking in
their midst
have you noticed something
Thor asked tear on the third day of
their Journey back through the land of
the frost chants they had camped for the
night in a small clearing and tearer was
scratching the furry neck of Loki's
second child with his huge right hand
what
they are not following us the Giants not
even the creature's mother has come
after us it's as if they want us to take
Loki's children out of yachtenham
that is foolish talk said tear but as he
said it even though the fire was warm he
shivered
two more days of hard traveling and they
were in Odin's Hall
these are the children of Loki said Tia
shortly
the first of Loki's children was tied to
a pine tree and was now longer than the
pine tree it was tied to
it was called Yeoman Gunda and it was a
serpent
it has grown many feet in the days we
have carried it back
said tear
Thor said careful it can spit burning
black venom it spat its poison at me but
it missed that's why we tied its head to
the tree like that
it is a child
said Odin it is still growing
we will send it where it can harm nobody
Odin took the serpent to the shore of
the sea that lies beyond all lands the
sea that circles midgard and there on
the shore he freed your mangunda and
watched it Slither and slip beneath the
waves and swim away in loops and curls
Odin watched it with his one eye until
it was lost on the horizon and he
wondered if he had done the right thing
he did not know
he had done as his dreams had told him
but dreams no more than they reveal even
to the wisest of the Gods
the serpent would grow beneath the gray
Waters of the world ocean grow until it
encircled the Earth
folk would call Yeoman Gunda the midgard
serpent
Odin returned to the Great Hall and he
ordered Loki's daughter to step forward
he stared at the girl
on the right side of her face her cheek
was pink and white
her eye was the green of Loki's eyes her
lips were full and Carmine on the left
side of her face the skin was blotched
and striated swollen in the bruises of
death her cyclist eye rotted and pale
her lipless mouth whizzened and
stretched over skull Brown teeth
what do they call you girl asked the old
father
they call me hell
she said if it pleases you or father
you're a polite child
said Odin I'll give you that
hell said nothing only looked at him
with a single green eye sharp as an ice
chip and her pallid eye dull and spoiled
and dead and he saw no fear in her
are you alive
he asked the girl are you a corpse
I am only myself Hal daughter of
angabotha and of Loki she said and I
like the dead best of all they are
simple things and they talk to me with
respect the living
look at me with the revulsion
Odin contemplated the girl and he
remembered his dreams then Odin said
this child will be the ruler of the
deepest of the Dark Places and ruler of
the dead of all the nine worlds
she will be the queen of those poor
souls who die in unworthy ways of
disease or of old age of accidents or in
childbirth Warriors who die in battle
will always come to us here in Valhalla
but the Dead who die in other ways will
be her folk to attend her in her
Darkness
for the first time since she had been
taken from her mother the girl hell
smiled with half a mouth
Odin took hell down to the lightless
world and he showed her the immense Hall
in which she would receive her subjects
and watched as she named her possessions
I will call my bowl hunger
said hell
she picked up a knife
this is called famine
and my bed
is called sick bed
[Applause]
that was two of Loki's children with
anger Botha dealt with them
one in the ocean one to the darkness
beneath the Earth
but what to do with the Third
when they had brought the third and
smallest of Loki's children back from
the land of giants
it had been puppy sized and tear had
scratched its neck and its head and
played with it removing its Willow
muzzle first
it was a wolf cup gray and black with
eyes the color of dark Amber
the wolf cub ate its meat raw but it
spoke as a man would speak in the
language of men and the gods and it was
proud
the Little Beast was called fenrir
it too was growing fast
one day it was the size of a wolf the
next the size of a Cave Bear and the
size of a great elk
the gods were intimidated by it all
except tear
he still played with it and romped with
it and he alone fed the wolf its meat
each day
and each day the Beast ate more than the
day before and each day it grew and it
became fiercer and stronger
Odin watched the wolf child grow with
foreboding for in his dreams the wolf
had been there at the end of everything
and the last things Odin had seen in any
of his dreams of the future were the
topaz eyes and the sharp white teeth of
Fenris wolf
the gods had a council and resolved at
that Council that they would bind fenra
they crafted heavy chains and shackles
in the forges of the Gods and They
Carried the shackles to fenrir
here
said the gods as if suggesting a new
game you have grown so fast fenrir it is
time to test your strength we have here
the heaviest chains and shackles
do you think you can break them
I think I can
said Fenris wolf
bind me
the gods wrapped the huge chains around
fenrir and Shackled his paws he waited
motionless while they did this
the gods smiled at each other as they
chained the enormous wolf
now shouted Thor
Fenris strained and stretched the
muscles of his legs and the chains
snapped like dry twigs
the Great Wolf howled to the Moon a howl
of Triumph and joy I broke your chains
he said
do not forget this
we will not forget
said the Gods
the next day tear went to take the wolf
is meat
I broke the Fetters
said fenrir I broke them easily
you did
said tear
do you think they will test me again
I grow and I grow stronger with every
day
they will test you again
I would wager my right hand on it
accept here
the wolf was still growing and the gods
were in the smithies forging a new set
of chains each link in the chains was
too heavy for a normal man to lift the
metal of the chains was the strongest
metal that the gods could find iron from
the earth mixed with iron that had
fallen from the sky they called These
Chains throw me
the gods hauled the chains to where
Fenris slept
the wolf opened his eyes
again
he said
if you can escape from these chains said
the gods then your Renown and your
strength will be known to all the worlds
Glory will be yours if chains like this
cannot hold you then your strength will
be greater than that of any of the gods
or the Giants
and looked at the chains called Draw Me
bigger than any chains had ever been
stronger than the strongest of bonds
there is no glory without Danger
said the wolf after some moments
I believe I can break these bindings
chain me up
they chained him
the Great Wolf stretched and strained
but the chains held
the gods looked at each other and there
was the beginning of Triumph in their
eyes but now the huge wolf began to
twist and arrive to kick out his legs
and strain in every muscle and every
sinew his eyes flashed and his teeth
flashed and his Jaws foamed
he growled as he writhed he struggled
with all his might
the gods moved back involuntarily and it
was good that they did so for the chains
fractured and then broke with such
violence that the pieces were thrown far
into the air and for years to come the
gods would find lumps of shattered
shackles embedded in the sides of huge
trees or the side of a mountain
yes
shouted fenrir and howled in his victory
like a wolf and like a man
the gods who had watched the struggle
did not seem the wolf observed
to Delight in his victory
not even tear
fenria Loki's child booted on this and
on other matters
and Fenris wolf grew Huger and hungrier
with each day that passed
Odin brewed it and he pondered and he
thought
all the wisdom of Mimi as well was his
and the wisdom he had gained from
hanging from the world tree a sacrifice
to himself
at last he called the light elf scanner
phrase Messenger to his side and he
described the chain called click near
scanner rode his horse across the
Rainbow Bridge to svartelfheim with
instructions to the dwarfs for how to
create a chain unlike anything ever made
before
the dwarfs listened to Scania described
the commission and they shivered and
they named their price
Skinner agreed as he had been instructed
to do by Odin although the dwarf's price
was high
the dwarfs gathered the ingredients they
would need to make glapnier
these were the six things dwarfs
gathered
for firstly the footsteps of a cat
for secondly the beard of a woman
for thirdly the roots of a mountain for
fourthly the sinews of a bear for
fifthly the breath of a fish for six and
lastly the spittle of a bird
each of these things was used to make
glipnier
you say you have not seen these things
of course you have not the dwarfs used
them in their crafting
when the dwarfs had finished their
crafting they gave Scania a wooden box
inside the box was something that looked
like a long silken ribbon smooth and
soft to the touch
it was almost transparent and weighed
next to nothing
rode back to Asgard with his box at his
side
he arrived late in the evening after the
sun had set he showed the gods what he
had brought back from the workshop of
the dwarfs and they were amazed to see
it
the gods went together to the shores of
the Black Lake and they called fenrir by
name
he came at a run as a dog will come when
it is called and the gods marveled to
see how big he was and how powerful
what's happening
asked the wolf
we have obtained the strongest bond of
all they told him not even you will be
able to break it
the wolf puffed himself up
I can burst any chains he told them
proudly
Odin opened his hand to display glapner
it shimmered in the Moonlight
that said the wolf that is nothing
the gods pulled on it to show him how
strong it was
we cannot break it they told him
the wolf squinted at the silken band
that they held between them glimmering
like a snail's Trail or The Moonlight on
the waves and he turned away
uninterested
no he said bring me real chains real
Fetters heavy ones huge ones and let me
show my strength
this is great now
said Odin it is stronger than any chains
or Fetters
are you scared fenra
scared
not at all but what happens if I break a
thin ribbon like that do you think I
will get renowned and fame that people
will gather together and say do you know
how strong and powerful Fenris wolf is
he is so powerful he broke a silken
ribbon
there will be no glory for me in
breaking glapner
you were scared
said Odin
the great Beast sniffed the air
I sent treachery and trickery
said the wolf his Amber eyes flashing in
the Moonlight
and although I think your Glacier may
only be a ribbon I will not consent to
be tied up by it
you you who broke the strongest biggest
chains there ever were you were scared
by this band said Thor
I am scared of nothing
crowd the wolf
I think it is rather that you little
creatures
are scared of me
Odin scratched his bearded chin
you are not stupid fenra
there is no treachery here
but I understand your reluctance it
would take a brave Warrior to consent to
be tied up with bonds he could not break
I assure you as the father of the Gods
and if you cannot break a band like this
a veritable silken ribbon as you say
then we Gods will have no reason to be
afraid of you and we will set you free
and let you go your own way
a long growl from the wolf
ah you lie all further
you lie in the way that some folk
breathe if you were to tie me up in
bonds I could not escape from then I do
not believe you would free me I think
you would leave me here I think you plan
to abandon me and to betray me I do not
consent to have that ribbon placed on me
fine words and brave words said Odin
words to cover your fear at being proved
a coward feneres wolf
you were afraid to be tied with a silken
ribbon no need for more explanations
the wolf's tongue lulled from his mouth
and he laughed then showing sharp teeth
each the size of a man's arm
rather than question my courage I
challenge you to prove there is no
treachery planned you can tie me up if
one of you will place his hand in my
mouth
I will gently close my teeth upon it but
I will not bite down
if there is no treachery afoot I will
open my mouth while I have escaped the
ribbon or when you have freed me and his
hand will be unharmed
there I swear if I have a hand in my
mouth you can tie me with your Ribbon so
whose hand will it be
the gods looked at each other
balder looked at Thor Heimdall looked at
Odin High near looked at Frey but none
of them made a move
then tear Odin's son sighed and stepped
forward and raised his right hand
I will put my hand in your mouth fenra
said to you
fenra lay on his side
and tear put his right hand into fenra's
mouth just as he had done when fenrir
was a puppy and they had played together
fenrik closed his teeth gently until
they held tears hand at the wrist
without breaking the skin
and he closed his eyes
the gods bound him with glapnia a
shimmering snail's Trail wrapped the
enormous wolf tying his legs rendering
him immobile
there said Odin
now Fenris wolf break your bonds
show us all how powerful you are
the wolf stretched and struggled it
pushed and strained every nerve and
muscle to snap the ribbon that bound it
but with every struggle the task seemed
harder and with every strain the
glimmering ribbon became stronger
at first the gods snickered
then the gods chuckled
finally when they were certain that the
Beast had been immobilized and that they
were in no danger the gods laughed
only tear was silent
he did not laugh
he could feel the sharpness of Fenris
Wolf's teeth against his wrist the
wetness and warmth of Fenris Wolf's
tongue against his palm and his fingers
fenra stopped struggling
he lay there unmoving if the gods were
going to free him
they would do it now
but the gods only laughed the harder
Thor's booming guthors each louder than
a Thunderclap mingled with Odin's dry
laughter with balder's bell-like
laughter
fenra looked at tear
tear looked at him bravely
then tear closed his eyes and nodded
do it
he whispered
fenrir bit down on tears wrist
tear made no sound
he simply wrapped his left hand around
the stump of his right and squeezed it
as hard as he could to slow the Spurt of
blood to an ooze
fenrir watched the gods take one end of
glepner and thread it through a stone as
big as a mountain and fasten it under
the ground
then he watched as they took another
Rock and used it to hammer the stone
deeper into the ground than the deepest
ocean
treacherous Odin
called The Wolf if you had not lied to
me I would have been a friend to the
Gods
but your fear has betrayed you
I will kill you father of the Gods I
will wait until the end of all things
and I will eat the Sun and I will eat
the moon but I will take the most
pleasure
in killing you
the gods were careful not to get Within
Reach of fenra's Jaws but as they were
driving the rock deeper fenrir twisted
and snapped at them the god nearest him
with presence of Mind thrust his sword
into the roof of Fenris Wolf's mouth the
hilt of the sword jammed in the wolf's
lower jaw wedging the jaw open and
preventing it from ever closing
the wolf growled inarticulately and
saliva poured from its mouth forming a
river if you did not know it was a wolf
you might have thought it a small
mountain with a river flowing from a
cave mouth
the gods left that place where the river
of saliva flowed down into the dark Lake
and they did not speak
but once they were far enough away they
laughed some more and clapped at each
other on the back and smiled at the huge
Smiles of those who believe they have
done something very clever indeed
tear did not smile
and he did not laugh
he bound the stump of his wrist tightly
with a cloth and he walked beside the
gods back to Asgard and he kept his own
Council
these then were the children of Loki
freya's unusual wedding
Thor God of Thunder mightiest of all the
Acer the strongest the bravest the most
Valiant in battle was not entirely awake
yet but he had the feeling that
something was wrong
he reached out a hand for his hammer
which he always kept Within Reach while
he slept
he fumbled around with his eyes closed
he groped about reaching for the
comfortable and familiar shaft of his
hammer
no hammer
Thor opened his eyes
he sat up he stood up
he walked around the room
there was no Hammer anywhere his hammer
was gone
Thor's hammer was called mjolnir it had
been made for Thor by the dwarfs Brock
and Atri it was one of the Treasures of
the Gods if Thor hit anything with it
that thing would be destroyed if he
threw the hammer at something the hammer
would never miss its Target and would
always fly back through the air and
return to his hand he could shrink the
hammer down and hide it inside his shirt
and he could make it grow again
it was a perfect hammer in all things
except one it was slightly Too Short in
the handle which meant that Thor had to
swing it one-handed
the hammer kept the gods of Asgard safe
from all the dangers that menaced them
and the world
Frost Giants and ogres trolls and
monsters of every kind all were
frightened of Thor's hammer
Thor loved his hammer
and his hammer simply
was not there
there were things Thor did when
something went wrong
the first thing he did was ask himself
if what had happened was Loki's fault
Thor pondered
he did not believe that even Loki would
have dared to steal his hammer
so he did the next thing he did when
something went wrong and he went to ask
Loki for advice
Loki was crafty Loki would tell him what
to do
don't tell anyone said Thor to Loki but
the Hammer of the Gods has been stolen
that said Loki making a face is not good
news
let me see what I can find out
Loki went to freya's Hall
Freya was the most beautiful of all the
gods
a golden hair tumbled about her
shoulders and it glinted in the morning
light
freya's two cats prowled the room eager
to pull her chariot around her neck as
golden and Shining as her hair glittered
the necklace of the briefings made for
Freya by dwarfs far Underground
I like to borrow your feathered cloak
said Loki the one that lets you fly
absolutely not said freyja that cloak is
the most valuable thing I possess it's
more valuable than gold I'm not having
you wearing it and going around and
making mischief
Thor's hammer has been stolen said Loki
I need to find it
I'll get you the cloak said Freya
Loki put on The Feathered cloak and he
took to the air in Falcon shape he flew
Beyond Asgard he flew deep into the Land
of the Giants looking for something
unusual
beneath him Loki saw a huge grave Mound
and sitting on it plaiting a dog collar
was the hugest
ugliest ogre of a giant he had ever seen
when the ogre saw Loki and Falcon shape
he grinned a sharp toothed grin and
waved
what's up with the ACL low-key what's
the news from The Elves and why have you
come alone into the Land of the Giants
Loki landed beside the ogre
there's nothing but bad news from Asgard
and nothing but bad news from the elves
really he said the yoga and he chuckled
to himself as if he were extremely
pleased with something he had done and
thought himself remarkably clever
Loki recognized that sort of chuckle
sometimes he did it himself
Thor's hammer is missing said Loki would
you know anything about that
the yoga scratched his armpit and he
chuckled once more
I might he admitted then he said house
Freya is she as beautiful as they say
if you like that sort of thing
said Loki
oh I do
said the ogre I do
there was another uncomfortable silence
the ogre put the dog collar down on a
pile of dog collars and began to plant
another
I have Thor's hammer
the ogre told Loki I've hidden it so
deep beneath the Earth that nobody could
ever find it not even Odin I am the only
one who could bring it up again and I
will return it to Thor if you bring me
what I want
I can Ransom the hammer said Loki I can
bring you gold and Amber I can bring you
Treasures Beyond counting don't want
them
said the ogre I want to marry freyja
bring her here in eight days from now
I'll return the Hammer of the Gods as a
bride gift on freya's wedding night
who are you
asked Loki
the ogre grinned and showed his crooked
teeth
while Loki son of Loy vey I Am threm
Lord of the ogres
I have no doubt that we can come to an
arrangement grape thrim
said Loki
he drew freya's feather cloak around him
then stretched his arms and took to the
skies
beneath Loki the world seemed very small
he looked down at the trees in the
mountains tiniest children's playthings
and the problems of the Gods seemed a
small thing also
Thor was waiting for him in the court of
the Gods and before Loki had even landed
he found himself seized by Thor's huge
hands
well you know something I can see it in
your face tell me whatever you know and
tell it now I don't trust you Loki and I
want to know what you know right this
moment before you've had a chance to
plot and a plan
Loki who plotted and planned as easily
as other folk breathed in and out
smiled at Thor's anger and innocence
your Hammer has been stolen by thrim
Lord of all the ogres he said
I have persuaded him to return it to you
but he Demands a price
fair enough
said Thor
what's the price
freyja's hand in marriage
he just wants her hand
asked Thor hopefully she had two hands
after all and might be persuaded to give
up one of them without too much of an
argument
tier head after all
all of her said Loki he wants to marry
her
oh said Thor she won't like that well
you can tell her the news you're better
at persuading people to do things than I
am when I'm not holding my hammer
they went together to freya's court once
more
here's your feathered cloak said Loki
thank you said freyja did you find out
who stole Thor's hammer
threm lord of the ogres
I've heard of him
a nasty piece of work
what does he want for it
you
said Loki he wants to marry you
Freya nodded
Thor was pleased that she seemed to have
accepted the idea so easily
put on your Bridal Crown a Freya and
pack your things he said you and Loki
are going to The Land of the Giants we
need to get you married off the throne
before he changes his mind I want my
hammer back
Freya did not say anything
Thor noticed that the ground was shaking
as were the walls freya's cats mood and
hissed and they fled beneath the chest
of Furs and would not come out
freya's hands were squeezed into tight
fists the necklace of the briefings
tumbled from her neck to the floor she
did not appear to notice
she was staring at Thor and Loki as if
they were the lowest most unpleasant
Vermin she had ever seen
Thor was almost relieved when Freya
began to speak
what kind of person
do you think I am
she asked very quietly
do you think I'm that foolish that
disposable
that I'm someone who would actually
marry an ogre just to get you out of
trouble
if you two think that I am going to the
Land of the Giants that I'll put on a
bridal crown and Veil and submit to the
touch and the
the last
a fat ogre
that I'd marry him
well
she stopped talking the walls shuddered
once again and Thor feared the entire
building would fall upon them get
out said Freya what kind of woman do you
think I am
but my hammer
said Thor
shut up Thor
said Loki
Thor shut up
they left
she's very beautiful when she's angry
said Thor you can see why that ogre
wants to marry her
shut up Thor
said Loki again
they called a gathering of all the gods
in the Great Hall
every god and goddess was there except
freyja who declined to leave her house
all day they talked debated and argued
there was no question that they needed
to get me all near back
but how each god and goddess made a
suggestion and each suggestion was shot
down by Loki
in the end only one God had not spoken
Heimdall the far-seeing who watches over
the world
not one thing happens that heimdel does
not see
and sometimes he sees events that have
yet to occur in the world
well said Loki what about you heimdo do
you have any suggestions
I do said Handel but you won't like it
Thor banged his fist down upon the table
it does not matter whether or not we
like it he said we are Gods there is
nothing that any of us gathered here
would not do to get back Beyond near the
Hammer of the Gods tell us your idea and
if it is a good idea we will like it
you won't like it said him though we
will like it said Thor
I think we should dress Thor as a bride
have him put on the necklace of the
briefings have him wear a bridal Crown
stuff his dress so he looks like a woman
Veil his face we'll have him wear keys
that jingle as women do drape him with
jewels I don't like it said Thor
people will think well for a start
they'll think I dress up in in women's
clothes
absolutely out of the question I don't
like it I am definitely not going to be
wearing a bridal veil none of us like
this idea do we terrible terrible idea
I've got a beard I can't shave off my
beard
shut up Thor said Loki son of Lloyd
it's an excellent idea if you don't want
the Giants to invade Asgard you will put
on a wedding veil which will hide your
face and your beard
Odin the all highest said
it is indeed an excellent idea well done
Heimdall we need the hammer back and
this is the best way goddesses prepare
Thor for his wedding night
the goddesses brought him things to wear
frigg and footler Sif Ethan and the rest
even scarfy freya's stepmother came and
helped to prepare him
they dressed him in the finest clothes
the kind of Highborn goddess would wear
to her wedding
to see Freya and came back with the
necklace of the briefings
and she hung it about Thor's neck
Sif Thor's wife hung her keys at Thor's
side
Ethan brought all her Jewels which he
draped about Thor so that he glittered
and gleamed in the candlelight and she
brought a hundred rings of red gold and
white gold to go on Thor's fingers they
covered his face with a veil so that
only his eyes could be seen and the
vowel the goddess of marriage placed a
shining headdress upon Thor's head a
bridal Crown high and wide and beautiful
I'm not sure about the eyes pharah said
they don't look very feminine
I should hope not muttered Thor
thou I looked at Thor
if I pulled down the headdress it will
hide them but he still has to be able to
see
do your best said Loki and then he said
I'll be your maidservant and go with you
to the Land of the Giants
Loki shifted his shape and now he was in
voice and in appearance a beautiful
young serving woman
there how do I look
Thor muttered something under his breath
but it might have been a good thing that
nobody could hear it
Loki and Thor clambered into Thor's
Chariot and the goats who pulled it to
snarla and grinder leapt into the skies
eager to be off
mountains broke in half as they passed
and the Earth burst into flame beneath
them
I have a bad feeling about this said
Thor
don't speak said Loki in the form of a
maiden let me do all the Talking can you
remember that if you speak you may ruin
everything
Thor grunted
they landed in the courtyard
giant-sized jet black oxen stood
impassively each Beast was larger than a
house the tips of their horns were
capped with gold and the courtyard stank
with the sharp smell of their dung
a booming voice could be heard from
inside the huge High Hall
move it you fools spread clean straw on
the benches what do you think you're
doing well pick it up or cover it with
straw don't just leave it there to rot
this is freyja the most beautiful
creature in existence njord's daughter
who comes to us she won't want to see
something like that
there was a path made of fresh straw
through the courtyard and after leaving
that Chariot the disguised Thor
and the serving Maiden who was Loki
walked across the straw lifting their
skirts so they did not drag in the muck
a giant woman was waiting for them she
introduced herself as thrim's sister and
she reached down and pinched Loki's
pretty cheek between her fingertips and
she prodded Thor with one sharp
fingernail
so this is the most beautiful woman in
the world doesn't look much to me and
when she picked up her skirts it seemed
to me that her ankles were as thick as
small tree trunks
a trick of the light she is the most
beautiful of all the gods said the
maiden who was Loki smoothly
when her veil comes off I promise you
will be struck down by her beauty
now where is her groom where is the
wedding Feast she is so eager for this I
have barely been able to restrain her
the sun was setting as they were led
into the Great Hall for the wedding
feast
what if he wants me to sit next to him
whispered Thor to Loki
you have to sit next to him that's where
the bride sits
but he might try and put his hand on my
leg Thor whispered urgently
I'll sit between you
said Loki I'll tell him it's our custom
thrim sat at the head of the table and
Loki sat next to him with Thor at the
next seat on the bench
thrim clapped his hands and giant
serving men came in They Carried five
whole roast oxen enough to feed the
Giants they brought in 20 whole baked
salmon each fish the size of a
ten-year-old boy also They carried in
dozens of trays of little pastries and
fancies intended for the women
they were followed by five more serving
men each one carrying a whole Cask of
mead a barrel huge enough that each
giant struggled beneath the weight of it
this meal is for the beautiful fryer
said trim and he might have said
something else but Thor had already
started to eat and to drink and it would
have been rude for thrim to have talked
while the bride-to-be was eating
a tray of pastries for the women folk
was placed in front of Loki and Thor
Loki carefully picked out the smallest
pastry Thor just as carefully swept the
rest of the pastries up and they
vanished to the sound of munching under
the Veil
the other women who had been looking at
the pastries hungrily glared
disappointed at the beautiful Freya
but the beautiful Freya had not even
begun to eat
Thor ate a whole Ox all by himself he
ate seven entire salmon leaving nothing
but the bones each time a tray of
pastries was brought to him he devoured
all the fancies and pastries on it
leaving all the other women hungry
sometimes Loki would kick him under the
table but Thor ignored every kick and
just kept eating
trim tapped Loki on the shoulder
um excuse me he said but the lovely
Freya has just polished off her third
Cask of mead
I'm sure she has
said the maiden who was Loki
amazing I've never seen any woman eat so
ravenously never seen any woman eat so
much or drink so much Mead
there is
said Loki an obvious explanation
he took a deep breath and watched Thor
inhale another whole salmon and pull a
salmon skeleton out from under his Veil
it was like watching a magic trick he
wondered what the obvious explanation
was
that makes eight salmon she's eaten said
trim eight days and eight nights said
Loki suddenly she hasn't eaten for eight
days and eight nights she was so Keen to
come to the Land of the Giants and make
love to her new husband now she is in
your presence she's finally eating again
[Music]
the maiden turned to Thor it's so good
to see you eating again my dear she said
Thor glad Loki from beneath the Veil I
should kiss her said trim
I wouldn't advise it not yet said Loki
but frim had already leaned over and was
making kissing noises with one huge hand
he reached for Thor's Veil the maiden
who was Loki put out her arm to stop him
but it was too late throm had already
stopped making kissing noises and had
sprung back shaken
trim tapped the maiden who was Loki on
the shoulder
can I talk with you he said
of course
they got up and walked across the hall
why are freya's eyes so
so terrifying asked thrim it seemed as
if there was a fire burning inside them
those weren't the eyes of a beautiful
woman
of course not said the maiden who was
Loki smoothly he wouldn't expect them to
be she hasn't slept for eight days and
eight nights Mighty trim she was so
consumed by love for you that she dared
not sleep she was so mad to taste your
love she's burning up inside for you
that's what you're seeing in those eyes
burning passion
oh
said trim
I see
he smiled and licked his lips with a
tongue bigger than a human pillow
well then
they walked back to the table
thrim's sister had sat down in Loki's
seat beside Thor and was tapping her
fingernails on Thor's hand
if you know what's good for you you'll
give me your rings she was saying all
your pretty golden rings you'll be a
stranger in this Castle you'll need
someone looking out for you otherwise
things are going to get pretty nasty so
far from home you've got so many rings
give me some as a bridal gift so pretty
they are all red and gold
isn't it time for the wedding asked Loki
hey cheese said frim he boomed at the
top of his voice bring in the hammer to
sanctify the bride I want to see mjolnir
placed on the beautiful freya's lap let
vow the goddess of pledges between men
and women bless and consecrate our love
it took four giants to carry Thor's
hammer they brought it in from deep
inside the hall
a glinted dolly in the firelight
with difficulty they placed it on Thor's
lap
now said trim now let me hear your
beautiful voice my love my Dove my
sweetness tell me that you love me tell
me that you will be my bride tell me
that you pledge yourself to me as women
have pledged themselves to men and men
to women since the beginning of time
what do you say
Thor held the haft of his hammer with a
hand that was covered with golden rings
he squeezed it reassuringly
it felt familiar and comfortable in his
hand
he started laughing then a deep booming
laugh
what I say said Thor in a voice like
thunder
is that you should not have taken my
hammer
he hit trim with his hammer only once
but once was all it took
the yoga fell to the straw-covered floor
and did not rise again
all the Giants and the ogres fell
beneath Thor's hammer the guests at the
wedding that was never to be
even thrim's sister who received a
bridal gift she had not been expecting
and when the hall was silent Thor called
Loki
Loki climbed out from under the table in
his original shape and surveyed the
Carnage
well he said you appear to have dealt
with the problem
Thor was already taking off his women's
skirts with relief
he stood there wearing nothing but a
shirt in a room filled with dead Giants
there that wasn't as bad as I had feared
he said cheerfully I've got my hammer
back and I had a good dinner
let's go home
the Mead of poets
do you wonder where poetry comes from
where we get the songs we sing and the
tales we tell
do you ever ask yourself how it is that
some people can dream great wise
beautiful dreams and pass those dreams
on as poetry To The World To Be Sung and
retold as long as the sun rises and sets
as long as the moon will Wax and Wane
have you ever wondered why some people
make beautiful songs and poems and tales
and some of us do not
it is a long story and it does no credit
to anyone there is murder in it and
trickery lies in foolishness seduction
and pursuit
listen
it began not long after the dawn of time
in a war between the gods the Acer
fought the Vania the Acer were warlike
gods of battle and Conquest the varnia
was softer brother and sister gods and
goddesses who made the soils fertile and
the plants grow but nonetheless powerful
for that
the gods of the Varner and the Acer were
too well matched
neither side could win the war and more
than that as they fought they realized
that each side needed the other that
there is no joy in A Brave battle unless
you have fine fields and Farms to feed
you in the feasting that follows
they came together to negotiate a piece
and once the negotiations were concluded
they marked their truce by each of them
Acer and Vania alike one by one spitting
into a vat
as their spit mingled so was their
agreement made binding
then they had a feast food was eaten
Mead was drunk and they caroused and
joked and talked and boasted and laughed
as the fires became glowing coals until
the sun crept up above the horizon
then as the Acer and the Vania roused
themselves to leave to wrap themselves
in Furs and cloth and step out into the
crisp snow and The Morning Mist Odin
said it would be a shame to leave our
mingled spittle behind us
Frey and freyja brother and sister were
leaders of the Vania who would stay with
the Acer in Asgard from now on under the
terms of the truce
they nodded
we could make something from it said
Frey we should make a man said freyja
and she reached into the vat
the spittle transformed and took shape
as her fingers moved and in moments it
had taken on the appearance of a man and
stood naked before them
you were closer
said Odin do you know who I am
you are owed in all highest said quasi
you are grimner and third you have other
names too many to list in this place but
I know them all and I know the poems and
the chants and the Kennings that go with
them
made of the joining of the Acer and the
Vania was the wisest of the Gods
he combined head and heart
the gods jostled each other to be the
next to ask him questions and his
answers to them were always wise he
observed keenly and he interpreted what
he saw correctly
soon enough class had turned to the gods
and said
I'm going to travel now I'm going to see
the nine worlds see midgard there are
questions to be answered that I have not
yet been asked
but you will come back to us they asked
I will come back said classier there is
the mystery of the net after all which
one day will need to be untangled
the what asked Thor
akwasia merely smiled and he left the
gods puzzling over his words and he put
on a traveling cloak and he left Asgard
and walked the Rainbow Bridge
Garcia went from town to town from
Village to Village he met people of all
kinds and he treated them well and
answered their questions and there was
not a place but was the better for
khwajes stopping there
in those days there were two dark elves
who lived in a fortress by the sea
they did Magic there and Feats of
alchemy
like all dwarfs they built things
wonderful remarkable things in their
workshop and their Forge but there were
things they had not yet made and making
those things obsessed them
they were brothers and were called fiala
and Gala
when they heard that kavasia was
visiting a town nearby they set out to
meet him
fiala and Gala found Glacier in the
Great Hall answering questions for the
townsfolk amazing all who listened he
told the people how to purify water and
how to make cloth from Nettles he told
one woman exactly who had stolen her
knife and why
once he was done talking and the
townsfolk had fed him the dwarfs
approached
we have a question to ask you that you
have never been asked before
they said but it must be asked in
private
will you come with us
I will come said Gracia
they walked to the Fortress
the seagulls screamed and the brooding
gray clouds were the same shade as the
gray of the Waves the dwarfs led quasia
to their workshop deep within the walls
of their Fortress
what are those
they are Vats they are called sewn and
Botham
I see
and what is that over there
how can you be so wise when you do not
know these things it is a kettle we call
it authoria
ecstasy Giver
and I see over here you have buckets of
honey you have gathered it is uncapped
and liquid
indeed we do said fiala
Gala looked scornful
if you were as wise as they say you are
you would know what our question to you
would be before we asked it and you
would know what these things are for
Gracia nodded in a resigned way
it seems to me he said that if you were
both intelligent and evil you might have
decided to kill your visitor and let his
blood flow into the Vats sawn and both
them and then you would heat his blood
gently in your Kettle or threrea and
after that you would blend uncapped
honey into the mixture and let it
ferment until it became Mead
finest Mead a drink that will intoxicate
anyone who drinks it but also give
anyone who tastes it the gift of poetry
and the gift of scholarship
we are intelligent admitted Gala and
perhaps there are those who might think
us evil
and with that he slashed kavasia's
throat and they hung vasia by his feet
above the Vats until the last drop of
his blood was drained
they warmed the blood and the honey and
the kettle called othered and did other
things to it of their own devising they
put berries into it and stirred it with
a stick
it bubbled and then it ceased bubbling
and both of them sipped it and laughed
and each of the brothers found the verse
and the Poetry inside himself that he
had never let out
the gods came the next morning
they said he was last seen with you
yes said the dwarfs he came back with us
but when he realized that we are only
dwarfs and foolish and lacking in wisdom
he choked on his own knowledge
if only we had been able to ask him
questions
he died you say
yes said fiala and Gala and they gave
the gods classier's bloodless body to
take back to Asgard for a God's funeral
and perhaps because gods are not as
others and death is not always permanent
for them
for a God's eventual return
thus it was that the dwarfs had the Mead
of wisdom and poetry and any person who
wished to taste it needed to beg it from
the dwarfs but Gala and fiala gave the
Mead only to those they liked and they
liked nobody but themselves
still there were those to whom they had
obligations
the giant gippling for example and his
wife the dwarfs invited them to come and
visit their Fortress and one Winter's
day they came
let us go rowing in our boat the dwarfs
told gitling
the Giant's weight made the boat ride
low in the water and the dwarfs rode the
boat onto the Rocks just under the
surface
always before their boat had floated
serenely above the rocks
not this time
the boat crashed onto the rocks and
overturned throwing the giant into the
sea
swim back to the boat the brothers
called to get Ling
I cannot swim he said and that was the
last thing he said for a wave filled his
open mouth with salt water and his head
hit the rocks and in a moment he was
lost to view
fiala and Gala righted their boat and
went home
gitling's wife was waiting for them
where is my husband she asked him said
Gala oh he's dead
drowned added fiala helpfully
at this the Giant's wife wailed and
sobbed as if each cry were being ripped
from her soul she called to her dead
husband and swore she would love him
always and she cried and moaned and wept
hush
said Gala you're weeping and wailing
hurts my ears it's very loud I expect
that's because you're a giant
but the Giant's wife simply wept the
louder
here said fiala would it help if we
showed you the place where your husband
died
she sniffed and nodded and cried and
wailed and keened for her husband who
would never come back to her
stand just over there and we will point
it out to you said fiala showing her
exactly where she should stand that she
should go through the great door and
stand beneath the wall of the Fortress
and he nodded to his brother who
scurried off up the steps to the wall
above
as gitling's wife walked through the
door
Gallard dropped a huge Stone on her head
and she fell her skull half crushed
good job
said fiala I was getting very tired of
those Dreadful noises
they pushed the woman's lifeless body
off the rocks and into the sea
the fingers of the gray waves dragged
her body away from them and gitling's
wife and gitling were reunited in death
the dwarfs Shrugged and believed
themselves to be extremely clever in
their Fortress by the sea
they drank the Mead of poetry each night
and declaimed great and beautiful verses
to each other made Mighty sagas about
the death of gitling and gitling's wife
which they declaimed from the rooftop of
their Fortress and eventually each night
they slept insensible and woke where
they had sat down or Fallen the night
before
one day they woke as usual
but they did not wake in their Fortress
they woke on the floor of their boat and
a giant whom they did not recognize was
rowing it into the waves
the sky was dark with storm clouds and
the sea was black
the waves were high and rough and the
salt water splashed over the side of the
dwarf's boat soaking them
who are you ask the Dwarfs
I am certain said the giant I heard you
were bragging to the wind and the waves
and the world about having killed my
father and mother
ah
said Gala does that explain why you have
tied us up
it does
said Satan
perhaps you are taking us to a glorious
Place said fiala hopefully where you
will untie us and there we will feast
and drink and laugh and become the best
of friends
I do not believe so
said Satan
it was low tide there were rocks jutting
out above the water they were the same
rocks upon which at high tide the dwarfs
boat had overturned on which gitling had
drowned
sutung picked up each of the dwarfs took
him from the bottom of the boat and
placed him on the rocks
these rocks will be covered by the Sea
at high tide said fiala our hands are
tied behind our backs we cannot swim if
you leave us here we will undoubtedly
drown
that is certainly the intention said
certain
he smiled then for the first time
and as you drown I shall sit in this
your boat and I shall watch the sea take
you both then I shall return home to
yachtenham and I will tell my brother
bogie and my daughter gunloth how you
died and we will be satisfied that my
mother and my father were appropriately
Avenged
the sea began to rise
it covered the dwarf's feet and then it
came up to their navels
soon enough the dwarf's Beards were
floating in the foam and there was panic
in their eyes
Mercy
they called
like the mercy you gave my mother and my
father
we will compensate you for their deaths
we will make it up to you we will pay
you
I do not believe that you dwarfs possess
anything that could compensate me for my
parents deaths I'm a wealthy Giant I
have many servants in my mountain
fastness and all the riches I could
dream of
gold I have and precious stones and iron
enough to make a thousand swords I am
the master of Mighty Magics what could
you give me that I do not already have
ask certain
the dwarfs said nothing at all
the waves continued to rise
we have made the Mead of poetry
sputtered Gullah as the water brushed
his lips
made of Cassius blood wisest of all the
gods shouted fiala two Vats and a kettle
all filled with it no one has it but us
no one in the whole world
sutung scratched his head
I must think about this I must Ponder I
must reflect
do not stop and think if you think we
will drown shouted Viola over the Roar
of the waves
the tide Rose
waves were splashing over the dwarf's
heads and they were gulping air and
their eyes were round with fear when
sutung the giant reached out and plucked
first fiala and then Gala from the waves
the Mead of poetry will be adequate
compensation
it is a fair price if you've thrown a
few other things and I'm sure you dwarfs
have a few other things
I shall spare your lives
he tossed them still bound and soaking
into the bottom of the boat where they
wriggled uncomfortably like a couple of
bearded lobsters and he rode back to
shore
Tung took the Mead the dwarves had made
from quasia's blood
he took other things from them as well
and he left that place and he left those
dwarfs who were all things considered
happy enough to have gotten away with
their lives
told people who passed their Fortress
the story of how illused they had been
by certain
they told it in the market when next
they went to trade
they told it when Ravens were near
in Asgard at his high seat
Odin sat and his Ravens hugin and moonin
whispered to him of the things they had
seen and heard as they had wandered the
world
Odin's one eye flashed when he heard the
tale of Sutton's Mead
the people who heard the story called
The Mead of poetry the ship of the
Dwarfs since it had floated fjala and
Gala off the rocks and taken them safely
home
they called it sutang's mead they called
the liquid of othrare or bothan or son
Odin listened to his Raven's words he
called for his cloak and his hat
he sent for the gods and told them to
prepare three enormous wooden Vats the
largest Vats that they could build and
to have them waiting by the gates of
Asgard
he told the gods he would be leaving
them to walk the world
there might be some time
I will take two things with me
said Odin
I need a wet stone to sharpen a blade
with the finest we have here
and I wish to have the auger the drill
called roti
rati means drill and rati was the finest
drill the gods possessed it could drill
deeply and drill through the hardest
rock
Odin tossed the Wet Stone into the air
and caught it again and put it into his
pouch beside the auger
then he walked away
I wonder what he's going to do
said Thor
Courvoisier would have known said frigg
he knew everything
is dead said Loki as for me I do not
care where the all father is going or
why
I am off to help build the wooden Vats
that the all-father requested
said Thor
Satan had given the precious Mead to his
daughter gunloth to watch over inside
the mountain called nitbjorg in the
heart of giant country
Odin did not go to the mountain instead
he went directly to the Farmland owned
by sutung's brother bulgi
it was spring
and the fields were high with grasses to
be cut for hay
balgee had nine slaves giants like
himself and they were cutting the grass
for hay with huge sides each side the
size of a small tree
Odin watched them
when they stopped work when the sun was
at its highest to eat their Provisions
Odin sauntered over to them and said I
have been watching you all work tell me
why does your master let you cut grass
with such blunt scythes
the blades are not blunt
said one of the workers
why would you say that ask another our
blades are the sharpest
let me show you what a well-sharpened
blade can do
said Odin
he took the Wet Stone from his pouch and
Drew it along first one Scythe blade
then another until each blade glimmered
in the Sun
the Giants stood around him awkwardly
watching him as he worked now said Odin
try them out
the giant slaves swept their scythes
through the meadow grass and gasped and
exclaimed with pleasure the blades were
so sharp they made cutting the grass
effortless the blades swept through the
thickest stalks and met with no
resistance
this is wonderful they told Odin can we
buy your wet stone
buy it said the all father
absolutely not let us do something more
fair and more fun all of you come here
stand in a group each man holding his
Scythe tightly stand closer
we can stand no closer said one of the
giant slaves for the sides are very
sharp
you are wise said Odin he held up the
Wet Stone I tell you this the one of you
who catches it he alone shall have it
and so saying he tossed the Whetstone
into the air
nine Giants jumped at the Whetstone as
it descended each reaching with his free
hand paying no attention to the Scythe
he held each Scythe with a blade
sharpened by the all-father at his
Whetstone wetted to a perfect sharpness
they jumped and they reached and the
blades glinted in the Sun
there was a spray and a spurt of crimson
in the sunlight and the bodies of the
slaves crumpled and twitched and one by
one fell to the freshly cut grass
Odin stepped over the bodies of the
Giants retrieved the Whetstone of the
Gods and placed it back in his pouch
each of the nine slaves had died with
his throat cut by his fellow's blade
Odin walked to the hall of baugi
Sutton's brother and asked for lodging
for the night
I am called bulverka
said Odin
said baogi a dismal name it means worker
of terrible things
only to my enemies
said the person who called himself
bulverka
my friends appreciate the things I do I
can do the work of nine men and I will
work tirelessly and without complaint
lodging for the night is yours
said baogi sighing
but you have come to me on a dark day
yesterday I was a rich man with many
fields and with nine slaves to plant and
to harvest to labor and to build
tonight I still own my fields and my
animals
but all my servants are dead they slew
each other
I do not know why
a dark day indeed said the bulverka who
was Odin
can you not get other workmen
nah not this year side bogey it is
already spring
the good workers are already working for
my brother sutong and few enough people
come here in the way of things you were
the first traveler who's asked me for
lodging and hospitality and many a year
and lucky you are that I did for I can
do the work of nine men
you are not a giant said baogi you are a
little shrimp of a thing how could you
do the work of one of my servants let
alone nine of them
if I cannot do the work of your nine men
said Boulevard
then you need not pay me
but if I do
yes
even in distant parts we have heard
tales about your brother sutung's
extraordinary mead they say it bestows
the gift of poetry on anyone who drinks
it
this is true
Sutton was never a poet When We Were
Young I was the poet in the family but
since he has returned with the dwarf's
Mead he has become a poet and a dreamer
if I work for you and plant and build
and harvest for you and do the work of
your dead servants I would like to taste
your brother sutong's Mead
but
Bogey's forehead creased
but that is not mine to give it is
certains
ah a Pity said bull Vaca then I wish you
luck in getting the Harvest in this year
wait
it is not mine true
but if you can do what you say I will go
with you to see my brother sotong and I
will do all I can to help you taste his
Mead
then
said bulverka we have a deal
never was there a harder worker than
bulverker he worked the land harder than
20 men let alone nine
single-handed he looked after the
animals single-handed he harvested the
crops he worked the land and the land
repaid him a thousandfold
as the first Mists of winter rolled down
the mountain you are misnamed for you
have worked nothing but good
have I done the work of nine men
you have and nine again
then will you help me to get a taste of
sutang's mead I shall
the next morning they Rose early and
walked and walked and walked and by
evening they had left baugi's land and
reached sutangs on the edge of the
mountains by Nightfall they reached
Sutton's huge Hall
greetings brother sotong said Balki this
is bullveka my servant for the summer
and my friend
and he told sutung of his agreement with
bulverka so you see he concluded I must
ask you to give him a taste of the Mead
of poetry
setting's eyes were like chips of ice
no he said flatly
no
said Balki
no I will not give away a single drop of
that Mead not one drop
I have it safe in its Vats in Botham and
so on and the kettle of
those Vats are deep inside the mountain
of hanipjurg which opens only to my
command
my daughter gunloth guards it this
servant of yours cannot taste it you
cannot taste it
but said bougie it was blood
compensation for our parents deaths
don't I deserve the smallest measure of
it to show bull Vaca here that I am an
honorable Giant
no said Sutton you don't
they left his Hall
doggy was disconsolate he walked with
his shoulders hunched high and his mouth
drooping down
every few Paces bowgie would apologize
to bulgar
I did not think my brother would be so
unreasonable he would say
he is indeed unreasonable said bulgar
who was Odin in disguise
but you and I could play a little trick
or two on him so that he would not be so
high and mighty in future so that next
time he will listen to his brother
we could do that said the giant bulky
and he stood straighter and the corners
of his mouth tightened into something
that almost resembled a smile
what are we going to do
first said bulverka we will climb
nitberg the beating Mountain
they climbed and it bjerg together the
giant going first and bull Vaca doll
sized in comparison never falling behind
they clambered up the paths that the
mountain sheep and goats made and then
they scrambled up rocks until they were
high in the mountain
the first Snows of winter had fallen on
the ice that had not melted from the
winter before they heard the wind as it
whistled about the mountain they heard
the cries of birds far below them and
there was something else they could hear
it was a noise like a human voice
it seemed to be coming from the rocks of
the mountain but it was always distant
as if it were coming from inside the
mountain itself
what noise is that
asked bulverka
baogi frowned
it sounds like my niece gunloth singing
then we will stop here
from his Leather Pouch
bulverka produced the auger called rati
yeah he said you're a giant and big and
strong why don't you use this auger to
drill into the side of the mountain
Bowie took the auger he pushed it
against the Mountainside and began to
twist
the tip of the auger drilled into the
Mountainside like a screw into soft cork
baogi turned it and turned it again and
again
it said bogie
he pulled out the auger
bulgar leaned over the hole made by the
drill and blew into it chips and the
dust of rocks blew back at him
I have just learned two things
said bulverka
what two things are these asked bulky
that we are not yet through the mountain
said bulverka you must keep Drilling
that is only one thing said baogi
but bulverka said nothing more on that
high mountain side where the icy winds
clawed and clutched at them
Balki pushed the drill rati back into
its hole and began to turn it once more
it was getting dark when baogi pulled
the auger from the hole again
it broke through into the inside of the
mountain he said
bulvac has said nothing but he blew
gently into the hole and this time he
saw the chips of rock blow inward
as he blew he was aware that something
was coming toward him from behind
bulverka transformed himself then he
turned himself into a snake and the
sharp auger plunged into the place where
his head had been
the second thing I learned when you lied
to me hissed the snake to baogi who
stood astonished holding the auger like
a weapon was that you would betray me
and with the flick of its tail the stake
vanished into the hole in the
Mountainside
doggy struck again with the auger but
the snake was gone and he flung the
drill from him angrily and heard it
clatter on the Rocks below
he thought about going back to Sutton's
Hall and once he was there telling his
brother that he had helped bring a
powerful magician a panitburg had even
helped him to get inside the mountain he
imagined sutung's reaction to this news
and then his shoulders slumping and his
mouth drooping bowgie climbed down the
mountain and trudged off home to his own
hearth and his own Hall
whatever happened in the future to his
brother or to his brother's precious
Mead why it was nothing to do with him
bulverka slid in snake shape through the
hole in the mountain until the hole
ended and he found himself in a huge
Cavern
the cavern was lit by crystals with a
cold light
Odin transformed himself from snake
shape into man shape once more and not
just a man but huge man giant sized and
well-formed
then he walked forward following the
sound of song
gunloth the daughter of Sutton stood in
the cavern in front of a locked door the
hindwich with the Vats called sewn and
bothen and the kettle of
she held a sharp sword in her hands and
she sang to herself as she stood
well met Brave Maiden said Odin
gunloth stared at him
I do not know who you are she said name
yourself stranger and tell me why I
should let you live
I am gunloth guardian of this place
I am bulverka said Odin and I deserve
death I know for daring to come to this
place but stay your hand and let me look
upon you
gunloth said
my father sutung set me on guard here to
protect the Mead of poetry
bulverka Shrugged
why would I care for the Mead of poetry
I came here only because I had heard of
the Beauty and the courage and the
virtue of gundloff
daughter I told myself if she just lets
you look at her it will be worth it if
of course she is as beautiful as they
say in the tales
that was what I thought
gunloth stared at the handsome Giant in
front of her
and was it worth it
who is about to die
more than worth it
he told her for you are more beautiful
than any tale I have ever heard or any
song that any Bard could compose more
beautiful than a mountain peak more
beautiful than a glacier more beautiful
than a field of fresh fallen snow at
dawn
gunloth looked down and her cheeks
reddened
can I sit beside you
asked bulveka
gunlath nodded saying nothing
she had food there in the mountain and
drink and they ate and they drank
after they ate they kissed gently in the
Darkness
after their lovemaking bulgar said sadly
ah I wish I could taste one sip of the
Mead from the vat called son
then I would make a true song about your
eyes and all men would sing it when they
wanted to sing of beauty
one sip
she asked
a sip so small nobody would ever know
he said but I am in no hurry you are
more important than that
let me show you how important to me you
are
and he pulled her to him
they made love in the Darkness
when they had finished and were curled
up together naked skin touching skin
Whispering endearments then bulvac aside
mournfully
what is wrong
ah I wish I had the skill to sing of
your lips how soft they are how much
better they are than the lips of any
other girl
I think that would be an excellent song
that is indeed unfortunate agreed
gunloth for my lips are very attractive
I often think they are my best feature
perhaps but you have so many perfect
features picking the best is so
difficult but if I were to take the
tiniest taste from the vet called bothan
The Poetry would enter my soul and I
would be able to make a poem about your
lips that would last until the sun is
eaten by a wolf
only the tiniest sip though
she said because father would get quite
irritable if he thought I was giving
away his Mead to every good-looking
stranger who penetrated this mountain
fastness
they walked the caverns holding hands
and occasionally brushing lips gunlov
should the doors and the windows that
she could open from inside the mountain
through which Sutton sent her food and
drink
and bulverker appeared to pay no
attention he explained that he was not
interested in anything that was not
about gunloth or her eyes or her lips or
her fingers or her hair
gunloth laughed and told him that he did
not mean any of his fine words and he
obviously could not want to make love
with her again
[Music]
he hushed her lips with his lips
and once again
they made love
when they were both perfectly satisfied
bulverka began to weep in the Darkness
what's wrong my love
asked gunloth kill me
sobbed bulverka kill me now
for I will never be able to make a poem
about the Perfection of your hair and
your skin of the sound of your voice of
the feel of your fingers
the beauty of gunlot is impossible to
describe
well she said I suppose it can't be easy
to make such a poem but I doubt it's
impossible
perhaps
yes
perhaps the smallest sip from the kettle
authoria would give me the lyrical
skills to conjure your beauty for
Generations still to come he suggested
his sobs ceasing
yes perhaps it would but it would have
to be the smallest of smallest sips
show me the kettle and I will show you
just how small a sip I can take
gunloth unlocked the door and in moments
she and bulverka were standing in front
of the kettle and the two Vats
smell of the Mead of poetry was heady on
the air
just the tiniest of sips she told him
for three poems about me that will echo
down Through the Ages
of course my darling
bulverka grinned in the Darkness
if she had been looking at him then she
would have known something was wrong
with his first drink he drank every drop
of the kettle of
with his second he drained the vat
called Botham
with his third he emptied the vat called
son
lath was no fool she realized that she
had been betrayed and she attacked him
she was strong and fast but Odin did not
stay to fight he ran from there he
pulled the door closed and locked her
inside
in the blink of an eye he became a huge
Eagle Odin screeched as he flapped his
wings and the mountain doors opened and
he rose into the skies
gunloth's screams pierced the dawn
in his Hall sutong woke and ran outside
he looked up and saw the eagle and knew
what must have happened sutong 2
transformed himself into Eagle shape
the two Eagles flew so high that from
the ground they were the tiniest of
pinpricks in the sky they flew so fast
that their flight sounded like the Roar
of a hurricane
in Asgard Thor said
it is time
he hauled the three huge wooden Vats
into the courtyard
the gods of Asgard watched the Eagles
screaming through the sky toward them it
was a close thing Sutton was fast and
close behind Odin his beak almost
touching Odin's tail feathers as they
reached Asgard
when Odin approached the hall he began
to spit
a fountain of mead spurted from his beak
into the Vats one after another like a
father bird bringing food for his
children
ever since then we know that those
people who can make magic with their
words who can make poems and sagas and
weave Tales have tasted the Mead of
poetry
when we hear a fine poet we say that
they have tasted Odin's gift
there
that is the story of the Mead of poetry
and how it was given to the world
it is a story filled with dishonor and
deceit with murder and trickery
but it is not quite the whole story
there is one more thing to tell you
the delicate among you should stop your
ears or read no further
here is the last thing and a shameful
admission it is
when the all father in Eagle form had
almost reached the Vats with sutong
immediately behind him Odin blew some of
the Mead out of his behind a splattery
wet fart a foul-smelling mead right in
certain's face blinding the Giant and
throwing him off Odin's Trail
no one then or now wanted to drink the
Mead that came out of Odin's ass
but whenever you hear Bad poets
declaiming their bad poetry filled with
foolish similes and ugly Rhymes you will
know which of the medes they have tasted
Thor's Journey to the Land of the Giants
one
Theory and his sister roskva lived with
their father eagle and their mother on a
farm at the edge of wild country
beyond their Farm were monsters and
Giants and wolves and many times the
Alvey walked into trouble and had to
outrun it he could run faster than
anyone or anything
living at the edge of the Wild Country
meant that thealdi and the roskva were
used to Miracles and strange things
happening in their world
nothing is strange however as the day
that two visitors from Asgard Loki and
Thor arrived at their Farm in a chariot
pulled by two huge goats whom Thor
called snala and grinder
the gods expected lodging for the night
and food
the gods were huge and Powerful
we have no food for the likes of you
said roskva apologetically
we have vegetables but it's been a hard
winter and we don't even have any
chickens left
Thor grunted
then he took his knife and killed both
his goats he skinned their corpses he
put the goats in the huge stew pot that
hung above the fire while rosva and her
mother cut up their winter stores of
vegetables and dropped them into the
stew pot
Loki took the Elvia side
the boy was intimidated by Loki his
green eyes his scarred lips his smile
Loki said
you know the marrow of the bones of
those goats is the finest thing a young
man can eat
such a shame that Thor always keeps it
all for himself
if you want to grow up to be as strong
as Thor you should eat the goat bone
marrow
when the food was ready Thor took a
whole goat as his portion leaving the
meat of the other goat for the other
five people
he put the goat skins down on the ground
and as he ate he threw the bones onto
his goat skin
put your bones on the other goat's skin
he told them and don't break or chew any
of the bones just eat the meat
you think you can eat fast you should
have seen Loki devour his food one
moment it was in front of him and the
next it was gone and he was wiping his
lips with the back of his hand
the rest of them ate more slowly
but the Alvi could not forget what Loki
had said to him and when Thor left the
table for a call of nature the Alvi took
his knife and split one of the goat's
leg bones and ate some of the marrow
from it
he put the broken bone down on the
goat's skin and covered it with
undamaged bones so nobody would know
they all slept in the Great Hall that
night
in the morning Thor covered the bones
with the goat skins he took his hammer
mjolnir and held it up high
he said
snarla be whole
a flash of lightning snarla stretched
itself bleated and began to graze
though I said grinder be whole and
grinder did the same
and then it staggered and limped
awkwardly over to snarla and it let out
a high-pitched bleat as if it were in
pain
Grinders heim's leg is broken
said Thor
bring me wood and cloth
he made a splint for his goat's leg and
he bandaged it up
and when that was done he looked at the
family and theovi did not think he had
ever seen anything quite as scary as
Thor's burning red eyes
Thor's fist was wrapped around the shaft
of his hammer
somebody here broke that bone he told
them in a voice like thunder
I gave you people food I asked only one
thing of you and yet you betrayed me
I did it said thiavi
I broke the bone
Loki was trying to look serious but even
so he was smiling at the corners of his
mouth
it was not a reassuring smile
Thor hefted his hammer I ought to
destroy this entire farm he muttered and
Eagle looked scared and agel's wife
began to weep then Thor said tell me why
I should not turn this whole place to
Rubble
Eagle said nothing
thealdi stood up he said it has nothing
to do with my father he didn't know what
I had done punish me not him look at me
I'm a really fast runner I can learn let
my parents be and I'll be your bond
servant
his sister rosva stood up
he is not leaving without me she said
take him you take both of us
Thor pondered this for a moment then
very well
for now roskva you will stay here and
tend snala and grinder while Grinder's
leg heals
when I return I will collect all three
of you
he turned to the elvi and you can come
with me and Loki we are going to utgaard
two
the world beyond the farm was Wilderness
and Thor and Loki and thelvi traveled
East towards yachtenheim home of the
Giants and the sea
it became colder the farther east they
went
freezing winds blew draining them of any
warmth
shortly before Sunset when there was
still enough light to see they looked
for a place to shelter for the night
Thor and thelb found nothing
Loki was away the longest he came back
with a puzzled look on his face
there's an odd sort of house over that
way
he said
Howard
asked Thor
it's just one huge room no windows and
the doorway is enormous but it has no
door it's like a huge cave
the cold wind numbed their fingers and
stung their cheeks Thor said we shall
check it out
the main hall went back a long way
there could be beasts or Monsters back
there said Thor let's set up by the
entrance
they did just that
it was as Loki had described a huge
building one huge hole with a long room
off to one side
they made a fire by the entrance and
slept there for an hour or so until they
were woken by a noise
what's that
said thelvi an earthquake
said Thor
the ground was trembling something
roared it might have been a volcano or
an avalanche of great rocks or a hundred
Furious bears
I don't think so
said Loki let's move into the side room
just to be safe
Loki and thealdi slept in the side room
and the tumbling roaring noise continued
until Daybreak
Thor stationed himself at the door to
the house all night holding his hammer
he had been getting more irritable as
the night wore on and wanted only to
explore and to attack whatever was
rumbling and shaking the Earth
as soon as the sky began to lighten Thor
walked into the forest without waking
his companions looking for the source of
the sound
there were he realized as he got closer
different sounds which occurred in
sequence
first a rumbling Roar followed by a
humming and then a softer sort of
whistling noise piercing enough to make
Thor's headache and his teeth hurt each
time he heard it
Thor reached the top of the hill and
looked at the world beneath him
stretched out in the valley below was
the biggest person Thor had ever seen
his hair and beard were blacker than
charcoal his skin was as white as a snow
field the Giant's eyes were closed and
he was regularly snoring that was the
rumble hum and whistle that Thor had
been listening to every time the giant
snored the ground shook
that was the shaking they had felt in
the night
the giant was so big that by comparison
Thor might have been a beetle or an ant
Thor reached down to his belt of
strength Megan girth and pulled it tight
doubling his strength to make sure that
he was strong enough to battle even the
hugest of giants
as Thor watched the giant opened his
eyes they were a piercing icy blue
the giant did not seem immediately
threatening though
hello
cold Thor
good morning called the black-haired
Giant in a voice like an avalanche they
call me screamer it means big fellow
they are sarcastic my lot calling a
runty little chap like me big fellow but
there you are now where's my glove I had
two you know last night but I dropped
one
he held up his hands his right hand had
a huge Mitten like leather glove on it
the other was bear
oh there it is
he reached down to The Far Side Of The
Hill Thor had climbed and he picked up
something that was obviously another
mitten God something's in it he said and
gave it a shake
Thor recognized their home of the
previous night Justice the Albion Loki
King tumbling out of the mouth of the
glove and landed in the snow beneath
screamer put his left Mitten on and
looked happily at his Mitten hands
we can travel together
he said if you're willing
Thor looked at Loki and Loki looked at
Thor and both of them looked at Young
thealdi Who Shrugged
I can keep up he said confident of his
speed
very well shouted Thor
they ate breakfast with the giant he
pulled whole cows and sheep from his
provision bag and crunched them down
the three companions ate more sparingly
after the meal screamer said here I'll
carry your Provisions inside my bag less
for you to carry and we will all eat
together when we camp tonight
he put their food in his bag did up the
laces and Strode off toward the east
Thor and Loki ran after the giant with
the untiring pace of Gods
theology ran as fast as any man has ever
run but even he found it hard to keep up
as the hours went by and sometimes it
seemed that the giant was just another
mountain in the distance his head lost
in the clouds
they caught up with screamer as evening
fell
he had found a camp for them beneath a
huge old oak tree and had made himself
comfortable nearby his head resting on a
great Boulder
I'm not hungry he told them don't you
worry about me I'm gonna get an early
night your Provisions are in my bag up
against the tree good night
he began to snore
as the familiar Rumble Hammond whistle
shook the trees the Alvey claimed the
Giant's provision bag
he called down to Thor and Loki I cannot
undo the laces they are too tough for me
they might as well be made out of iron
I can bend iron
said Thor and he leapt to the top of the
provision bag and began to tug on the
laces
well
asked Loki
Thor grunted and hold hold and grunted
then he Shrugged
I don't think we'll be having dinner
tonight
he said not unless this damnable giant
undoes the laces on his bag for us
he looked at the Giant he looked at
mjolnir his hammer
then he clambered down the bag and he
made his way onto the top of Screamer's
sleeping head
he raised the hammer and slammed it down
on Screamer's forehead
screamer opened one eye sleepily
I think a leaf just fell on my head and
woke me up
he said have you all finished eating are
you ready for bed don't blame you if you
are long day
and he rolled over closed his eyes and
began to snore once again
Loki and the Alvi managed to fall asleep
despite the noise but Thor could not
sleep he was angry he was hungry and he
did not trust this giant out in the
Eastern wilderness
at midnight he was still hungry and he
had had enough of the snoring he
clambered up onto the Giant's head once
more he positioned himself between the
Giant's eyebrows
Thor spat into his hands He adjusted his
belt of strength he raised mjolnir over
his head and with all his might he swung
he was certain that the hammer sank into
Screamer's forehead
it was too dark to see the color of the
Giant's eyes
but they opened
whoa the big fellow said Thor are you
there
I think an acorn just fell off the tree
onto my head
what time is it
it's midnight
said Thor
well then see you in the morning
giant snores shook the ground and made
the tops of the trees tremble
it was Dawn but not yet day when Thor
hungrier angrier and still Sleepless
resolved to strike one final blow that
would silence the snoring forever
this time he aimed for the Giant's
Temple and he hit screamer with all his
strength never was there such a blow
Thor heard it Echo from the mountaintops
huh
you know said screamer
I think a bit of bird's nest just
dropped on my head
twigs
I don't know
he yawned and stretched then he got to
his feet
well I'm done sleeping time to be on our
way
are you three headed to utgaard
they will look after you well there
I guarantee you a mighty Feast horns of
Ale and afterward wrestling and racing
and contests of strength they like their
funny new God that's dewist just head
that way where the sky is lightning me
I'll be off to the north
he gave them a gap-toothed grin which
would have seemed foolish and vacant if
his eyes had not been so very blue
and so very sharp
then he leaned over and put a hand
beside his mouth as if he did not wish
to be overheard an effect slightly
lessened by his whisper which was loud
enough to deafen
I couldn't help overhearing you fellows
back then when you were saying how very
big I was and I suppose you thought you
were complimenting me but if you ever
make it to the North you'll meet proper
Giants the really big fellows and you'll
find out what a shrimp I really am
screamer grind again
and then he stomped off toward the North
and the ground rumbled beneath his feet
three
they traveled East through yotenheim
always traveling toward the sunrise for
some days
at first they thought they were looking
at a normal sized Fortress and that it
was relatively close to them
they walked toward it hurrying their
Pace but it did not grow or change or
seem closer
as the days passed they realized how big
it was
and just how far away
is that udgaard
asked the Alvey
Loki seemed almost serious as he said
it is this is where my family came from
have you ever been here before
I have not
they Strode up to the Fortress gate
seeing no one they could hear what
sounded like a party going on inside
the gate was higher than most Cathedrals
it had metal bars covering it of a size
that would have kept any unwanted Giants
at a respectable distance
Thor shouted but no one responded to his
calls
shall we go in
he asked Loki and Theory
they ducked and climbed under the bars
of the gate
The Travelers walked through the
courtyard and into the Great Hall
there were benches as high as Treetops
with giants sitting on them
Thor Strode in
the Alvey was terrified but he walked
beside Thor and Loki walked behind them
they could see the king of the Giants
sitting on the highest chair at the end
of the hall
they crossed the hall
and then they bowed deeply
the king had a narrow intelligent face
and Flame red hair
his eyes were an icy blue
he looked at The Travelers and he raised
an eyebrow
good Lord he said it's an invasion of
tiny toddlers
now my mistake you must be the famous
Thor of the Acer which means you must be
low-key Loy vey's son I knew your mother
a little
hello small relation
I am utka de Loki the Loki of utkad and
you are
the Alvi said the Alvi I am Thor's Bond
servant
welcome all of you to udguard said Loki
the finest place in the world for those
who are remarkable
anyone here who is in craft or canning
Beyond everyone else in the world is
welcome
can any of you do anything special
what about you little relative what can
you do that's unique
I can eat faster than anybody
said Loki without boasting
how interesting I have my servant here
his name is amusingly enough logi would
you like an eating competition with him
Loki Shrugged as if it were all the same
to him
clapped his hands and a long wooden
trough was brought in with all manner of
roasted animals in it geese and oxen and
sheep goats and rabbits and deer
when he clapped his hands again Loki
began to eat starting at the far end of
the trough and working his way inward he
ate hard he ate single-mindedly he ate
as if he had only one goal in life to
eat all he could as fast as he could his
hands and mouth were a blur
ghi and Loki met at the middle of the
table
utkar the Loki looked down from his
throne
well he said you both ate at the same
speed not bad but Logie ate the bones of
the animals and yes it appears he also
ate the wooden trough it was served in
Loki ate all the flesh it's true but he
barely touched the bones and he didn't
even make a start on the trough so this
round goes to Logie
but got a Loki looked at the Alvey you
he said boy
what can you do
the Alvey Shrugged
he was the fastest person he knew he
could outrun startled rabbits outrun a
bird in Flight he said
I can run
then said utga Loki you shall run
they walked outside and there on a level
piece of ground was a track perfect for
running
a number of giants stood and waited by
the track rubbing their hands together
and blowing on them for warmth
you're just a boy theelvey said uttar
Loki so I will not have you run against
a grown man
where is our little huyi
a giant child stepped forward so thin he
might not have been there not much
bigger than Loki or Thor
the child looked at utga Loki and said
nothing
but he smiled
thiavi was not certain that the boy had
been there before he had been called
but he was there now
huyi and thealvi stood side by side at
the starting line and they waited
in a voice like Thunder and the boys
began to run
the Alvey ran as he had never run before
but he watched Hui pull ahead and reach
the Finish Line when he was barely
halfway there
but God aloki called Victory goes to
huyi
then he crouched down beside the Alvey
you will need to run faster if you have
a hope of beating huyi said the giant
still I've not seen any human run like
that before run faster thealvey the Alvi
Stood Beside huyi at the starting line
once more
filthy was panting and his heart was
pounding in his ears he knew how fast he
had run and yet huyi had run faster and
huyi seemed completely at ease
he was not even breathing hard
the giant child looked at the Alvey and
smiled again there was something about
Tui that reminded the Alvi of utga Loki
and he wondered if the giant child was
at Garden Loki's son
go
they ran
the Alvi ran as he had never run before
moving so fast that the world seemed to
contain only himself and huyi and Hui
was still ahead of him the whole way who
ye reached the Finish Line when thelvi
was still five perhaps 10 seconds away
they all be knew that he had been close
to winning that time knew that all he
had to do was give it all he had
let us run again
he panted
very well said it got a Loki you can run
again
you're a fast young man but I do not
believe you can win still we will let
the final race
decide the outcome
Hui stepped over to the starting line
the LV stood next to him he could not
even hear who ye breathing
good luck said the Alvey
this time
said Hui in a voice that seemed to sound
in the alvey's head
you will see me run
go call it got a lucky
the LV ran as no man alive had ever run
he ran as a peregrine falcon Dives he
ran as a Stormwind blows he ran like the
Alvey and nobody has ever run like thelv
not before and not since
but huyi ran on her head easily moving
faster than ever before the Alvey was
even halfway huyi had reached the end of
the track and was on the way back
enough
called up God eloki
they went back into the Great Hall the
mood among the Giants was more relaxed
now more jovial
ah say Dr Loki well the failure of these
two is perhaps understandable but now
now we shall see something to impress us
now is the turn of Thor God of Thunder
mightiest of Heroes Thor whose Deeds are
sung across the worlds gods and Mortals
tell stories of your Feats will you show
us what you can do
Thor stared at him
for a start
I can drink
said Thor
there is no drink I cannot drain
but God aloki considered this
of course he said where is my cup Bearer
the cup Bearer stepped forward
bring me my special drinking horn
the cup Bearer nodded and walked away
returning in moments with a longhorn
it was longer than any drinking horn
that Thor had ever seen but he was not
concerned he was Thor after all and
there was no drinking horn he could not
drain
runes and patterns were engraved on the
side of the horn and there was silver
about the mouthpiece
it is the drinking Horn of this Castle
we have all emptied it here in our time
the strongest and mightiest of us drain
it all in one go
some of us I admit it take two attempts
to drain it
I am proud to tell you that there is
nobody here so weak so disappointing
that it has taken them three drafts to
finish it
it was a long horn but Thor was Thor and
he raised the brimming horn to his lips
and began to drink
the Mead of the Giants was cold and
salty but he drank it down draining the
horn drinking until his breath gave out
and he could drink no longer
he expected to see the horn emptied
but it was as full as when he had begun
to drink
or nearly as full
I had been led to believe that you were
a better Drinker than that said it got a
lucky triley still I know you can finish
it at a second draft as we all do
Thor took a deep breath and he put his
lips to the horn and he drank deeply and
drank well
he knew that he had to have emptied the
horn this time and yet when he lowered
the horn from his lips it had gone down
by only the length of his thumb
the Giants looked at Thor and they began
to jeer but he glared at them and they
were silent
ah
said guardaloki
so the tales of the Mighty Thor
are only Tales
well even so we will allow you to drink
the horn dry on your third attempt
there cannot be much left in there after
all
Thor raised the horn to his lips and he
drank and he drank like a god drinks
drank so long and so deeply that Loki
and thealvi simply stared at him in
astonishment
but when he lowered the horn the Mead
had gone down by only another Knuckles
worth
I am done with this
said Thor and I am not convinced that it
is only a little Mead
utga Loki had his cup Bearer take away
the horn
it is time for a test of strength
can you lift up a cat
he asked Thor
what kind of a question is that of
course I can pick up a cat
well said guardaloki we have all seen
that you are not as strong as we thought
you were
youngsters here in odgaard practice
their strength by picking up my house
cat now I should warn you you were
smaller than any of us here and my cat
is a Giant's cat so I will understand if
you cannot pick her up
I will pick up your cat
said Thor
she's probably sleeping by the fire
Loki let us go to her
the cat was sleeping but she roused when
they entered and sprang into the middle
of the room
she was gray and she was as big as a man
but Thor was mightier than any man and
he reached around the cat's belly and
lifted her with both hands intending to
raise her High over his head
the cat seemed unimpressed she arched
her back raising herself forcing Thor to
stretch up as far as he could
Thor was not going to be defeated in a
simple game of lifting a cat
he pushed and he strove and eventually
one of the cat's feet was lifted above
the ground
from far away Thor and theelvey and Loki
heard a noise as if of huge rocks
grinding together the rumbling noise of
mountains in pain
it's not your fault that you cannot pick
up my house cat Thor it is a large cat
and you are a scrawny little fellow at
best compared to any of our Giants
he grinned
scrawny little fellow said Thor why
I'll wrestle any one of you after what
we've seen so far said utga Loki
I would be a terrible host if I let you
wrestle a real giant you might get hurt
and I'm afraid that none of my men would
wrestle someone who could not drain my
drinking horn who could not even lift up
the family cat
but I will tell you what we could do
if you wish to wrestle I will let you
wrestle my old Foster mother
your Foster mother
Thor was incredulous
she is old yes but she taught me how to
wrestle long ago and I doubt she has
forgotten
she is shrunken with age so she will be
closer to your height
she is used to playing with children
and then seeing the expression on Thor's
face he said her name is Ellie and I
have seen her defeat men who seemed
stronger than you when she wrestled them
do not be overconfident though
I would prefer to wrestle your men
said Thor
but I will wrestle your old nurse
they sent for the old woman
and she came
so frail so gray so wizened and wrinkled
that it seemed like a breeze would blow
her away
she was a giant yes but only a little
taller than Thor
her hair was wispy and thin on her
ancient head
Thor wondered how old this woman was
she seemed older than anyone he had ever
encountered
he did not want to hurt her
they stood together facing each other
the first to get the other one down onto
the ground would win
Thor pushed the old woman and he pulled
her he tried to move her to trip her to
force her down but she might as well
have been made of rock for all the good
it did
she looked at him the whole time with
her colorless old eyes
and said nothing
and then the old woman reached out and
gently touched Thor on the leg
he felt his leg become less firm where
she had touched him and he pushed back
against her but she threw her arms
around him and bore him toward the
ground he pushed as hard as he could but
to no avail and soon enough he found
himself forced onto one knee
stop
we have seen enough great Thor
you cannot even defeat my old Foster
mother
I do not think any of my men will
wrestle you now
Thor looked at Loki
and they both looked at the Alvey
they sat beside the great fire under the
Giants showed them hospitality
the food was good and the wine was less
salty than the Mead from the Giant's
drinking horn
but each of the three of them said less
than he usually would have said during a
feast
the companions were quiet and they were
awkward and humbled by their defeat
they left the Fortress of utgaard at
dawn and King utga Loki himself walked
beside them as they left
well
foreign
how did you enjoy your time in my home
they looked up at him gloomily
not much
said Thor
I've always prided myself on being
powerful
and right now I feel like a nobody and a
nothing
I thought I could run fast said the
Alvey
and I've never been beaten at an eating
contest
said Loki
they passed through the gates that
marked the end of utkar De Loki's
stronghold
you know
said the Giant you are not no bodies
and you are not nothing
honestly if I knew last night what I
know now I would never have invited you
into my home
and I'm gonna make very certain you are
never invited in again
you see
I tricked you
all of you
with illusions
The Travelers looked at the giant who
smiled down at them
do you remember screaming
he asked the giant of course
that was me I used illusion to make
myself so large and to change my
appearance
the laces of my provision bags were tied
with unbreakable iron wire and could be
undone only by Magic
when you hit me with your Hammer Thor
while I pretended to sleep I knew that
even the lightest of your blows would
have meant my death so I used my magic
to take a mountain and put it invisibly
between the hammer and my head
look over there
far away was a mountain in the shape of
a saddle with the valleys plunging into
it three Square shaped valleys the last
one going deepest of all
that was the mountain I used
cedotgarloki
those valleys are your blows
Thor said nothing but his lips grew thin
and his nostrils flared and his red
beard prickled
Loki said
tell me about last night in the castle
was that illusion too
of course it was have you ever seen
Wildfire come down a valley burning
everything in its path
you think you can eat fast
you will never eat as fast as logi for
Logie is fire incarnate and he devoured
the food and the wooden trough it was in
as well by burning it
I have never seen anyone eat as quickly
as you
Loki's green eyes flashed with anger and
with admiration for he loved a good
trick as much as he hated being fooled
how fast can you think boy he asked can
you think faster than you can run
of course
said the Alvey I can think faster than
anything
which is why I had you run against who
you is thought
it does not matter how fast you ran and
none of us have ever seen anyone Run
Like You the LV even you cannot run
faster than thought
the Alvey said nothing
he wanted to say something to protest or
to ask more questions when Thor said in
a low Rumble like thunder echoing on a
distant Mountaintop
and me
what did I actually do last night
was no longer smiling
a miracle
he said
you did The Impossible
you could not perceive it but the end of
the drinking horn was in the deepest
part of the sea you drank enough to take
the ocean level down to make Tides
because if you Thor the sea water will
rise and ebb forevermore I was relieved
that you did not take a fourth drink you
might have drunk the ocean dry
the cat to whom you tried to lift was no
cat
that was Yeoman Gunda the midgard
serpent the snake who goes around the
center of the world it is impossible to
lift the mid-guard serpent
and yet you did and you even loosened
the coil of it when you lifted its paw
from the ground
do you remember the noise you heard that
was the sound of the Earth moving
and the old woman
asked Thor your old nurse
what was she
his voice was very mild but he had hold
of the shaft of his hammer and he was
holding it comfortably
that was Ellie old age
no one can beat old age because in the
end she takes each of us makes us weaker
and weaker until she closes our eyes for
good all of us
except you though
you wrestled old age and we marveled
that you stayed standing that even when
she took power over you you fell down
Only onto one knee we have never seen
anything like last night Thor never and
now that we have seen your power we know
how foolish we were to let you reach
utgaard
I plan to defend my Fortress in the
future and the way that I plan to defend
it best is to ensure that none of you
ever find utgaard or see it again and to
be quite certain that whatever happens
in the days to come
none of you will ever return
Thor raised his hammer high above his
head but before he could strike
udgada Loki was gone
look
said the Alvi
The Fortress was gone
there was no trace of utga Loki's
stronghold or the grounds it was in
now the three Travelers were standing on
a desolate plane with no signs of any
kind of Life whatsoever
let's go home said Loki and then he said
that was well done
brilliantly deployed illusions
I think we've all learned something
today
I will tell my sister that I raced
thought
said the Alvey I will tell rossva I ran
well
but Thor said nothing
he was thinking about the night before
and wrestling old age
of drinking the sea
he was thinking
about the midgard serpent
the apples of immortality
one
this was another time that there were
three of them exploring in the mountain
wastes on the edge of yachtenheim the
home of the Giants
this time the three of them were Thor
and Loki and heineer
Heine was an old God he had given the
gift of reason to humans
food was hard to find in those mountains
and the three gods were hungry and
getting hungrier
they heard a noise the lowing of distant
cattle and they looked at each other and
grinned the grins of hungry men who
would eat that night
they came down into a Green Valley a
place of life where huge oak trees and
high pine trees boarded Meadows and
streams and there they saw a herd of
cattle huge and fat on the Valley's
grass
they dug a pit and built a fire of wood
in the pit and they slaughtered an ox
and buried it in the bed of hot coals
and they waited for the food to be done
they opened the pit but the meat was
still raw and bloody
again they lit a fire
again they waited again the meat had not
even been warmed by the heat of the fire
did you hear something
asked Thor
what said heineer I heard nothing
I heard it said Loki listen
they listened and the sound was
unmistakable
somebody somewhere was laughing at them
vast and amused
the three Gods looked all around them
but there was no one else in the valley
only themselves and the cattle
and then Loki looked up
on the highest branch of the tallest
tree was an eagle it was the largest
eagle that they had ever seen a giant of
an eagle
and it was laughing at them
do you know why our fire will not cook
our dinner
asked Thor
I might know
said the eagle
my you do look hungry why don't you eat
your meat raw that is what Eagles do we
tear it with our beaks
but you do not have beaks do you
we are hungry said hi near could you
help us cook our dinner
in my opinion
said the eagle there must be some kind
of Magic on your fire draining its heat
and its power
if you promise to give me some of your
meat for myself
I'll give your fire back its power
we promise
said Loki you can help yourself to your
portion as soon as there is cooked meat
for all of us
the eagle flew once around the meadow
beating its wings in gusts so powerful
that the coals in the pit flared and
flamed and the gods were forced to hold
on to each other to keep from being
blown off their feet
and then it returned to its perch high
in the tree
this time they buried the meat in the
fire pit with a good heart and they
waited
it was the summer when the sun barely
sets in the Northlands and the day lasts
forever so it was late in the night that
still felt like day when they opened the
pit to be met with the Glorious smell of
cooked beef tender and ready for their
knives and their teeth
as the pit was opened the eagle swooped
down and seized in its claws the two
rear haunches of the ox along with a
shoulder and began to tear at it with a
ravenous beak Loki was Furious seeing
much of his dinner about to be devoured
and he struck at the eagle with his
spear hoping to force it to drop its
plundered food
the eagle flapped its wings hard
creating a wind so strong it almost
knocked the gods over and it dropped the
meat
Loki had no time to enjoy his Triumph
because he discovered the spear was
stuck in the great Bird's side and as
the eagle took off into the air it
carried him with it
Loki wanted to let go of his spear but
his hands were stuck to the shaft he
could not let go
the bird flew low so Loki's feet were
dragged over stones and gravel over
Mountainside and over trees there was
magic at work and it was a magic
mightier than anything Loki could
control
please he shouted stop this you're gonna
tear my arms from my sockets my boots
are already destroyed you are going to
kill me
the eagle soared off the side of the
mountain encircled gently in the sky
with only the crisp air between them and
the ground
perhaps I will kill you it said
whatever it takes to make you put me
down gasps Loki whatever you want please
I want
said the eagle it done
and I want her apples
the apples of immortality
Loki hung in the air
it was a long way down
was married to breakey god of poetry and
she was sweet and gentle and kind
she carried a box with her made of Ash
wood which contained golden apples when
the gods felt age beginning to touch
them to frost their hair or ache their
joints then they would go to itun
she would open her box and allow the god
or goddess to eat a single Apple
as they ate it their youth and power
would return to them without idan's
apples the gods would scarcely be gods
you are not saying anything
I think said the eagle I will drag you
over some more rocks and mountain tops
perhaps I will also drag you through
some deep Rivers this time
I'll get the apples for you said Loki I
swear it just let me down
the eagle said nothing but with a twitch
of a wing it began to descend to a Green
Meadow from which a fire's smoke Rose
swoop down to a Thor and high near were
standing open-mouthed looking up at them
as the eagle flew above the fire pit
Loki found himself falling still
grasping his Spear and he tumbled onto
the grass
with a cry the eagle beat its wings and
Rose above them and in moments it was a
tiny dot in the sky
I wonder what that was about
said Thor
who knows
said Loki
we left you some food
said hi there
Loki had lost his appetite which his
friends attributed to his flight in the
air
nothing else interesting or out of the
ordinary occurred on their way home
2.
the next day Idan was walking through
Asgard greeting the gods looking at
their faces to see if any of them were
beginning to look old
she passed Loki normally Loki ignored
her but this morning he smiled at her
and greeted her it done so good to see
you I feel age upon me he told her I
need to taste one of your apples
you do not look as if you're aging she
said I hide it well said Loki oh my
aching back
oh old age is a terrible thing her done
they're done opened her Ashwood box and
gave Loki a golden apple
he ate it with enthusiasm devouring it
seeds and all
then he made a face
ah oh dear he said I thought you'd have
well nicer apples than this
What A peculiar thing to say
said it done
never before had her apples been
received like this normally Gods talked
only about the Perfection of the flavor
and how good it was to feel young again
Loki they are the apples of the Gods the
apples of immortality
Loki looked unconvinced
perhaps he said but I saw some apples in
the forest that were finer in every way
than your apples look nicer smelled
nicer tasted nicer than these I think
they were apples of immortality too
perhaps a better kind of immortality
than yours
he watched Expressions chasing each
other across sidhan's face disbelief
puzzlement and concern
these are the only apples like this that
there are she said
Loki Shrugged I'm just telling you what
I saw
he said
Idan walked beside him
where are these apples
she asked
over there not sure I could tell you how
to get there but I could take you
through the forest it's not a long walk
she nodded
but when we see the apple tree said Loki
how will we be able to compare those
apples to the ones in your Ash box back
in Asgard I mean I could say they are
even better than your apples and you
would say nonsense Loki these are
shriveled crab apples compared to my
apples and how could we tell
don't be silly said it done I will bring
my apples we will compare them
oh said Loki what a clever idea well
then let's go
he led her into the forest a done
holding tightly to her Ash box
containing the apples of immortality
after half an hour of walking Idan said
Loki I am starting to believe that there
are no other apples and there is no
apple tree
that's unkind of you and hurtful said
Loki the apple tree is just at the top
of that Hilda
they walked up to the top of the hill
there is no apple tree here said it done
tell me that Tall Pine with the eagle in
it
is that an eagle
asked Loki
it's very big
as if it heard them the eagle spread its
wings and dropped from the pine tree
no Eagle am I
said the eagle
but the Giant fiasi in Eagle shape here
to claim the beautiful Idan you will be
a companion to my daughter scarthy and
perhaps you will learn to love me but
whatever happens time and immortality
have run out for the gods of Asgard so
say I so says theazi
it seized a done in one Talent claw and
the Ashwood books of apples in the other
and it Rose into the sky above Asgard
and was gone
hmm so that's who that was
said Loki to himself I knew it wasn't
just an eagle
and he made his way home hoping vaguely
that nobody would notice that Idan and
her apples were gone or that if they did
it would be long after anyone would
connect her disappearance with Loki
taking it done into the forest
three
you were the last to see her
said Thor rubbing the knuckles of his
right hand
no I wasn't said Loki why would you even
say that
and you haven't become old like the rest
of us
said Thor
I'm old but I'm lucky
said Loki I wear it well
Thor grunted entirely unconvinced
his Red Beard was now Snow White with a
few pale orange hairs in it like a once
proud fire become white ashes
hit him again said Freya
her hair was long and gray and the lines
in her face were deep and Care worn
she was still beautiful but it was the
beauty of age not of a golden-haired
maiden he knows where Idan is and he
knows where the apples are
the necklace of the brisings still hung
around her neck but it was dull and
tarnished and it did not shine
Odin father of the Gods held on to his
staff with knobby arthritic fingers blue
veined and twisted his voice always
booming and commanding was now cracked
and Dusty
do not hit him a Thor
he said in his old voice
see I knew that you at least would see
reason all father said Loki I had
nothing to do with it why would he done
have gone anywhere with me she didn't
even like me
do not hit him repeated Odin and he
peered at Loki with his one good eye now
Glaucus Gray
I want him to be whole and unbroken when
he is tortured they are heating the
fires now and sharpening the blades and
collecting the rocks
we may be old but we can torture and we
can kill as well as ever we could when
we were in our Prime and had the apples
of it done to keep us Young
the smell of burning coals reached
Loki's nostrils
if
he said
if I manage to work out what happened to
it done and If I Were Somehow to bring
her and her apples back to Asgard safely
could we forget all about the torture
and death
it is your only chance at life
said Odin in a voice so old and cracked
that Loki could not tell whether it was
the voice of an old man or an old woman
bring it done back to as God and the
apples of immortality
Loki nodded
unfasten These Chains he told them I'll
do it I'll need freya's Falcon feather
cloak though
my cloak asked freyja
I'm afraid so
Freya walked stiffly away and returned
with a cloak covered with falcon
feathers
Loki's chains were unfastened and he
reached for the cloak
don't think you can just fly off and
never return
said Thor and he stroked his white beard
meaningfully
I may be old now he said but if you do
not return ancient desire My will hunt
you down wherever you hide and I and my
hammer will be your death for I am still
a Thor and I am still strong
you are still extremely irritating said
Loki save your breath and you can use
your strength in making a pile of wood
shavings beyond the walls of Asgard an
enormous pile of wood shavings you will
need to cut down many trees and Chip
them into thin shavings I'll need a long
high pile along the wall
so you should start now
then Loki wrapped the Falcon cloak
tightly about himself and in full
conform flapped his wings and Rose
faster even than an eagle and was gone
flying North
toward the lands of the frost Giants
four
Loki flew in the shape of a falcon
without pause until deep in the lands of
the frost Giants he reached the Fortress
of the Giant theazi and he perched on
the high roof observing all that went on
beneath
he watched theazi in giant form Lumber
out of his keep and walk across the
shingle to a rowing boat bigger than the
largest whale
theazi hauled the boat down the Strand
into the cold Waters of the northern
ocean and road with huge Strokes out
into the sea
soon he was lost to sight
then Loki flew as a falcon about the
keep peering into each window as he went
in the farthest room through a barred
window he saw it done
sitting and weeping and he perched on
the bus
cease you're weeping he said it is I
Loki here to rescue you
done glad at him with red rimmed eyes
it is you who are the source of my
troubles
she said well perhaps but that was so
long ago that was yesterday's low-key
today's Loki is here to save you and to
take you home
how
she asked
do you have the apples with you
I am a goddess of the Acer she told him
where I am the apples also are
she showed him the box of apples
that makes things simple said Loki close
your eyes
she closed her eyes and he transformed
her into a hazelnut in its shell with
the green husk still clinging to it
Loki closed his Talons on the nut hopped
up to and Between the Bars of the window
and began the journey home
the Aussie had a poor days fishing
no fish were biting for him
he decided that the best use of his time
would be to return to his keep and pay
court to it done
he would tease her by telling her just
how with her and her apples gone all the
gods were frail and withered drooling
palsied quivering hulks slow of thought
and crippled in mind and body
he rode home to his keep and went in a
run to idan's room
it was empty
the Aussie Surah Falcon's feather on the
ground and he knew in that moment where
it done was and who had taken her
he leapt into the sky in the form of an
eagle even Huger and mightier than any
he had been before and he began to beat
his wings and flew faster and ever
faster toward Asgard
the world moved beneath him the wind
blew about him he went even faster so
fast that the air itself boomed with the
sound of his passing
the Aussie flew onward he left the Land
of the Giants and entered the land of
the Gods when he spotted a falcon ahead
of him theazi let out a scream of rage
and increased his speed
the gods of Asgard heard the Screech and
the boom of the Wings and they went to
the high walls to see what was happening
they saw the little Falcon coming toward
them the enormous eagle so close behind
it
Falcon was so close
now
asked Thor
said Freya
Thor Set Fire to the wood shavings there
was a moment before they caught a moment
just long enough for the Falcon to fly
over them and to settle inside the
castle and then with a warmth they burst
into flame it was like an eruption a
gout of fire higher than the walls of
Asgard itself terrifying and
unimaginably hot
theosian Eagle form could not stop
himself could not slow his flight could
not change direction he flew into the
Flames the Giant's feathers caught fire
the tips of his Wings burned and a
featherless Eagle he fell from the air
and crashed into the ground with a bang
and a thud That Shook The Fortress of
the Gods
burned dazed stunned the naked Eagle was
no match even for elderly Gods before he
could transform himself back into giant
shape he was already wounded and as he
changed from bird into giant a blow of
Thor's hammer parted the Aussie from his
life
5.
edun was glad to be reunited with her
husband
the gods ate of the apples of
immortality and regained their youth
Loki hoped that the matter was now done
with
it wasn't the Aussie's daughter scuffy
put on her armor picked up her weapons
and came to Asgard to avenge her father
my father was everything to me
she said you killed him his death fills
my life with tears and misery I have no
joy in my life I am here for vengeance
or for compensation
the Acer and scuffy bargained for
compensation back and forth
in those days each life had a price on
it and theazi's life was priced highly
when the negotiations were concluded the
gods and scarthy had agreed that she
would be recompensed for her father's
death in three ways
first that she would be given a husband
to take the place of her dead father
it was obvious to all the gods and
goddesses that scarthy had set her heart
on balder the most beautiful of all the
gods
she kept winking at him and staring
until balder would look away blushing
and embarrassed
second that the gods would make her
laugh again
because she had not smiled or laughed
since her father had been killed
and last that the gods would make it so
that her father would never be forgotten
the gods let her choose a husband from
their number but they had one condition
they told her that she could not choose
her husband by seeing his face
the male Gods would all stand behind a
curtain with only their feet showing
scathy would have to choose her husband
by his feet
One By One The Gods walked past the
curtain and scathy stared at their feet
ugly feet she would say as each set of
feet went past
and she stopped and exclaimed with
delight
those are the feet of my husband to be
she said those are the most beautiful
feet they must be balder's feet nothing
on Boulder could be ugly
and while balder was indeed beautiful
the feet she had chosen Scotty
discovered when the curtain was lifted
belonged to nyod God of Chariots father
a Frey and a Freya
she married him then and there
at the wedding Feast that followed her
face was the saddest any of the Acer had
ever seen
Thor nudged Loki
go on he said make her laugh
this is all your fault anyway
Loki's side
really
Thor nodded and he tapped the handle of
his hammer meaningfully
Loki shook his head
then he went outside to pens where the
animals were kept and he came back into
the wedding Feast leading a large
extremely irritated billy goat
Loki irritated the goat even more by
tying a strong rope tightly around its
beard
then Loki tied the other end of the Rope
around his own private parts
he tugged on the rope with his hand the
goat screamed feeling its beard tugged
painfully and it jerked back the Rope
pulled hard on Loki's private parts Loki
screamed and grabbed the Rope again
yanking it back
the gods laughed
it did not take a lot to make the gods
laugh but this was the best thing they
had seen in a long time they placed bets
on what would be torn off first the
goat's beard or Loki's private parts
they mocked Loki for screaming like a
fox wailing in the night time exclaimed
balder stifling his laughter
Loki sounds like a weeping baby giggled
Baldur's brother hod who was blind but
still laughed every time Loki screeched
scuffy did not laugh although the ghost
of a smile began to haunt the corners of
her lips every time the goat screamed or
Loki wailed like a child in pain her
smile became a little wider
Loki pulled the goat pulled Loki
screamed and yanked the Rope the goat
yelped and pulled back even harder
the Rope snapped
Loki shot through the air clutching at
his groin and landed smack in scuffy's
lap whimpering and broken
scothy laughed like an avalanche in
Mountain Country she laughed as loudly
as a carving Glacier she laughed so long
and hard that tears of laughter
glittered in her eyes and as she laughed
for the first time she reached out and
squeezed her new husband nyord's hand
Loki clambered down from her lap and
staggered away both hands clutching
between his legs as he went glaring in
an aggrieved fashion at all the gods and
goddesses who only laughed the louder
we are done then said Odin the all
father to scathi the Giant's daughter
when the wedding Feast was over
or almost done
he signals gothy to follow him out into
the night and she and Odin walked out of
the hall together with her new husband
by her side
beside the funeral pyre the gods had
made for the remains of the giant two
huge orbs sat filled with light
those orbs said Odin to scuffy those
were your father's eyes
the old father took the two eyes and
threw them up into the night sky where
they burned and glittered together
side by side
look up into the night in mid-winter
you can see them there Twin Stars One
blazing beside the other
those two stars are thiazi's eyes
they're shining still
story of Geth and fray
one
Frey the brother of Freya was the
mightiest of the Vania
he was handsome and Noble a warrior and
a lover but he was missing something in
his life and he did not know what it was
The Mortals of midgard revered Frey he
made the seasons they said Frey made the
fields fertile and brought forth life
from the dead ground
the people worshiped Frey and they loved
him
but this did not fill the empty place
inside him
Freight took stock of his possessions
he had a sword so powerful and
remarkable that it fought by itself
but this did not satisfy Frey
he had gulen bursty the boar with the
golden bristles created by the dwarf
Brock and his brother Atri
ghoul University pooled Frey's Chariot
it could run through the air and over
the water run faster than any horse and
run even in the darkest night for its
golden bristles Shone so brightly
but goldenbursty did not satisfy Frey
he had skiff blaffner a boat made for
him by the three dwarves known as the
sons of Vivaldi it was not the biggest
ship there was
that was nagelfar the death ship made
from the untrimmed fingernails of the
dead but there was room for all of the
Acer on board
when the sales of skiff blaffner were
set the winds were always fair and it
took you wherever you needed to go
even though it was the second biggest
ship there had ever been and would hold
all the Acer Frey could fold skiff
bluffner up like a cloth and place it in
his bag
it was the best of All Ships
but skeith blathner did not satisfy him
he owned the finest residence that was
not as guard it was our Fame the home of
the light elves where he was always
welcomed and acknowledged as Overlord
there was nowhere like our Fame and yet
it did not satisfy him
Frey's servant Scania was one of the
light elves he was the finest of
servants wise of counsel and fair of
face
Frey ordered Skinner to harness gulin
busti
and they set out for Asgard together
when they reached asgar they walked
toward Valhalla the Great Hall of the
slain
in Odin's Valhalla lived the anheria
those who fight alone all the men who
have died nobly in battle since the
beginning of time
their souls are taken from the
battlefields by Valkyries the warrior
women charged by Odin with the task of
bringing the souls of the noble dead
battle slain to their ultimate reward
there must be a lot of them
said skier near who had not been there
before
there are
Frey told him but there are more to come
and still more will be needed when we
fight the wolf
they heard the sound of battle as they
approached the fields around Valhalla
they heard the Clash of metal on metal a
third of metal on flesh
as they watched they saw powerful
warriors of all ages and places
well-matched in Battle dressed in their
War gear each man fighting his hardest
soon enough half the men were lying dead
on the grass
enough
call The Voice the battle is over for
the day
at this those who were still standing
helped the dead men get up from the
courtyard floor
their wounds healed as Frey and skier
near watched and they clambered onto
their horses
all the soldiers who had fought that day
whether they had won or lost rode home
to Valhalla the Hall of the noble dead
Valhalla was an enormous Hall it had 540
doors and each door allowed 800 Warriors
to walk abreast it seated more people
than the mind could hold
in the hall the Warriors cheered as the
feast began
they were eating boar meat ladled out
from an enormous cauldron this was the
meat of the boar sarimner every night
they would Feast upon the Boar's meat
and each morning the Monstrous Beast
would be alive again ready to be slain
later that day and to give its life and
its flesh to feed the noble dead
no matter how many of them there were
there would always be enough meat
Mead was brought for them to drink
so much Mead for so many warriors said
Skinner
where does it come from
it comes from a goat called hadron
Frey told him she stands on top of
Valhalla and eats the leaves of the tree
called lyrath which is what we call that
branch of igdrasal the world tree
from her others the finest Mead flows
there will always be enough for every
Warrior
they walked to the high table where Odin
sat
he had a bowl of meat in front of him
but did not taste it he would stab a
piece of meat with his knife from time
to time and flick it onto the ground to
be eaten by one of his wolves Gary and
Frankie
two Ravens sat on Odin's shoulders and
he would give the Ravens scraps of meat
as well while they whispered to him of
things that were happening far away
he isn't eating
whispered skin near
he does not need to said Frey he drinks
he only needs wine nothing else come on
we are done here
why were we here
asked Skinner as they walked out of one
of the 540 doors of Valhalla
because I wanted to make certain that
Odin was here in Valhalla with the
Warriors and not in his own Hall at the
halidskulf the observation point
they entered Odin's Hall wait here said
Frey
Frey walked alone into Odin's Hall and
clambered up onto the khalid's gelf The
Throne from which Odin could see
everything that happened across the nine
worlds
Frey looked out across the worlds he
looked to the South to the East and to
the west and he did not see the thing he
was looking for
and then he looked to the north and saw
the thing he was missing in his life
ski Amir was waiting by the door when
his master came from the hall
there was an expression on Frey's face
Scania had never seen before
and Skinner was afraid
they left that place without speaking
two
Frey drove the Chariot pulled by
golembursty back to his father's Hall
Frey spoke to nobody when they got there
neither his father Nord who is the
master of all who sailed the seeds nor
his stepmother scuffy the lady of the
mountains he went to his room with a
face as dark as midnight
and there he stayed
on the third day njord sent for skirmia
Frey has been here for three days and
three nights nyod said
he has not eaten nor has he drunk
anything
this is true
said Skinner
what have we done to anger him so asked
Nord my son who was always so gentle and
filled with kind wise words now says
nothing only looks at us with Fury what
did we do to upset him so
I do not know
said Skinner
then said New York you must go to him
and ask him what is happening ask him
why he is so angry he will not speak to
any of us
I would rather not
said Skinner
but I cannot refuse you Lord
he is in such a strange dark mood I'm
afraid of what he will do if I ask him
ask him
Sydney art and do what you can for him
he is your master
skier near of the light elves went to
where Frey stood looking out at the sea
Frey's face was clouded and troubled and
Skinner hesitated to approach him
Frey
said Skinner
Frey said nothing
Frey
what has happened you are angry or you
were downcast
something has happened you have to tell
me what is happening to you
I am being punished
said Frey and his voice sounded Hollow
and distant
I went to the all father's holy seat
and I looked out at the world
for my arrogance in believing I had a
right to the observation place
my happiness has been taken from me
forever
I have paid for my crime and I am paying
still
my Lord
said scan near
what did you see
Frey was silent and Skinner thought he
had once again sunk into a troubled
silence
but after some time he said
I looked to the north
I saw a dwelling there a splendid house
and I saw a woman walking up to the
house
I have never seen a woman like her
nobody who looks like her nobody who
moves like her as she raised her arms to
unlock the door to her house the light
glanced off her arms and it seemed to
illuminate the air and to brighten the
sea and because she is in it the whole
world is a brighter and more beautiful
place
and then I looked away and saw her no
more and my world became dark and
hopeless and empty
who is she
asked skinnier
a giant
her father is gimme the Earth giant her
mother a mountain giant our Botha
and is this beautiful creature have a
name
her name is ger
ay was silent once more
said
your father is worried about you we are
all worried
is there something I can do
if you will go to her and ask for her
hand
I would give anything
I cannot live without her bring her back
to me to be my wife whatever her father
says I will pay you so well
you were asking a lot my Lord
said Skinner
I will give anything
said pray fervently and he shivered
skin and nodded
I will do this thing Lord
he hesitated
Frey may I look at your sword
Frey took out his sword and held it out
for skier near to examine
there is no other sword like this it
will fight by itself without a hand
holding it it will always protect you no
other sword no matter how powerful can
penetrate its defense they say that this
sword could even Prevail against the
Flaming sword of certa
the fire demon
Skinner Shrugged
it is a fine sword
if you wish me to bring you Gareth the
sword will be my wages
Fray nodded ascent
he gave skier near his sword and a horse
to ride
skinhead traveled North until he reached
the house of gimir
he entered as a guest and explained who
he was and who had sent him
he told the beautiful Geth of his master
Frey
he is the most Splendid of all the gods
he told her he has dominion over the
rain and the weather and the Sunshine
and he gives the folk of midgard good
harvests and peaceful days and nights he
watches over the prosperity and
abundance of humanity all people love
and worship him
he told gath of the beauty of Frey and
of his power
he told her of the wisdom of Frey and at
the last he told her of the love frabor
for her how he had been heartstruck by a
vision of her and now would no longer
eat or sleep drink or speak until she
agreed to be his bride
girth smiled and her eyes Shone with joy
tell him yes
she said I will meet him on the aisle
Barry for the wedding nine days from now
go and tell him
Scania returned to nyod's Hall
before he could even climb down from his
horse Frey was there even more pale and
even more one than when he had left him
what news he asked do I Rejoice or do I
despair
she will take you to be her husband nine
days from now on the island of Barry
said Skinner
Frey looked at his servant without Joy
the nights without her and my life last
forever
he said one night is so long
two nights are even longer how will I
manage to cope with three nights four
days feel like a month to me and you
expect me to wait nine days
and skier near looked at his Lord with
pity
nine days from that day on the Isle of
Barry Frey and Gaff met for the first
time and they married in a field of
waving Bali
she was as beautiful as he had dreamed
and her touch was as fine her kiss as
sweet as he had hoped their wedding was
blessed and some say that their son
fionir went on to become the first king
of Sweden
he would drown in a vat of mead late one
night hunting in the darkness for a
place to piss
Skinner took the sword he had been given
phrase sword that fought all by itself
and he returned to alfame with it
the beautiful gath filled the hole in
Frey's life and the hole in his heart
Frey did not miss his sword and he did
not replace it when he fought the giant
Bailey he killed him with a Stags antler
Frey was so strong he could kill a giant
with his bare hands
even so he should not have given his
sword away
Ragnarok is coming when the sky splits
asunder and the dark powers of muspel
March out on their War Journey Frey will
wish he still had his sword
fishing Expedition
the gods arrived at a Year's huge Hall
at the edge of the sea
we are here called Thor who was at the
head of the company make a feast for us
Aya was the greatest of the sea Giants
his wife was ran into whose net those
who drown at Sea are gathered his nine
daughters are the waves of the sea
Aya had no desire to feed the gods but
he also had no wish to fight them
he looked Thor in the eye and said
I will make a banquet and it will be the
finest Feast that any of you will ever
have attended my servant femafeng will
serve each of you diligently bringing
you as much food as your Bellies can
hold as much ale as you can drink
I have only one condition
I will throw the feast but you must
first bring me a cauldron big enough to
brew ale for you all there are so many
of you and your appetites are huge
the gods had no such cauldron and
without The Cauldron he did not have to
give the feast
Thor asked the other gods for advice but
each God he asked was of the opinion
that such a cauldron did not exist
finally he asked tear god of battle God
of War
tear scratched his chin with his left
hand
which was his only hand
on the edge of the world see he said
lives the giant king Hamer he owns a
cauldron three miles deep it's the
biggest cauldron there has ever been
can you be sure
asked Thor
tear nodded
hamir is my stepfather he's married to
my mother he said she is a giant
I have seen the great cauldron with my
own eyes and as my mother's son I will
be welcome in Jemez Hall
tieren Thor climbed into Thor's Chariot
pulled by the goats snarla and grinder
and swiftly they traveled to hamir's
enormous Fortress
Thor tied the goats to a tree and the
two made their way inside
there was a giantess in the kitchen
cutting up onions as big as Boulders and
cabbages the size of boats
Thor could not help staring the old
woman had 900 heads each head uglier and
more terrifying than the last
he took a step backward
if tear was Disturbed he did not show it
tear called out greetings grandmother
we're here to see if we can borrow Jemez
cauldron to brew our beer
such tiny things I thought you were mice
said tears grandmother and when she
spoke it sounded like a crowd of people
shouting
you do not want to talk to me grandson
you should talk to your mother
she called out we have guests your son
is here with a friend
and in moments another giantess walked
in
this was heimer's wife Tia's mother
she was dressed in Golden cloth and she
was as beautiful as her mother-in-law
was alarming
she carried two of the tiniest giant
symbols which she had filled with beer
Thor and tear gripped the Thimbles which
were the size of buckets and they drank
the beer with enthusiasm
it was excellent beer
the giantess asked Thor his name Thor
was about to tell her but before he
could speak tyr said his name is VR
mother he's my friend and an enemy of
the enemies of hamir and the Giants
they heard a distant rumbling like
thunder on the Peaks or mountains
crumbling or huge waves crashing to
Shore and the Earth shook with each
Rumble
my husband is coming home
said the giantesse I hear his gentle
Footsteps in the distance
the rumbling became more distinct and
seemed to be coming rapidly closer
my husband is often bad tempered when he
gets home wrathful and Grim of mind he
treats his guests badly
the giantess warned them why don't you
get under that kettle and stay there
until he's cheerful enough for you to
come out
she hid them beneath a kettle on the
floor of the kitchen
it was dark under there
the ground shook a door slammed and Thor
and tear knew that Heimer must be home
they heard the giantess tell her husband
that they had guests her son and a
friend and that he had to be on his best
behavior as a gracious host and not kill
them
why
the Giant's voice was loud and petulant
the little one is our son tear you
remember him
the big one's name is Theo be nice to
him
four
Thor our enemy Thor who has killed more
Giants than anyone else even other
Giants Thor whom I have sworn to slay If
Ever I encounter him Thor that vior
said his wife calming him down not Thor
feel he's our son's friend and an enemy
of your enemies so you have to be nice
to him
I am Grim of mind and wrathful of spirit
and I have no desire to be nice to
anyone said a huge rumbling Giant's
voice
where are they hiding
no just behind that beam over there
said his wife
Thor and tear heard a crash as the beam
she had pointed to was smashed and
broken
this was followed by another series of
crashes as one after another all the
kettles in the kitchen were knocked down
from the ceiling and destroyed
are you finished breaking things
asked tears mother
I suppose so
said hey Miss voice grudgingly
then look under that kettle she said the
one on the floor that you didn't destroy
the kettle beneath which tear and Thor
were hidden was lifted and they found
themselves staring up at an enormous
face its features Twisted into a sulky
scowl
this Thor new was hamir the giant king
his beard was like a forest of
ice-covered trees in mid-winter his
eyebrows like a field of thistles his
breath as a rank and foul as a midden in
a bog
hello tear
said hey without enthusiasm
hello father said tear with if possible
even less pleasure
you will join us as guests at dinner
said hey man he clapped his hands
the door of the hall opened and a giant
Ox was led in its coat shining its eyes
bright its horns sharp it was followed
by another even more beautiful and then
the last Ox even finer than the first
two
these are the most excellent oxen in
existence so much bigger and fatter than
the beasts of midgard or Asgard
I am hamare confided enormously proud of
my herd of cattle they are my treasures
and the Delight of my eyes I treat them
like my own children
and for a moment his scowling face
seemed to soften
the grandmother with 900 heads killed
each Ox skinned it and tossed it into
her enormous cooking pot
the pot boiled and bubbled over a fire
which hissed and spat and she stirred it
with a spoon as big as an oak tree
she sang quietly to herself as she
cooked in a voice like a thousand old
women all singing at the tops of their
voices at once
soon enough the food was ready
you are guests here do not stand on the
ceremony take as much as you can eat
from the pot
said hey Mary expansively The Strangers
were small after all how much could they
eat
after all the oxen were enormous
Thor said he didn't mind if he did and
he proceeded to devour two of The Oxen
all by himself one after the other
leaving nothing but clean picked Bones
then he belched in a satisfied way
that's a lot of food for your
said hey man
it was meant to feed us for several days
I do not think I have ever seen even a
giant eat two of my oxen at once before
I was hungry said Thor and I got a
little carried away
look tomorrow why don't we go out
fishing I hear you are quite a fisherman
Heimer prided himself on his skills at
fishing
I am an excellent fisherman he said we
can catch tomorrow night's dinner
I too am a fine fisherman said Thor
he had never fished before but how hard
could it be
we'll meet tomorrow at dawn out on the
dock
said hey man
in their huge bedroom that night tear
said to Thor
I hope you know what you are doing
of course I do
said Thor
but he didn't he was just doing whatever
he felt like doing
that was what Thor did best
in the gray light Before Dawn Thor met
Hamer on the dock
I should warn you little veor said the
giant that we will be going far out into
the icy waters I row farther out into
the cold and stay out longer than a tiny
thing like you can survive icicles will
form on your beard and your hair and you
will turn blue with cold probably you
will die
doesn't worry me said Thor I like the
cold it's bracing what are we using for
bait
I already have my own bait said hey man
you must find your own you could look in
the field of The Oxen for it nice big
maggots in the ox done after all bring
whatever you want from there
Thor looked at hamir
he thought about hitting him here with
his hammer but then he would never get
The Cauldron not without a fight
he walked back up the shore
in the meadow was Jemez herd of
beautiful oxen
there were giant patties of dung on the
ground with huge maggots writhing and
burrowing in them but Thor avoided all
of them
instead he walked over to the biggest
most majestic fattest of the beasts
raised his fist and thumped it between
the eyes killing it instantly
Thor ripped off the beast's head placed
it in his sack and carried it down to
the Sea
Hamer was in the boat he had already
cast off and was rowing out of the Bay
Thor jumped into the cold water and swam
out hauling his sack behind him
he grabbed the back of the boat with
numb fingers then hauled himself on
board dripping with seawater ice
crusting his red beard
ah said Thor that was fun nothing to
wake you up on a cold morning like a
good swim
mer said nothing
Thor took the other set of oars and they
began to row together soon enough the
land was gone and they were alone on the
Waters of the Northern sea the ocean was
gray the waves were choppy and high and
the wind and the seagulls screamed
Hamas stopped rowing
we will fish here he said
here asked Thor we've hardly gone out
into the sea at all
and he picked up the oars and began
single-handedly to row them into deeper
waters the boat flew across the waves
stop boom Tamir these waters are
dangerous this is where yorman Gunda the
midgard serpent is to be found
Thor stopped rowing
Hamed took two large fish from the
bottom of the boat
he gutted them with this sharp sharp
bait knife tossed the guts into the sea
then impaled the fish on the hooks of
his line
Hamer dropped his baited fishing line
he waited until the line jerked and
twitched in his hand and then he holed
up the line
two monstrous whales hung from it the
hugest whales that Thor had ever seen
Hema grinned with pride
not bad
said Thor
he pulled the head of the ox from his
sack
when Jemez saw the dead eyes of his
favorite Ox his face froze
I got bait
said Thor helpfully from the ox field
like you said
expressions of shock of horror and of
anger chased each other across hamir's
huge face
but he said nothing
Thor took hamer's fishing line rammed
the ox's head onto the hook and through
the line and the head into the ocean
he felt it sink to the bottom
he waited
fishing he said to Hamer I suppose it
must all be about learning patience
it's a bit dull his knit
I wonder what I'm gonna catch for our
dinner
and that was when the sea erupted
yormongunda the midgard serpent had
bitten down on the huge Ox head and the
hook had dug deep into the roof of its
mouth the serpent writhed in the water
trying to free itself
Thor held onto the line
it's going to drag us under boom tamer
in horror let go of the lime
Thor shook his head he strained against
the fishing line determined to hold on
the Thunder God slammed his feet through
the bottom of the boat and he used the
sea bottom to brace himself and he began
to haul jormungunda up on board
the serpent spat gouts of black poison
toward them Thor ducked and the poison
missed him he continued to pull
it's the midgard serpent you fool
shouted hamir let go of the line we'll
both die
Thor said nothing
just hold the line in hand over hand his
eyes fixed on his enemy
I will kill you he whispered to the
serpent beneath the Roar of the waves
and the howl of the wind and the
thrashing and screaming of the Beast
or you will kill me
This I Swear
he said it beneath his breath but he
could have sworn that the midgard
serpent heard him it fixed him with its
eyes and the next gout of poison came so
close to Thor that he could taste it on
the Ocean Air
the poisons sprayed his shoulder and it
burned where it touched
Thor simply laughed and hauled again
somewhere it seemed to thaw in the
distance hamair was babbling and
grumbling and shouting about the
Monstrous Serpent and about the sea
rushing into the rowing boat through the
holes in the bottom and about how they
would both die out here in the cold cold
ocean so far from dry land
Thor did not care about any of this he
was fighting the serpent playing it
letting it exhaust itself thrashing and
pulling
Thor began to pull the fishing line back
onto the boat
the mid-guard Serpent's head was almost
within Striking Distance Thor reached
down without glancing away and his
fingers closed around the half of his
hammer
he knew just where the head of the
hammer would need to strike to kill the
serpent one more heave on the fishing
line and
Jemez bait knife flashed and the line
was cut
your mangunda the serpent reared up high
above the boat
then tumbled back into the sea
Thor threw his hammer at it
but the monster was already gone
vanished into the cold gray Waters
the hammer returned and Thor caught it
he turned his attention back to the
sinking fishing boat hamir was
desperately baling the water from the
bottom
amen bailed the water and Thor rode the
boat back to shore
the two whales that haymere had caught
earlier at the prow of the boat made the
rowing harder than it normally would
have been
there's the shore
gasped Hamer but my home is still many
miles distant
we could make land here
said Thor
only of you are willing to carry the
boat and me and the two whales I caught
all the way to my hall said hey
exhausted
boom all right
Thor jumped over the side of the fishing
boat a few moments later Hamer felt the
boat Rising into the air
Thor was carrying them on his back boat
oars hamir and whales carrying them
along the shingle at the edge of the sea
when they reached hamir's Hall Thor
lowered the boat to the ground
there
said Thor I brought you home as you
requested now I need a favor from you in
return
what is it asked hamir
your cauldron the huge one you brew beer
in I want to borrow it Hamer said
you were a mighty fisherman and you row
hard but you were asking for the finest
Brewing Kettle in existence the beer
that is magically brewed in it is the
best of beers I will only lend it to
someone who can break the cup I drink
from
hmm
that doesn't sound very hard
said Thor
they ate roast whale meat for dinner
that night in a hall filled with many
headed Giants all of them shouting and
happy and most of them drunk
after they had eaten Hamed drained the
last of the beer from his drinking cup
and called for silence then he handed
the cup to Thor
smash it he said smash this cup and the
cauldron in which I brew my beer is
yours as my gift to you
fail and you die
Thor nodded
the Giants stopped their joking and
their songs
they watched him wearily
Jemez Fortress was built of stone
Thor took the drinking cup half did it
in both hands then threw it with all his
might against one of the Granite pillars
that held up the roof of the banqueting
hall
there was an ear splitting crash and the
air was filled with blinding dust
when the dust settled Jaime got up and
walked over to what was left of the
Granite pillar
the cup had gone through first one
pillar then another breaking them into
tiny fragments of stone
in the rubble of the third pillar
was the drinking cup
a little dusty but quite undamaged
hamare held his drinking cup above his
head and the Giants cheered and laughed
and made faces at Thor with all their
heads along with crude gestures
haymere sat down at the table once more
see he said to Thor I didn't think you
were strong enough to break my cup
he held up the cup and his wife poured
beer into it
Jemez slurped the beer
best beer you will ever taste he said
here wife pour more beer for your son
and for his friend vior let them taste
the best beer there is and be sad that
they will not be taking my cauldron home
with them and that they will never again
taste beer this good
also they will be sad that I need to
kill vior now for my cup remains
Unbroken
Thor sat at the table beside tear and
picked up a lump of charred whale meat
and chewed it resentfully
the Giants were raucous and loud and now
we're ignoring him
tears mother leaned over to fill Thor's
cup with beer
you know
she said quietly my husband has a very
hard head
he's stubborn and thick sculled
they say the same of me said Thor
no she said as if she were talking to a
small child
he has a very hard head hard enough to
break even the toughest of cups
Thor drained his beer it really was the
best beer he had ever tasted
he stood up and walked over to Hamer
could I try again
he asked
the Giants in the hall all laughed at
this and none of them laughed louder
than hamir well of course you can he
said
Thor picked up the drinking cup
he faced the stone wall hefted the cup
once twice then turned swiftly on his
heel and smashed the cup down on Jemez
forehead
fragments of the cup fell one by one
unto hemez lap
there was silence in the hole then
a silence broken by a strange heaving
noise
Thor looked around to see what the noise
was and then he turned back and saw
hamir's shoulders shaking
the giant was crying in huge heaving
sobs
my greatest treasure is no longer mine
said hey man
I could always tell it to brew me ale
and The Cauldron itself would magically
Brew the finest beer
never again will I say
Brew me ale my cauldron
Thor said nothing
Heimer looked at tear and said bitterly
if you want it stepson then take it it's
huge and heavy it takes over a dozen
Giants to lift it do you think you were
strong enough
tear walked over to the cauldron
he tried to lift it once twice
but it was too heavy even for him
he looked at Thor
Thor Shrugged grasped The Cauldron by
the rim and flipped it so he was inside
it and the handles clattered at his feet
then The Cauldron began to move with
Thor inside it headed toward the door
while all around the hall many headed
Giants stared open-mouthed
hey man no longer wept tear glanced up
at him thank you for the cauldron he
said and then keeping the moving
cauldron between himself and hamir tyr
edged out of the room
Thor and tear left the castle together
untethered Thor's goats and climbed into
Thor's chariot
Thor still carried The Cauldron on his
back
the goats ran as best they could but
while snala ran well and ran fast even
with the weight of the Giants cauldron
to pull grinder limped and staggered its
leg had once been broken for marrow and
Thor had set it but the goat had never
been as strong again
grinder bleated in pain as it ran
can't we go any faster
asked tear
we can try said Thor and he whipped the
goats so they ran even faster
tear looked behind they are coming he
said the Giants are coming
they were indeed coming with Hamer at
their rear
urging them on all the Giants of that
part of the world are many headed
monstrous Bunch the Giants of the waste
misshapen and deadly an army of Giants
all intent on getting their cauldron
back
go faster
said tear
it was then that the goat called grinder
stumbled and fell throwing them out of
the chariot
Thor staggered to his feet then he threw
the cauldron to the ground and began to
laugh
what are you laughing about asked tear
there are hundreds of them
Thor hefted mjolnir his hammer I didn't
catch and kill the serpent he said not
this time
but a hundred Giants almost make up for
it
methodically
enthusiastically one after the next Thor
killed the Giants of the waste until the
Earth ran black and red with their blood
tear fought one-handed but he fought
bravely and he slew his share of giants
that day
when they were done and all the Giants
were dead
Thor crouched beside grinder his injured
goat and helped it back to its feet
the goat limped as it walked and Thor
cursed Loki whose fault it was that his
goat was lame
Hamer was not among the slain and tear
was relieved for he did not want to
bring his mother any additional distress
Thor carried The Cauldron to Asgard to
the meeting of the Gods
they took the cauldron to a year
here
said Thor a brewing cauldron big enough
for all of us
the sea Giant sighed
it is indeed what I asked for he said
very well
there will be an Autumn Feast for all
the gods in my hall
he was as good as his word and since
then every year once the Harvest is in
the gods drink the finest ale there ever
was or will be in the autumn in the sea
Giant's hole
the death of balder
1.
nothing there is that does not love the
sun it gives us warmth and life it melts
the bitter snow and ice of winter
it makes plants grow and flowers bloom
it gives us the long summer evenings
when the darkness never comes it saves
us from the bitter days of mid-winter
when the darkness is broken for only a
handful of hours and the Sun is cold and
distant like the pale eye of a corpse
Baldur's face Shone like the sun
he was so beautiful that he illuminated
any place he entered
belda was Odin's Second Son and he was
loved by his father and by all things
he was the wisest the mildest the most
eloquent of all the Acer
he would pronounce judgment and all
would be impressed by his wisdom and his
fairness
his home the hole called braithablik was
a place of joy and music and knowledge
balder's wife was Nana and he loved her
and only her
their son for seti was growing up to
become as wise a judge as his father
there was nothing wrong with Boulder's
life or his world
save only one thing
Boulder had bad dreams
he dreamed of Worlds ending and of the
Sun and the Moon being eaten by a wolf
he dreamed of pain and death Without End
he dreamed of Darkness of being trapped
Brothers slew Brothers in his dreams and
nobody could trust anyone else
in his dreams a new age would come upon
the world an age of storm and of murder
balder would wake from these dreams in
tears troubled beyond all telling
belder went to the gods and he told them
of his nightmares
none of them knew what to make of the
dreams and they too were troubled
all but one of them
when Loki heard balder talk of his bad
dreams
Loki smiled
Odin set out to find the cause of his
son's dreams
he put on his gray cloak and his broad
brimmed hat and when folk asked his name
he said he was Wanderer son of warrior
nobody knew the answers to his questions
but they told him of a Seer a wise woman
who understood all dreams
she could have helped him they said
but she was long dead
at the end of the world was the wise
woman's grave
Beyond it to the east was the realm of
the Dead who had not died in battle
ruled over by hell Loki's Daughter by
the giantesse angor Botha
Odin traveled East and he stopped when
he reached the grave
the all father was the wisest of the
Acer and he had given his eye for more
wisdom
he stood by the grave at the end of the
world and in that place he invoked the
darkest of runes and called on Old
Powers long forgotten
he burned things and he said things and
he Charmed and he demanded
the storm wind whipped at his face and
then the wind died and a woman stood
before him on the other side of the fire
her face in the shadows
it was a hard journey coming back from
the Land of the Dead
she told him I've been buried here for
such a long time
rain and snow have fallen on me
I do not know you man who raised me
what do they call you
they call me Wanderer
said Odin Warrior was my father
tell me the news from hell
the dead wise woman stared at him
Boulder is coming to us
she told him
we are Brewing Mead for him there will
be despair in the world above but in the
world of the Dead there will be only
rejoicing
Odin asked her who would kill Boulder
and her answer shocked him
he asked who would avenge balda's death
and her answer puzzled him
he asked who would mourn balder and she
stared at him across her own grave as if
she was seeing him for the first time
you are not Wanderer
she said
her dead eyes flickered and there was
expression on her face you are Odin who
was sacrificed by himself to himself so
long ago
and you are no wise woman you are she
who was in life anger Botha Loki's lover
mother to hell to jormungunda The
midgard Serpent and to Fenris wolf
said Odin
the dead giantesse smiled
ride home little Odin
she told him run away run back to your
hall no one will come to see me now
until my husband Loki escapes from his
bonds and returns to me and Ragnarok the
Doom of the Gods tearing all asunder
approaches
and then there was nothing in that place
but Shadows
Odin left with his heart heavy and with
much to think about
even the gods cannot change Destiny and
if he was to save bowder he would have
to do it with cunning and he would need
help
there was one other thing that the dead
giantess had said that Disturbed him
why did she talk about Loki escaping his
bonds
wondered Odin
Loki is not bound
and then he thought
not yet
2.
Odin kept his own counsel
but he told frigg his wife mother of the
gods that Boulder's dreams were true
dreams and that there were those who
meant their favorite son harm
frigg thought
practical as ever she said
I do not believe it
I shall not believe it there is nothing
that despises the sun and the warmth and
the life it brings the Earth and by the
same token there is nothing that hates
my son balda the Beautiful
and she set out to ensure that this was
so
she walked the Earth and exacted an oath
from each thing that she encountered
never to harm balda the Beautiful
she spoke to fire and it promised it
would not burn him Water Gave its oath
never to drown him
Ayan would not cut him nor would any of
the other metals Stones promised never
to bruise his skin friggs spoke to trees
to beasts and to birds and to all things
that creep and fly and crawl and each
creature promised that its kind would
never hurt balder
the trees agreed each after its kind
Oaken Dash Pine and Beach Burch and fur
that their wood could never be used to
hurt balder
she conjured diseases and spoke to them
and each of the diseases and infirmities
that can hurt or wound a person agreed
that it too would never touch Boulder
nothing was too insignificant for frigg
to ask
save only the mistletoe a creeping plant
that lives on other trees it seemed too
small Too Young Too insignificant and
she passed it by
and when everything had sworn its oath
not to harm her son frigg returned to
Asgard
Boulder is safe she told the Acer
nothing will hurt him
all of them doubted her even balder
frigg picked up a stone and whipped it
toward her son
the stone skipped around him
belder laughed with delight and it was
as if the sun had come out
the gods smiled and then one by one they
threw their weapons at Boulder and each
of them was astonished and amazed swords
would not touch him Spears would not
pierce his flesh
all the gods were relieved and happy
there were only two faces in Asgard that
were not radiant with joy
Loki was not smiling or laughing
he watched the gods hack at balder with
axes and with swords or drop enormous
rocks on belder or try to strike belder
with huge knotted wooden clubs and laugh
as the clubs and swords and rocks and
axes avoided balder or touched him like
gentle feathers and Loki brooded
and slipped away into the Shadows
the other was belder's brother hod
who was blind
what is happening
asked blind Hood
will somebody please tell me what is
happening
but nobody talked too hot
he listened to the sound of Mary Making
and joy and he wished he could be a part
of it
you must be very proud of your son
said a kindly woman to frigg frigg did
not recognize the woman but the woman
beamed when she looked at balder and
frigg was indeed proud of her son
everybody loved him after all
but won't they hurt him the poor darling
throwing things at him like that if I
were his mother I would be afraid for my
son
they will not hurt him said Frank
no weapon can hurt Boulder no disease no
Rock no tree
I have taken an oath from all the things
there are that can harm
that's good said the kindly woman I'm
pleased
but are you sure you didn't miss any of
them
not a one said frigg all the trees the
only one I did not bother with was the
mistletoe it's a creeper that grows on
the oak trees west of Valhalla but it's
too young and too small ever to do any
harm you could not make a club from
mistletoe
my my said the kindly woman mistletoe
well truth to tell I wouldn't have
bothered with that either
much too weedy
the kindly woman had begun to remind
frigg of someone but before the goddess
could think who it was tear held up an
enormous rock with his good left hand
held it high above his head and crashed
it down on Boulder's chest
it disintegrated into dust before ever
it touched the shining God
when frigg turned back to talk to the
kindly woman she was already gone and
Frank thought no more about it
not then
Loki in his own form traveled to the
west of Valhalla
he stopped by a huge oak tree
here and there pendulous clumps of green
mistletoe leaves and pale white berries
hung from the oak seeming even more
insignificant when seen next to the
Grandeur of the oak
they grew directly out of the bark of
the oak tree
Loki examined the berries the stems and
the leaves he thought about poisoning
Boulder with mistletoe berries but that
seemed too simple and straightforward
if he was going to do harm to balda he
was going to hurt as many people as
possible
three
blind hod stood to one side listening to
the merriment and the shouts of joy and
astonishment coming from the green and
he sighed
hard was strong even if he was sightless
one of the strongest of the Gods and
usually falder was good about making
certain that he was included
this time even balder had forgotten him
you look sad
a familiar voice
it was Loki's voice
that's hard Loki everyone is having such
a good time I hear them laughing and
Baldur my beloved brother he sounds so
happy I just wish I could be part of it
that is the easiest thing in the world
to remedy
said Loki
HUD could not see the expression on his
face but Loki sounded so helpful so
friendly and all the gods knew that Loki
was clever
hold out your hand
hod did so Loki put something into it
closed hod's fingers around it
it is a little wooden Dart I made
I will bring you close to Boulder and I
will point you at him and you shall
throw it at him as hard as you can throw
it with all your might and then all the
gods will laugh and balder will know
that even his blind brother has taken
part in his day of Triumph
Loki walked hard through the people
toward the hubbub
here said Loki this is a good place to
stand now when I tell you throw the dart
it is only a little Dart
said hod wistfully I wish I were
throwing a spear or a rock
a little Dart will do said Loki the tip
of it is sharp enough
throw it there like I told you
a mighty cheer and a laugh a club made
of knotted thornbush wood studded with
sharp iron Nails was swung by Thor into
Boulder's face the club skipped up and
over his head at the last moment and
Thor looked as if he were dancing it was
very comical
now
whispered Loki now while they are all
laughing
hod through the dart of mistletoe just
as he had been told
he expected to hear cheers and laughter
nobody laughed and nobody cheered
there was silence
he heard gasps and a low muttering
why is nobody cheering me asked blind
hod I threw a dart it was neither big
nor heavy but you must have seen it
Boulder my brother why are you not
laughing
he heard wailing then high and keen and
awful and he knew the voice
it was his mother who wailed
Boulder my son
obelda
o my son
she wailed
it was then that hod knew his Dart had
hit home
how terrible how sad you have killed
your brother
said Loki but he did not sound sad
he did not sound sad at all
four
Boulder lay dead pierced by the
mistletoe Dart
the gods gathered weeping and tearing
their garments Odin said nothing save
only no Vengeance will be taken on hard
not yet not right now not at this time
we are in a place of holy peace
friggs said
who among you wants to win my good
graces by going to hell perhaps she will
let balda return to this world even hell
could not be so cruel as to keep him
she thought for a moment
how was after all Loki's daughter
and we will offer her a ransom to give a
spellder back is there one of you who is
willing to travel to Hell's Kingdom
you might not return
the gods looked at each other
and then one of them raised his hand
this was hermod called the Nimble Odin's
attendant the fastest and the most
daring of the young gods
I will go to hell he said I will bring
back Boulder the Beautiful
they brought forth sleep near Odin's
stallion the eight-legged horse
I might mounted it and prepared to ride
down ever down to greet hell in her High
Hall where only the dead go
as hermod rode into darkness the gods
prepared balda's funeral
they took his corpse and they placed it
on ringhorn balder's ship
they wanted to launch the ship and burn
it but they could not move it from the
shore
they all pushed and heaved even thought
but the ship sat on the shore unmoving
only Boulder had been able to launch his
ship and now he was gone
the gods sent for hirokin the giantess
who came to them riding on an enormous
wolf with serpents for Reigns
she went to the prowl of Boulder's ship
and she pushed as hard as she could
she launched the ship but her push was
so violent that the role as the ship was
on burst into flame and the Earth Shook
and the waves were terrifying
I ought to kill her said Thor still
stinging from his own Failure to Launch
the ship and he grasped the handle of
mjolnir his hammer she shows disrespect
you will do nothing of the kind
said the other gods
I'm not happy about any of this said
Thor I'm gonna kill somebody soon just
to relieve the tension you'll see
balder's body was brought down the
shingle born by four gods
eight legs took him past the crowd
assembled there
Odin was foremost in the crowd of
mourners his Ravens on each shoulder and
behind him the Valkyries and the Acer
there were Frost Giants and Mountain
Giants at balder's funeral there were
even dwarfs the cunning Craftsman from
beneath the ground for all things that
there were mourned the death of balder
balder's wife Nana saw her husband's
body carried past
she wailed and her heart gave out in her
breast and she fell dead onto the shore
They carried her to the funeral pyre and
they placed her body beside boulders
out of respect Odin placed his arm ring
drop near onto the pyre this was the
miraculous ring made for him by the
dwarves proc and Atri which every nine
days would drip eight other rings of
equal Purity and beauty
then Odin whispered a secret
into polda's dead ear
and what Odin whispered none but he and
balder will ever know
balder's horse fully caparisoned was
ridden to the pyre and sacrificed there
in order that it would be able to Bear
its master in the world to come
they lit the pyre
it burned consuming the body of balder
and the body of Nana and his horse and
his possessions
balder's body flamed like the sun
Thor stood in front of the funeral pyre
and he held mjolnir high
I sanctify this pyre he proclaimed
darting grumpy looks at the giantesse
hirokin who still did not thorfelt
appear to be properly respectful
lit one of the dwarfs walked in front of
Thor to get a better view of the pyre
and Thor kicked him irritably into the
middle of the Flames which made Thor
feel slightly better and made all the
dwarfs feel much worse
I don't like this
said Thor testerly I don't like any of
it one little bit I hope Homewood the
Nimble is sorting things out with hell
the sooner balder comes back to life the
better it will be for all of us
five
hermod the Nimble rode for nine days and
nine nights without stopping
he rode deeper and he rode through
Gathering Darkness from Gloom to
Twilight to night to a pitch black
starless dark all that he could see in
the darkness was something golden
glinting far ahead of him
closer he rode and closer and the light
grew brighter
it was gold and it was the thatch of the
bridge across the gyala river across
which all who die must travel
he slowed sleep near to a walk as they
crossed the bridge which swung and shook
beneath them
what is your name
asked a woman's voice who are your kin
what are you doing in the Land of the
Dead
Hamad said nothing
he reached the far end of the bridge
where a maiden stood
she was pale and very beautiful and she
looked at him as if she had never seen
anything like him before
her name was mouthguf
and she guarded the bridge
yesterday enough dead men to fill five
kingdoms crossed this bridge but you
alone cause it to shake more than they
did though there were men and horses
beyond all Counting
I can see the red blood beneath your
skin you are not the color of the Dead
they are gray and green and white and
blue
your skin has life beneath it
who are you why are you traveling to
hell
I am hermod he told her I am a son of
Odin and I'm writing to Hell on Odin's
horse to find balder have you seen him
no one who saw him could ever forget it
she said balda the beautiful crossed
this bridge nine days ago
he went to Hell's Great Hall
I thank you
said hermod that is where I also must go
it is downward and northward she told
him always go down and keep traveling
north
you will reach Hell's Gate
Hamad rode on
he rode Northerly and he followed the
path down until he saw before him a huge
high wall and the gates To Hell which
were higher than the tallest tree
then he dismounted from his horse and he
tightened the girth strap
he remounted and holding tight to the
saddle he urged sleep near faster and
faster and at the last it leapt a jump
like no horse has made before or since
and it cleared the gates of hell and
landed safely upon the other side in
Hell's domain where no living person can
ever go
hermod rode to the Great Hall of the
dead dismounted and walked inside
balder his brother was seated at the
head of the table at the seat of Honor
Felder was pale his skin was the color
of the world on a gray day when there is
no sun
he sat and drank the Mead of hell and
ate her food when he saw her mod he told
him to sit beside him and spend the
night with them at the table
on the other side of balda was Nana his
wife and next to her and not in the best
of tempers was a dwarf called lit
in Hell's world the Sun never Rises and
the day can never begin
Hamad looked across the hall
and he saw a woman of peculiar Beauty
the right side of her body was the color
of flesh but the left-hand side of her
body was dark and ruined like that of a
week-old corpse that you might find
hanging from a tree in the forest or
frozen into the snow and hermod knew
that this was hell Loki's daughter whom
the all father had set to rule over the
lands of the Dead
I have come for Boulder said hermod to
hell Odin himself sent me
all things there are mourn him
you must give him back to us
hell was impassive
one green eye stared at her mod and one
sunken Dead Eye
I am hell she said simply
the Dead Come to Me
and they do not return to the lands
above
why should I let balda go
all things mourn him his death unites us
all in misery God and frost giant dwarf
and elf the animals mourn him and the
trees even the metals Weep the stones
dream that brave Baldo will return to
the lands that know the sun let him go
hell said nothing
she watched balder with her mismatched
eyes
and then she sighed
he is the most beautiful thing and I
think the best thing ever to come to my
Realm
but if it is truly as you say if all
things mourn Boulder if all things love
him
then I will give him back to you
Ahmad threw himself at her feet that is
Noble of you thank you thank you great
Queen
she looked down at him
get up she said I have not said I will
give him back
this is your task hermod
go and ask them
all the gods and the Giants all the
rocks and the plants ask everything
if all things in the world weep for him
and want him to return I will give balda
back to the Acer and the day
but if one creature will not cry or
speaks against him
then he stays with me forever
hermod got to his feet
balda led him from the hall and he gave
hermod Odin's ring drop near to return
to Odin as evidence that hermod had been
to Hell
Nana gave him a linen robe for frigg and
a golden ring for Fuller friggs
handmaiden lit just grimaced and made
Rude gestures
hermod clambered back on sleep near
this time the gates of hell were opened
for him as he left and he retraced his
steps
he crossed the bridge and eventually he
saw daylight once again
in Asgard hermod returned the arm ring
drop near to Odin the all father and
told him all that had happened and all
that he had seen
while hermod was in the Underworld Odin
had had a son to replace Boulder this
son named Vali was the son of Odin and
the goddess rind
before he was a day old the baby found
and slew hard
so bold as death was Avenged
six
the Acer sent Messengers across the
world
The Messengers of the Acer rode like the
wind and they asked each thing they
encountered if it wept for balder so
that balder could be free of Hell's
world
the women wept and the men the children
and the animals
birds of the air wept for Boulder as did
the Earth the trees the stones even the
metals The Messengers encountered wept
for Boulder in the way that a cold iron
sword will weep when you take it from
the freezing cold into the sunlight and
warmth all things wept for balder
The Messengers were returning from their
mission triumphant and Overjoyed Alder
would soon be back among the Acer
they rested on a mountain on a Ledge
beside a cave and they ate their food
and drank their Mead and they joked and
they laughed
who is that called a voice from inside
the cave and an elderly giant test came
out
there was something Vaguely Familiar
about her but none of the messengers was
entirely certain what it was
I am thook she said which means
gratitude
why are you here
we have asked each thing there is if it
would weep for balder who is dead
beautiful balder killed by his blind
brother
for each of us Mrs Boulder as we would
miss the sun in the sky where it never
to shine again and each of us weeps for
him
the giantesse scratched her nose cleared
her throat and spat onto the Rock
how old thook won't weep fabalda she
said bluntly alive or dead old Odin's
son brought me nothing but misery and
aggravation I'm glad he's gone good
riddance to bad rubbish let hell keep
him
then she shuffled back into the darkness
of her cave and was lost to sight
The Messengers returned to Asgard and
told the gods what they had seen and
that they had failed in their mission
for there was one creature that did not
weep for Boulder and did not want him to
return
an old giantesse in a cave on a mountain
and by then they had also realized who
old Fook reminded them of
she had moved and talked much like Loki
the son of loyvee
I expect it was really low-key in
disguise
said Thor
of course it was Loki it's always Loki
Thor hefted his hammer mjolnir and
gathered a group of the Gods to go
looking for Loki to take their Revenge
but the crafty Troublemaker was nowhere
to be seen
he was hiding far from Asgard hugging
himself in Glee at his own cleverness
and waiting for the fuss to die away
the last days of Loki
one
Boulder was dead
and the gods were still mourning his
loss
they were sad
and the gray Reigns fell unceasingly
and there was no joy in the land
Loki when he returned from one of his
journeys to distant Parts was
unrepentant
it was the time of autumn feast in Ayers
Hall
where the gods and elves were gathered
to drink the sea Giant's fresh brewed
ale brewed in The Cauldron Thor had
brought back from the land of the Giants
so long ago
Loki was there
he drank too much of a Year's ale drank
himself Beyond joy and laughter and
trickery and into a brooding Darkness
when Loki heard the gods praise aeyer's
servant femafeng for his swiftness and
diligence he sprang up from the table
and stabbed femafeng with his knife
killing him instantly
the horrified Gods drove Loki out of the
feast Hall into the darkness
time passed
the feasting continued but now it was
subdued
there was a commotion at the doorway
and when the gods and goddesses turned
to find out what was happening they saw
that Loki had returned
he stood in the entry to the hall
staring at them with a sardonic smile on
his face
you are not welcome here
said the Gods
Loki ignored them he walked up to where
Odin was sitting
all father
you and I mixed our blood long long ago
did we not
Odin nodded
we did
Loki smiled even more widely
did you not swear back then great Odin
that you would drink at a banqueting
table only if Loki your sworn Blood
Brother drank with you
Odin's good gray eye stared into Loki's
green eyes
and it was Odin who looked away
let the wolf's father Feast with us
said Odin gruffly
and he made his son Vida move over to
make room for Loki to sit down beside
him
Loki grinned with malice and Delight
he called for more of a Year's ale and
gulped it down
one by one that night Loki insulted the
gods and the goddesses
he told the gods that they were cowards
till the goddesses that they were
gullible and unchaste each insult was
woven with just enough truth to make it
wound
he told them that they were fools
reminded them of things they thought
were safely forgotten he smeared and
jeered and raised old scandals and would
not stop making everyone there miserable
until Thor arrived at the feast
a Thor ended the conversation very
simply he threatened to use mjolnir to
shut Loki's evil mouth for good and send
him to hell all the way to the hall of
the Dead
Loki left the feast then but before he
swaggered out he turned to a year
you brewed fine ale
said Loki to the Sea Giant
but there will never be another Autumn
Feast here
Flames will take this hole your skin
will be burned from your back by the
fire everything you love will be taken
from you
This I Swear
and he walked away from the gods of
Asgard into the dark
2.
Loki sobered up the next morning and
thought about what he had done the night
before
he felt no shame for shame was not
Loki's way but he knew that he had
pushed the gods too far
Loki had a home on a mountain near the
sea and decided to wait there until the
gods had forgotten him
he had a house on the top of the
mountain with four doors one on each
side allowing him to see danger coming
toward him from any direction
during the day Loki would transform
himself into a salmon
and he would hide in the pool at the
bottom of fronang's Falls a high
waterfall that tumbled down the
Mountainside
a stream connected the pool to a little
river
and the river led directly to the Sea
Loki liked plans and counter plans as a
salmon he was fairly safe he knew the
gods themselves could not catch salmon
as they swam
but then he began to doubt himself
he wondered
could there be a way of catching a fish
in the Deep Waters of the pool beneath
the waterfall
how would he the craftiest of all the
most cunning planner catch a salmon
Loki took a ball of nettle yarn and he
began to knot and weave it into a
fishing net the first such net ever to
be made
yes
he thought if I used this net I could
catch a salmon
now he thought to work out a counter
plan what will I do if the gods weave a
net like this one
he examined the net he had made
he thought
salmon can jump he thought they can swim
upstream even travel up waterfalls I
could jump over the net
something drew his attention
he peered out from first one door and
then another
he was startled the gods were coming up
the Mountainside and they had almost
reached his house
Loki flung The Net Into the Fire and
watched it burn with satisfaction
then he stepped into fronang's Falls
in the shape of a silver salmon Loki was
swept over the waterfall and he vanished
into the depths of the deep pool at the
base of the mountain
the Acer reached Loki's house on the
mountain
they waited by each door cutting off
Loki's Escape if he was still inside
wisest of the Gods walked in through the
first door
once he had been dead and Mead had been
brewed from his blood
but now he was alive once more
he could tell from the fire and from the
half-drunk cup of wine beside it that
Loki had been there only moments before
he arrived
there was no clue to where Loki could
have gone though
classes scanned the sky
then he looked down at the floor
and at the fireplace
he's gone the sniveling little weasel
said Thor coming in through another of
the four doors
he could have transformed himself into
anything we'll never find him
do not be so hasty
said quasir
look
it's only ashes
said Thor
but look at the pattern of it said
Gracia
he bent down touched the ash on the
floor beside the fire sniffed it then
touched it to his tongue
it is the ash of a cord that has been
thrown into the fire and burned cord
just like that ball of nettle twine in
the corner
Thor rolled his eyes
I do not think that the ashes of a
burned cord are going to tell us where
Loki is
you think not
but look at the pattern a crisscross
diamond shape and the squares are
perfectly regular
if I say you are wasting all our time
admiring the shapes that the ash makes
this is foolishness every moment we
spend staring at the ash is time in
which Loki is getting farther and
farther away
perhaps you are right Thor
but to make the squares in the chord
that regular you would need something to
space them with like that piece of scrap
wood on the floor by your foot
you would need to tie one end of the
chord to something as you wove it
something like that stick jutting from
the floor over there
then you would not and thread your rope
weaving it so that one piece of cord
would form up hmm
I wonder what Loki called it
I will call it a net
why are you still jabbering said Thor
why are you staring at Ash and at sticks
and scraps of wood when we could be
chasing Loki classier as you Ponder and
talk your nonsense he is getting away
from us
I think that such a net is this
would be best used to trap fish
said glacier
I am done with you and your foolishness
ah side Thor so it's to be used to trap
fish well bully for you Loki would have
been hungry and so he must have wanted
to catch fish to eat Loki invents things
that's what he does he always was clever
that's why we used to keep him around
you are correct but ask yourself why
would you if you were Loki invent
something to trap fish with and then
throw the net you made onto the fire
when you knew we were coming
because
said Thor creasing his brow and
pondering so hard that distant Thunder
could be heard in the mountaintops
exactly because you would not want us to
find it when we arrived and the only
reason for not wanting us to find it is
to stop us the gods of Asgard from using
it to trap you
Thor nodded slowly
I see he said
then
yes I I suppose so he said and finally
so Loki
is hiding in the deep water pool at the
foot of the waterfall in the shape of a
fish yes exactly I knew you would get
there in the end though
Thor nodded with enthusiasm not entirely
certain how he had come to this
conclusion from ashes on the floor but
happy to know where Loki was hiding
I will go down there to the pool with my
hammer said Thor and I will
I will
we will need to go down there with a net
said farcia the wise God
classic took the remaining nettle twine
and the piece of spacing wood he tied
the end of the twine to the stick and he
began to wrap the twine around the stick
to weave it in and around and through
he showed the other gods what he was
doing and soon each of them was weaving
and knotting
he attached the Nets they made one to
the other until they had a net as long
as the pool
and they made their way down the side of
the waterfall to the base of the
mountain
there was a stream that ran out of the
pool where it overflowed that stream ran
down toward the sea
when they reached the base of frownang's
Falls the gods unrolled the net they had
made
the net was huge and heavy and long
enough to go from one end of the pool to
the other
it took all the Warriors of the Acer to
hold up one end of it and thaw to hold
up the other end
the gods started from one end of the
pool beginning immediately underneath
the falls and wading until they reached
the other side
they caught nothing
there's definitely something living down
there said Thor I felt it push against
the net but it swam down deeper into the
mud and the net went over it
classes scratched his chin thoughtfully
not a problem we need to do it again but
this time we will weigh down the bottom
of the net he said so nothing can get
underneath it
the gods gathered heavy stones with
holes in them and tied each Stone to the
bottom of the net as a weight
the gods waded into the pool again
Loki had been pleased with himself the
first time the gods had entered his pool
he had simply swumed down to the Muddy
Bottom of the pool
slipped between two flat stones and
waited while the net had gone above him
now he was worried
down in the dark and the cold he thought
about this
he could not transform himself into
something else
until he left the water
and even if he did the gods would be
after him now it was safer to remain in
Salmon shape
but as a salmon he was trapped he would
have to do what the gods would not be
expecting they would expect him to head
for the Open Sea he would be safe there
if he got to the Sea even if he would be
easy to spot and catch in the river that
led from the pool to the Bay
the gods would not expect him to swim
back the way he had come up the
waterfall
the gods hauled their net along the
bottom of the pool
they were intent upon what was happening
in the depths and so were taken by
surprise when a huge silver fish bigger
than any salmon they had ever seen
before leapt over the net with a Twist
of its tail and began swimming Upstream
the huge salmon swam up the Falls
springing up and Defying Gravity as if
it had been thrown upward into the air
fasis shouted at the Acer ordering them
to form into two groups one on one end
of the net one on the other
he will not stay in the waterfall for
long it's too exposed his only chance is
still to make it to the Sea so you two
groups will walk along dragging the net
between you meanwhile Thor
who was wise you will Wade in the middle
and when Loki tries that jumping over
the net trick again you must snatch him
from the air like a bear catching a
salmon do not let him go though he is
tricky
Thor said I have seen Bears pluck
leaping salmon from the air
I am strong and I am as fast as any bear
I will hold on
the gods began to drag the net Upstream
toward the place where the huge silver
salmon was biding its time
Loki planned and plotted
as the net came closer Loki knew that
this was the critical moment he had to
LEAP the net as he had done before and
this time he would race toward the sea
he tensed like a spring about to whip
back
and then he shot into the air
Thor was fast he saw the silver salmon
glitter in the Sun and he grabbed it
with his huge hands just as a hungry
bear snatches a salmon from the air
salmon a slippery fish and Loki was the
slipperiest of salmon he wriggled and
tried to slip through Thor's fingers but
Thor simply gripped the fish harder and
squeezed it tightly down by the tail
they say that salmon have been narrower
near the Tail ever since
the gods brought their net and they
wrapped it tightly around the fish and
carried it between them
the salmon began to drown in the air
gasping for water and then it thrashed
and twitched and now they were carrying
a panting Loki
what are you doing
he asked where are you taking me
Thor just shook his head and grunted and
did not reply
Loki asked the other gods
but none of them would tell him what was
happening
and none of them would meet his eye
three
the gods entered the mouth of a cave and
with Loki slung between them they went
down deep into the Earth
stalactites hung from the ceiling of the
cave and bats fluttered and flickered
they went down lower
soon the way was too narrow to carry
Loki and now they let him walk between
them
Thor walked immediately behind Loki his
hand on Loki's shoulder
they went down a long long way
in the deepest of the caves there were
Brands burning and three people stood
there waiting for them
Loki recognized them before he saw their
faces and his heart sank
no
he said do not hurt them
they did nothing wrong
Thor said
they are your sons and your wife
Loki lie Smith
there were three huge flat stones in
that cave
the Acer set each Stone on its side and
Thor took his hammer
he broke a hole through the middle of
each Stone
please let our father go
Sid narfi Loki's son
he is our father said Valley
Loki's other son
you have sworn Oaths that you will not
kill him he is a blood brother and an
oath brother to Odin highest of the Gods
we will not kill him
said quasia
Tommy volley what is the worst thing
that one brother could do to another
for a brother to betray his brother
said volley without hesitating for a
brother to murder her brother as hod
killed balda this is abominable
said
it is true that Loki is a blood brother
to the gods and we cannot kill him
but we are bound by no such Oaths to you
his sons
spoke words to Vali words of change
Words of Power
Farley's human shape fell from him and
where Vali had stood was a wolf foam
flicking its muzzle the intelligence of
Valley was fading from its yellow eyes
to be replaced by hunger by anger by
Madness
it looked at the gods at sigin who had
been its mother
and finally at sonafi
it growled low and long in the back of
its throat
and its hackles Rose
Nafi took a step back only a step
and then the wolf was on him
Nafi was Brave
he did not scream not even when the wolf
that had been his brother tore him apart
ripping open his throat and spilling his
guts onto the rock floor
the wolf that had been volley howled
once long and loudly through
blood-soaked Jaws
then it sprang High over the heads of
the Gods and it ran off into the cave
darkness and would not be seen in Asgard
again
not until the end of everything
the gods forced Loki onto the three
great Stones they put one of the stones
beneath his shoulders one under his
loins and one beneath his knees
the gods took nafi's spilled entrails
and they pushed them through the holes
they had made in the stones binding
Loki's neck and shoulders tightly they
wound the entrails of his son around his
loins and his hips tied his knees and
legs so tightly he could barely move
then the gods transformed the intestines
of Loki's murdered son into Fetters so
tight and so hard that they might have
been iron
sigan Loki's wife had watched as her
husband was bound in the entrails of
their son
and she said nothing
she wept silently to herself for the
pain of her husband for the death and
the dishonor of their sons
she held a bowl although she did not yet
know why
before the gods had brought her there
they had told her to go to her kitchen
and bring the biggest bowl she had
scuffy giant daughter of dead fiazi wife
of neurod of the beautiful feet came
into the cave then
she carried something huge in her hands
something that writhed and twisted she
bent over Loki and placed the things she
carried above him winding it about the
stalactites that hung from the ceiling
of the cave so that its head was just
above Loki's own
it was a snake
cold of I its tongue flickering its
fangs dripping with poison
it hissed and a drop of poison from its
mouth dripped onto Loki's face making
his eyes burn
Loki screamed and contorted writhing and
twisting in pain he tried to get out of
the way to move his head from beneath
the poison the bonds that had once been
the entrails of his own son held him
tightly
One By One The Gods left that place with
grimly satisfied looks on their faces
soon only quasia was left
sigan looked at her bound husband and at
the disemboweled corpse of her wolf
murdered son
what are you going to do to me
she asked
nothing
said quasia
you are not being punished you may do
whatever you wish
and then even he left that place
another drop of the Serpent's Venom
dripped onto Loki's face and he screamed
and threw himself about writhing in his
bonds
the Earth itself Shook at Loki's
threshing
sigan took her bowl and went to her
husband
she said nothing
what was there to say
but she Stood Beside Loki's head with
tears in her eyes and caught each Drop
of Poison as it fell from the snake's
fangs into her Bowl
this all happened long long ago in time
out of mind in the days when the gods
still walked the Earth
so long ago that the mountains of those
days have worn away and the deepest
lakes have become dry land
siggins still Waits beside Loki's head
as she did then staring at his beautiful
Twisted face
the bowl she holds fills slowly one drop
at a time but eventually the poison
fills the bowl to the brim
it is then and only then
but sigin turns away from Loki she takes
the bowl and pours the Venom away and
while she is gone the snake's poison
Falls onto Loki's face and into his eyes
he convulses them jerks and Judds jolts
and twists and writhes so much that the
whole earth shakes
when that happens we here in midgard
call it an earthquake
they say that Loki will be bound there
in the darkness beneath the Earth and
sigan will be with him holding the bowl
to catch the poison above his face and
Whispering that she loves him until
Ragnarok comes
brings the end of days
Ragnarok the final Destiny of the Gods
1.
until now I have told you of things that
have happened in the past things that
happened a long time ago
now I shall tell you of the days to come
I shall tell you how it will end
and then how it will begin once more
these are dark days I will tell you of
dark days and hidden things concerning
the ends of the Earth and the death of
the Gods
listen and you will learn
this is how we will know that the end
times are upon us
it will be far from the age of the Gods
in the time of men
it will happen when the gods all sleep
every God but All-Seeing Handel
he will watch everything as it begins
although he will be powerless to prevent
what he sees from happening
it will begin with the winter
this will not be a normal winter
the winter will begin and it will
continue winter following winter there
will be no spring no warmth
people will be hungry and they will be
cold and they will be angry
great battles will take place all across
the world
Brothers will fight Brothers fathers
will kill Sons mothers and daughters
will be set against each other sisters
will fall in battle with sisters and
will watch their children murder each
other in their turn
this will be the age of cruel winds the
age of people who become as wolves who
Prey Upon each other who are no better
than wild beasts
Twilight will come to the world and the
places where the humans live will fall
into ruins flaming briefly then crashing
down and crumbling into Ash and
devastation
then when the few remaining people are
living like animals the Sun in the sky
will vanish as if eaten by a wolf and
the moon will be taken from us too and
no one will be able to see the stars any
longer
Darkness will fill the air like ashes
like mist
this will be the time of the terrible
winter that will not end
thimble winter
there will be snow driving in from all
directions Fierce winds and cold colder
than you have ever imagined cold could
be an icy cold so cold your lungs will
ache when you breathe so cold that the
tears in your eyes will freeze
there will be no spring to relieve it no
summer no Autumn only winter followed by
winter followed by winter
after that
there will come the time of the great
earthquakes the mountains will shake and
crumble
trees will fall
and any remaining places where people
live will be destroyed
the earthquakes will be so great that
all bonds and shackles and Fetters will
be destroyed
all of them
fenra
the Great Wolf will free himself from
his shackles his mouth will gape his
upper jaw will reach the heavens the
lower jaw will touch the Earth there is
nothing he cannot eat nothing he will
not destroy Flames come from his eyes
and his nostrils
where Fenris wolf walks flaming
destruction follows
there will be flooding too as the Seas
rise and surge onto the land jormungunda
the midgard serpent huge and dangerous
will writhe in its Fury closer and
closer to the land the Venom from its
fangs will spill into the water
poisoning all the sea life it will
spatter its black poison into the air in
a fine spray killing all the seabirds
that breathe it
there will be no more life in the oceans
where the mid-guard serpent rides
the rotted corpses of fish and of whales
of seals and sea monsters will wash in
the waves
all who see the brothers fenrir the wolf
and the mid-guard serpent the children
of Loki
will know death
that is the beginning of the end
the Misty Sky will split apart with the
sound of children screaming and the sons
of muspel will ride down from the
heavens led by certa the fire giant
holding High his sword which burns so
brightly no mortal can look upon it they
will ride across the Rainbow Bridge
across by Frost and the rainbow will
crumble as they ride its once bright
colors becoming shades of charcoal and
of Ash
there will never be another rainbow
Cliffs will crumble into the sea
Loki who will have escaped from his
bonds beneath the Earth will be the
Helmsman of the ship called nagelfar
this is the biggest ship there will ever
have been it is built of the fingernails
of the Dead nagelfar floats upon the
flooded Seas
the crew looks out and sees only dead
things floating and rotting on the
surface of the ocean
Loki steers the ship but its Captain
will be Harem leader of the frost Giants
the surviving Frost Giants all follow
Crim huge and inimical to humanity
the achrim soldiers in the final battle
Loki's troops are the legions of hell
they are the uneasy dead the ones who
died shameful deaths who will return to
the Earth to fight once more as walking
corpses determined to destroy anything
that still loves and lives above the
Earth
all of them Giants and the dead and the
burning sons of moospel will travel to
the battle plane called vigrith
vigrid is huge 300 miles across
Fenris wolf pads his way there also and
the midgard serpent will navigate the
flooded Seas until it too is close to
vigrith
then it will rise up onto the sand and
force itself ashore only its head in the
first mile or so of its body
most of it will remain in the sea
they will form themselves into battle
order
and the sons of moospel will be there in
Flames the Warriors of hell and Loki
will be there from beneath the Earth
the frost Giants will be there harim's
troops the mud freezing where they stand
fenra will be with them and the
mid-guard serpent
the worst enemies that the mind can
imagine will be there that day
heimdel will have seen all this as it
occurs
he sees everything after all he is the
Watchman of the Gods
now
and only now
he acts
hendel will blow the gyala horn the horn
that once was Mimi's and he will blow it
with all his strength
as God shakes with its noise and it is
then that the sleeping Gods will wake
and they will reach for their weapons
and assemble beneath igrazel Atwood's
well to receive the blessing and the
counsel of the norms
Odin will ride the horse sleep near to
me as well to ask the head of mime for
Council for himself and for the Gods
Mimi's head will whisper its knowledge
of the future to Odin just as I am
telling it to you now
what nime Whispers to Odin will give the
all-father Hope even when all looks dark
the great ash tree iggrassel the world
tree
will shake like a leaf in the wind and
the Acer and with them the inheria all
the Warriors who died good deaths in
battle will dress for war and together
they will ride out to vigrith the final
Battlefield
Odin will ride at the head of their
company
his armor gleams and he wears a golden
helmet
Thor will ride beside him mjolnir in his
hand
they reached the field of battle
and the final battle will begin
Odin makes straight for fenrir the wolf
now grown so huge as to be Beyond
Imagining the all-father grips Gung near
his spear in his fist
Thor will see that Odin is heading for
the Great Wolf and Thor will smile and
whip his goats to Greater speed and he
will head straight for the midgard
serpent his hammer in his iron gauntlet
Frey makes for Sota flaming and
monstrous sort his flaming sword is huge
and it burns even when it misses
Frey fights hard and well but he will be
the first of the Acer to fall
his sword and his armor are no match for
certa's burning sword
Frey will die missing and regretting the
loss of the sword he gave to scanner so
long ago for love of Geth
that sword would have saved him
the noise of battle will be furious
Odin's Noble Warriors are locked in
pitched battle with the Evil Dead Loki's
troops
the hellhound garm will growl
he is smaller than fenra but he is still
the mightiest and most dangerous of all
dogs
he has also escaped his shackles beneath
the Earth and is returned to rip the
throats of the warriors on the Earth
tear will stop him
tear the one-handed and they will fight
man and Nightmare dog
tear fights bravely but the battle will
be the death of both of them
gum dies with its teeth locked in tears
throat
Thor will finally kill the midgard
serpent as he has wanted to do for so
long Thor smashes the great Serpent's
brains in with his hammer he will leap
back as the sea snake's head tumbles
onto the battlefield
Thor is a good nine feet away from it
when its head crashes to the ground but
that is not far enough
even as it dies the serpent will empty
its venom sex over the Thunder God in a
thick black spray
Thor grunts in pain and then Falls
lifeless to the Earth
poisoned by the creature he slew
Odin will battle fenrir bravely but the
wolf is more vast and more dangerous
than anything could possibly be it is
bigger than the Sun bigger than the moon
Odin thrusts into its mouth with his
spear but one snap of fenrir's Jaws and
the spear is gone another bite and a
crunch and a swallow
and Odin the all father greatest and
wisest of all the gods
is gone as well never to be seen again
Odin's son Vida the silent God the
reliable God
will watch his father die
Fida will stride forward as fenrir
gloats over Odin's death and thrust his
foot into the wolf's lower jaw
vidar's two feet are different one of
them has a normal shoe on it the other
wears a shoe that has been constructed
since the dawn of time
it is assembled from all the bits of
leather that people cut from the toes
and the heels when they make shoes for
themselves and throw away
if you want to help the Acer in the
final battle you should throw away your
leather scraps all thrown out scraps and
trimmings from shoes will become part of
vidar's shoe
this shoe will hold the Great Wolf's
lower jaw down so it cannot move then
with one hand Vidar will reach up and
grasp the wolf's upper jaw and rip its
mouth apart
in this way fenrir will die
and so Vida will avenge his father
on the battlefield called vigrith the
gods will fall in battle with the frost
Giants and the frost chants will fall in
battle with the Gods
the undead troops from hell will litter
the ground in their final deaths and the
noble einharya will lie beside them on
The Frozen Ground all of them dead for
the last time beneath the lifeless Misty
Sky never to rise again never to wake
and fight
of Loki's Legions only Loki himself will
still be standing bloodied and wild eyed
with a satisfied smile on his scarred
lips
Heimdall The Watcher on the bridge the
gatekeeper of the Gods will also not
have fallen
he will stand on the battlefield his
sword huvath wet and bloody in his hand
they walk toward each other across
viegriff treading on corpses wading
Through Blood and Flames to reach each
other
ah Loki will say
The muddy-backed Watchmen of the Gods he
woke the gods too late tender was it not
delightful to watch them die one by one
Loki will watch Angel's face looking for
weakness looking for emotion but hindel
will remain impassive
nothing to say Heimdall of the nine
mothers
when I was bound beneath the ground with
the Serpent's poison dripping into my
face with poor siggins standing beside
me trying to catch what Venom she could
in her Bowl bound in the darkness in the
intestines of my son all that kept me
from Madness was thinking of this moment
rehearsing it in my mind Imagining the
days when my beautiful children and I
would end the time of the Gods and end
the world
heimdel will still say nothing but he
will strike and strike hard his sword
crashing against Loki's armor and Loki
will counter and Loki will attack with
fierceness and intelligence and Glee
as they fight they will remember a time
they battled long ago when the world was
simpler
they had fought in animal form
transformed into seals competing to
obtain the necklace of the breezings
Loki had stolen it from freyja at Odin's
request and hendel had retrieved it
Loki never forgets an insult
they will fight and Slash and stab and
hack at each other they will fight and
they will fall heimdel and Loki fall
beside each other each mortally wounded
it is done
Whispers Loki dying on the battlefield
I won
but Heimdall will grin then in death
grin threw golden teeth flecked with
spittle and with blood
I can see further than you
hemdal will tell Loki
Odin's son Vida killed your son Fenris
wolf and Vida survives
and so does Odin's Sun Valley his
brother
Thor is dead but his children magni and
Morty still live
they took mjolnir from their father's
cold hand
they're strong enough and Noble enough
to wield it
none of this matters the world is
burning
says Loki The Mortals are dead midgard
is destroyed I have won
I can see further than you can Loki
I can see all the way to the world tree
hemdel will tell him with his last
breath
certa's fire cannot touch the world tree
and two people have hidden themselves
safely in the trunk of igdrasal
the woman is called life
the man is called life's yearning
their descendants will populate the
Earth
it is not the end
there is no end
it is simply the end of the old times
Loki and the beginning of the new times
rebirth always follows death
you have failed
Loki would say something something
cutting and clever and hurtful but his
life will have gone
and all his Brilliance and all his
cruelty and he will say nothing not ever
again
he will lie still and cold beside
Heimdall on the Frozen Battlefield
now certa the burning giant who was
there before the beginning of all things
looks out at the vast plane of death and
raises his bright sword to the heavens
there will be a sound like a thousand
forests turning to Flame
and the air itself will begin to burn
the world will be cremated in searches
Flames the flooding oceans Steam
the last fires rage and Flicker and then
are extinguished black ash will fall
from the sky like snow
in the Twilight where Loki and
heimdall's bodies once lay beside each
other nothing can be seen but two heaps
of gray Ash on the blackened Earth the
smoke mingling with the mist of the
morning
nothing will remain of the armies of the
living and of the dead of the dreams of
the Gods and The Bravery of their
Warriors nothing but Ash
soon after the swollen ocean will
swallow the ashes as it washes across
all the land and everything living will
be forgotten under the sunless sky
that is how the worlds will end in Ash
and flood in darkness and in ice
that is the final destiny of the Gods
two
that is the end
but there is also what will come after
the end
from the gray Waters of the ocean the
green earth will arise once more
the sun will have been eaten but the
son's daughter will shine in the place
of her mother and the new sun will shine
even more brightly than the old shine
with young light and new
the woman and the man life and life's
yearning will come out from inside the
ash tree that holds the worlds together
they will feed upon the dew on the Green
Earth and they will make love and from
their Love Will Spring mankind
Asgard will be gone but ithavul will
stand where Asgard once stood Splendid
and continual
Odin's Sons Vida and Valley
will arrive in ethavul
next will come Thor's Sons Morty and
magni
they will bring me all near between them
because now that Thor is gone it will
take two of them to carry it
Boulder and hod will return from the
underworld
and the six of them will sit in the
light of the new Sun
and talk among themselves remembering
Mysteries and discussing what could have
been done differently and whether the
outcome of the game was inevitable
they will talk of fenrir the wolf that
ate the world and of the mid-guard
serpent
and they will remember Loki who was of
the Gods yet not of them who saved the
gods and who would have destroyed them
and then balder will say
hey
what's that
what
asks magni
there glittering in the long grass
do you see it
and there
look it's another of them
they go down on their knees then in the
long grass the Gods like children
magni Thor's son is the first to find
one of the things in the long grass and
once he finds it he knows what it is
it is a golden chess piece the kind the
gods played with when the gods still
lived it is a tiny golden carving of
Odin the all-father on his High Throne
the king
they find more of them
here is Thor holding his hammer there is
Handel his horn at his lips frigg Odin's
wife is the queen
Boulder holds up a little golden statue
that one looks like you Morty tells him
it is me
says Boulder it is me long ago before I
died when I was of the Acer
they will find other pieces in the grass
some beautiful
some less so
here half buried in the black soil a
Loki and his monstrous children
there is a frost Giant
here is Serta his face all a flame
soon they will find they have all the
pieces they could ever need to make a
full chess set
they arranged the pieces into a chess
game
on the tabletop chessboard the gods of
Asgard face their Eternal enemies the
new minted sunlight glints from the
golden Chessmen on this perfect
afternoon
Boulder will smile
like the sun coming out and reach down
and he will move his first piece
and the game begins anew
thank you